SERVICES COMMITTEE WILL COME TO
ORDER IN RESPONSE TO THE COMMON
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLICLY JUST
LEADERS AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES. AND COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED. MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO ONE OR TWO HEARING ROOMS TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING. REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR WEBSITE. IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. ONE
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE THREE. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN ZERO FIVE
SIX NINE OH NINE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES STYLE MARKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY MODERATOR.
TO DIAL ONE BEEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THIS
CAN BE SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER. HE
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE
A MUTED AND YOU ARE NOT READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING. THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND IN.
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE. OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS NEEDED.
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT HEARINGS AND AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LATIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WERE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL PATIENTS
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARING. TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS CLEANING
PARTICLES WE WILL INSTITUTE
TIME LIMITS ON TESTIMONY.
ACCORDINGLY WITNESS. IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION WILL BE LIMITED
TO THREE MINUTES EACH. ALL
OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY
DURING PUBLIC COMMENT. SOME OF
THE COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE ON THE MEASURES. WE
HAVE TWENTY BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA SIX BILLS ARE ON
CONSENT. THOSE BILLS ARE AB
THREE ONE SEVEN FOR PATTERSON
AB EIGHT SIX FIVE BY QUICK
SILVA. AND AB TEN FIFTY ONE BY
BENNETT. AB TEN FIFTY FIVE A
ROMMEL'S AB TWELVE NINETY FOUR
QUIRK IN AB THIRTEEN TWENTY SIX
BY ARAMBULA. ADDITIONALLY WE
HAVE A FEW ITEMS THAT WILL BE
TAKEN UP OUT OF ORDER. AGENDA-ITEM FIFTEEN. AB EIGHT THIRTEEN
WILL BE PRESENTED IMMEDIATELY
FOLLOWING AB TWENTY TWO. BOTH
BILLS WILL BE PRESENTED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AGENDA ITEM FOR BY SB
SIX SIX FIVE WITH ONE OF OUR
SIERRA WILL BE PRESENTED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAMOS
IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING SOMETHING
MEMBER ARMS AS PRESENTATION OF
HIS BILL AB TWO TWO SIX. LET'S
START WITH. LET'S LET'S START
WITHOUT. ASSUMPTION OF CORN
JUST YET I'D LIKE TO REMIND
MEMBERS. THAT. AT TWO USER
MICROPHONES WHEN- WHEN THEY
SPEAK BUT AT THE MOMENT GIVEN
THAT WE DON'T HAVE AN
ESTABLISHED FORMAL- GO HEAD TO
BEGIN WITH. AT THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
SOAP OPERAS WE HAVE AB TWENTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER KEVIN
MCCARTY. GIVING YOUR COLLEAGUE
I ADVICE BECAUSE I ALSO GOT THE
EYE SURGERY LAST YEAR SO
IMPORTANT LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
ON. YES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
I- I'M HERE TO PRESENT MY BILL
AB TWENTY TWO AND ALSO AS YOU
AS YOU NOTED SUMMER MULLINS
BILL NEXT AT FIRST AB TWENTY
TWO. YEAH SO THIS BILL WAS
HEARD LAST WEEK IN EDUCATION-
COMMITTEE AS WELL. AND THANK
YOU FOR HEARING IT TODAY- THIS
IS ABOUT EXPANDING ACCESS TO
EARLY EDUCATION FOR
CALIFORNIANS WE ALL KNOW THAT
YOU SEE MATTER IS A BIG.
DIFFERENCE MAKER IN THE
TRAJECTORY OF SUCCESS FOR OUR
YOUNGEST LEARNERS- ALSO TO MAKE
SURE THAT- KIDS DO WELL IN LIFE
AND ALSO AND END UP A LESS
LIKELY TO BE IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM KIDS WHO GO TO A
HIGH QUALITY EARLY EDUCATION.
BUT WE KNOW IT'S SUPER
EXPENSIVE FOR TOO MANY OF OUR
FAMILIES PRIVATE CARE IS
EXPENSIVE AND SUBSIDIZED CARE
AS WAITING LISTS. HOW YOU CAN
BE A FAMILY IN THE MIDDLE ON
SOME OF THESE COMMUNITIES WORK
LET'S SAY YOU MAKE BETWEEN YOU
KNOW FIFTEEN SEVENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND YOU'RE TOO RICH TO
GET. THE FREE AND YOU'RE REALLY
TWO PARTS TO PAY THE TUITION
EQUIVALENT TO WHAT IT COST TO
GO TO UC BERKELEY OR SO. TO GO
TO A MONTHLY FULL DAY PRE K.
PROGRAM AND THIS BILL BEFORE US
WILL GIVE- FREE HIGH QUALITY
PRE K. FOR ALL FOUR YEAR OLDS
THROUGH TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN. AT WE DO KNOW
THAT T. K. ALREADY EXIST FOR
ABOUT A FOURTH OF THE KIDS IN
CALIFORNIA. WHO HAPPENED TO BE
LUCKY IN BORN IN THE FALL BUT
THIS WOULD MAKE IT UNIVERSALLY
ACCESSIBLE FOR EVERYBODY AND-
WHAT THIS MEANS IN CONJUNCTION
WITH OUR STATE BUDGET AND OTHER
PIECES. IS WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY TRANSFORM
EARLY CARE EDUCATION IN
CALIFORNIA- WITH THIS PLUS THE
INCREASE IN SLOTS IN THE BUDGET
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A HALF A
MILLION NEW STATE FUNDED.
ACCESS LOTS FOR ZERO THREE FIVE
YEAR OLDS TO GET EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION ABOUT A FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT THIS YEAR NEW
MONEY FOR THIS- BUT THIS IS
PART OF AN OVERALL PACKAG AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER THE DIGITAL
SLOTS. WITH THE EVER ELUSIVE
RATE REFORMS. TO MAKE SURE
THESE PROGRAMS ARE APPLE FUNDED
AND WE CAN PAY THE- FOR. A
LIVING WAGE- SO THIS IS A PIECE
OF THE PUZZLE. I WEEK WE HAVE
HEARD THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION. LOUD AND CLEAR
SO WE'RE ADDRESSING SOME OF
THESE ISSUES FOCUSING ON-
PARENT CHOICE MAKING SURE THAT.
OUR PRINCIPALS AND
ADMINISTRATORS HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE TRAINING. AS WELL
AS- HAVING AN EVALUATION OF
THIS AND LASTLY MAKING SURE.
THAT WE HAVE- PROPER. THE
ENGAGEMENT- IN THE YEAR OF
TRANSITION TO MAKE SURE WE WORK
WITH EXISTING. LOCAL PLANNING
COUNCIL'S HEAD START PROGRAMS
AND COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
TO WORK COLLABORATIVE LEE AS WE
EXPAND TO K. THROUGHOUT%
CALIFORNIA I WITH ME TODAY ARE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM KIDDING GO
YOU DATA. RIOS AS WELL AS
CARMEN POLY SANDRO FROM CSEA
THANK YOU MANAGER. THANK YOU
WITH ALL THE MEMBER- KEVIN
MCCARTY- I BEFORE WE PROCEED
I'D LIKE TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
SO CONSULTANT IF YOU CAN PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. HER TITLE. HERE
JONES. COURTESY YOUR PROTECT
THE PRESIDENT CALM WATER. FROM
LONGER PRESENT PAN. M. PRESENT
AND WITH A QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED AND. YOU MAY
PROCEED WITH OUR LEAD WITNESS
NUMBER ONE GET THE DRUG DEAL SO
SHE ON THE TELEPHONE. SHE'S
WITH US TODAY. REAL PERSON ALL
RIGHT YES REAL WITNESS. WELCOME.
I THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS JENNY THAT VIDEOS I
AM A SAID THAT THE DOCTOR AND
TEACHER OF GIVING A MINUTE
PHYSICAL IN SAN JOSE I HAVE
BEEN A PRESCHOOL TEACHER FOR
FIVE YEARS I HAVE SIXTEEN YEARS
OF EXPERIENCE WORKING WITH
CHILDREN AND THEIR FAMILIES. I
DECIDED TO BECOME A PRESCHOOL
TEACHER BECAUSE I ENJOYED OF
FACILITATING CHILDREN'S EARLY
YEARS OF DEVELOPMENT AND I SEE
MYSELF AS I GO TO THE OTHER
NAMES BECOMING ANOTHER CHILD
LOOK AT LOOK AT IT WAS NOT AN
EASY JOURNEY FOR ME IT WAS VERY
DIFFICULT FINANCIALLY
ESPECIALLY WHEN OPINION MIGHT
BE A- I DO NOT QUALIFY FOR
FINANCIAL AID. BECAUSE I WAS
WORKING FULL TIME SO I HAD TO
PAY FOR EVERYTHING OUT OF
POCKET I DIDN'T PURSUE MY GOAL
TO BECOME MY QUE TO OUR FUTURE
BECAUSE IN ORDER TO GET A
TEACHING CREDENTIAL I HAD TO
QUIT MY PERMANENT JOB I KEEP ON
GOAL AND I COULDN'T AFFORD TO
DO THAT. YET KNOWING THAT I CAN
MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN CHILDREN'S
LIVES I MADE SURE THAT I
COMPLETED MY BA IN CHILD
DEVELOPMENT I AM ALSO. THE
FIRST GRADUATING MY FARMING.
CHILDREN BENEFIT FROM A TWENTY.
BECAUSE THIS- OPENS UP MORE
THAN. ON MY TV WITH PEERS THAT
H. THE WENT BACK. ALSO HAVE
MORE. ON FOR ONE ONE THAT THE
INSURANCE. WANTED TO CAN HANDLE
MORE. THREE AND GAY GOOD X. ON.
WE KNOW CHINA WILL HAVE A
QUALITY. CLICK CAPITA OUTCOME.
FREE PRE K. ALSO HERE'S
FAMILIES FINANCIALLY. DEVASTATE
EXPANSIVE UTK IT WOULD MEAN I
NEED FOR MORE QUALIFIED
TEACHERS WITH EASY EXPERIENCE.
THE BEST OPPORTUNITY COMES TO.
FRUITION PRESCHOOL TEACHERS
WOULD WANT TO PER SO I TEACH
ACTIVATION FORTY KATE. MY
CREATED NOT BY THE WAY FOR
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATORS LIKE
MYSELF. WOULD ALLOW US TO FOR
FOOD. SB NATION'S. SO WE CAN
CONTINUE HELPING CHILDREN HAVE
A HEALTHY DEVELOPMENT FOR
PROVIDING. DIFFERENTLY FOR LACK
OF A MAKE OPPORTUNITIES TO
IMPROVE IS CALLED READY NEXT. I
WOULD ALSO BE ABLE TO EARN A
HIGHER SALARY. AND THAT IS WHY
I SUPPORT AB. TWENTY TWO. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION. THANK
YOU. AND OUR NEXT WE WOULDN'T
ARE OF THE SONS. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR HER TITLE GOOD TO SEE YOU
AGAIN GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CARMEN ALESSANDRO I
LIVE IN SANGER CALIFORNIA AND
I'M A CONSTITUENT OF YOUR
DISTRICT MISATO. I AM ALSO A
MEMBER OF C. C. BOARD OF
DIRECTORS AND I HAVE BEEN A
CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEE FOR
THIRTY THREE YEARS. CCA IS CO
SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY TWO I WILL
FOCUS MY TESTIMONY TODAY ON
ADDRESSING SOME WORKFORCE
CONCERNS. WE REPRESENT
PRESCHOOL AND HEAD START
TEACHERS AND EDUCATORS AS WELL
AS MEMBERS AND T. K. AND
KINDERGARTEN. ONE OF THE
CONCERNS WE'VE HEARD IS THAT
UNIVERSAL T. CABLE CROWD OUT
EXISTING PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS WE
DO NOT BELIEVE THAT WILL HAPPEN
OR ARE MEMBERS IN PRESCHOOL AND
HEAD START WILL BE DISPLACED.
IN FACT THERE ARE SO MANY
ELIGIBLE CHILDREN ZERO TO THREE
WHO CAN. BE AND WILL BE SERVED
BY PRESCHOOL AND HEAD START
POINT FOR YOUR ROLES ARE BEING
SERVED BY T. K. THERE IS NO
SHORTAGE OF ELIGIBLE STUDENTS
WHICH MEANS THERE IS PLENTY OF
IMPORTANT WORK FOR OUR MEMBERS
TO DO. AB TWENTY TWO IS GOING
TO PROVIDE MORE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR YOUNG STUDENTS AND FOR OUR
MEMBERS SPECIFICALLY THE LOWER
RATIO WILL BENEFIT INDIVIDUAL
STUDENT NEEDS AND- REQUIRE THE
ASSISTANCE OF PARA EDUCATOR IN
THE TKA CLASSROOM. THIS WILL
ADD ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
FOR EXPERIENCED EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATORS TO MOVE INTO THE T.
K. CLASSROOM IF THEY CHOOSE OR-
THEY CAN CHOOSE TO STAY IN
PRESCHOOL OR HEAD START
PROGRAMS. EXPANDING TK'S GOING
TO EXPAND OPPORTUNITIES WE NOT
ONLY SUPPORT OUR MEMBERS IN
THEIR JOBS BUT WE ALSO SUPPORT
STUDENT OPPORTUNITIES AND STAFF
INVESTMENT OPPORTUNITIES THAT
IMPROVE THE LIVELIHOODS OF OUR
MEMBERS. AS MENTIONED I WORKED
IN PUBLIC EDUCATION FOR MANY
YEARS. THE TEACHER SHORTAGE
ISRAEL THE PARA EDUCATOR
SHORTAGE IS REAL BUT THE WORK
IS STILL THERE. THIS IMPORTANT
WORK STILL NEEDS TO BE DONE OUR
MEMBERS ARE THERE TO FOSTER AND
SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS ON THEIR
EDUCATIONAL JOURNEY WITH T. K.
BEING A CRITICAL COMPONENT IN
THE EARLY YEARS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR GABLE ON AB TWENTY
TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY- WILL BE
MOVING ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT AND
SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OR THREE. AND OKAY ASSENAGON
MOVING ON TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
NUMBER AS WELL I WILL BE MOVING
ON TO TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY
TWO. IF YOU ARE SUPPORTING AB
TWENTY TWO PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE. IN
EIGHTEEN T. SPECIALIST WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER. WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS NICOLE
FOREMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE TWO
ZERO ONE. YES GOOD MORNING OR
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS ERIC HER
DISABILITY RIGHT CAL IN STRONG
SUPPORT. LINE. TO TWENTY TWO.
GOOD AFTERNOON PATTY HER ON
BEHALF OF EARLY EDUCATION
FORMULA A PROUD CO SPONSOR OF
AB TWENTY TWO IN SUPPORT. BLIND.
TO THIRTY TWO. A GOOD
AFTERNOON- HAPPY THEN OFTEN
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
CALIFORNIA IMPORT. LINE. TWO
THIRTY FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON
CALLING BCK FROM YOU HAVE THE
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND THE PART. BLIND.
ONE EIGHTY SIX. WE'VE LOST NINE
ONE EIGHTY SIX IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO RE QUEUE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWO THIRTY. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JEFF FLOCK
OF REPRESENTING THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS IN SUPPORT. BLIND. TO
TWENTY ONE. JONATHAN HOWARD
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION ON BEHALF THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE ONE
NINETY SEVEN. SH GOOD AFTERNOON
AND TO GET RIDE SHOWN- PROUD CO
SPONSOR ON BEHALF OF SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED AND IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE NO FOR
THE LINES IN Q. THANK YOU
HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS WILL NOW FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS TO HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE TO.
WELL ACTUALLY HAVE A LOOK AT
LEAD WITNESS IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL AND WILL BEGIN- BOB
BY CHOOSING KISHA. KISHA WE
VISIT THIS SPENDING. PROCEED
YOU HAPPY NEW YEAR- MY FELLOW-
WAIT WAIT A MINUTE- LET ME
CONTACT JACQUI JOB INTERVIEW
UNEXPECTEDLY DURING THE TIME
PERIOD I'M GOING TO BE HER
WORDS AND I FOLLOW WITH MY
MONEY I'M AT A DIFFERENT TIME A
CAR DON'T KNOW WHO THE MOTHER
EDUCATOR. AND EDUCATIONAL
RESEARCHER. DURING THE SUMMER
NINE. I WOULD SINGLE MOTHER
CHOI CHU YEAR OLD I'M- AND THE
MIDST OF COMPLETING MY DOCTORAL
DEGREE FROM UC BERKELEY
GRADUATE SCHOOL OF EDUCATION.
THE OVERBURDEN AFTER NOT HAVING
ABLE CHILD CARE. TO BE ABLE TO
WORK TO COMPLETE MY DOCTORAL
DEGREE NEGATIVELY IMPACTED MY
HEALTH. I CALLED MY LOCAL
REPORTER PRO AGENCY BANANAS
EACH DAY WITH THE HOPE I WOULD
MOVE UP THE WAITING LIST FOR
AFFORDABLE CHILDCARE. ON THE
BRIDGE OF LOSING HOPE I WOULD
BLESSED HAVING A SPOT AVAILABLE
FOR SUBSIDIZED CHILD CARE FOR
MY DYING ACT AND YOU'LL BE ACT.
HOUSING AFFORDABLE DEPENDABLE
CHILD CARE WAS.
TRANSFORMATIONAL BROWN. IT
SHOULD BE THAT IS THE ME OKAY
BECAUSE NOT A PROVIDE A LOVING.
WARM AND EDUCATIONAL WHERE MY
THANK YOU DRIVE OKAY ALSO COULD
HOME MEAL AND CALL THE TEACHERS.
THE IRISH IT'S ONE OF THE.
PORTABLE BILINGUAL. WHAT MAKES
JANET. OUR FAMILIES WHICH
INCLUDES YOUR ID THAT'S UP MOST
IMPORTANT ME. HAVING ACCESS TO
BLANK. WHAT TIME YOUR LONG CO
IN ME TO RETURN TO TEACHING THE
COLLEGE LEVEL I KNOW PHD ENERGY.
FROM UNDER MY PROCEDURE AND- I
RESTORED AT A P. MOREOVER I
COPPING THAT WOULD BE THAT IT
PROVIDING MY SPEND WITH
SUPPLIER AND CAL NEEDS TO BE
READY FOR KINDERGARTEN. PASSING
YOU TWENTY TWO WAS WHEN THE
CHILD CARE ON FOR OTHER. AND
THE CALLER MORE WARRIORS IN
AMERICAN. I THINK AB TWO THE
MAN. PRESS THE BLACK AND GRAY
MOTHER THANK YOU CHOICES DON'T
MATTER THANK YOU DON'T. THERE
ARE THOUSANDS OF PARENTS ON THE
WAY TO LIST FOR A CARE. WE'RE
NOT GETTING IT WHO CAN AFFORD.
OPERATING ACROSS CARE YOU OLD
THE ONLY INTRODUCED. BEEF PATTY.
PAGE WE ARE BECAUSE IT LONG-
YOU THAT CAN BASED. THE
PROVIDER DON'T WE DEVELOPING
MENTAL FOR REPAIR THEM FIRST.
MALAYALEE A DANGEROUS IT DIDN'T
BENEFIT ALL MODELS WORK FOR
CHILDREN FAMILIES AT THE FIRST.
IT SUCH APPROACHES FOR THE COOL
LEAGUE FIVE. EMBEDDED IN OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM COMBINED GET
THEIR COMMUNITY AND FAMILIES OF
COLOR. IF OUR DESIRES THE
MESSAGE OF WHAT OTHER. DIVERSE
GROUP WHO IN THE FAMILY AND
COMMUNITIES COLLEGE AND WE NEED
TO CLOSE. IT IS ABOUT IMPACTS
READ THEM WORKING BASED EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION OPTION.
THANK ENJOY THE THAT WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE DíAS YOU TO VOTE
NO ON AB TWO. AND WORK TOWARD A
TRULY. MAKE THE RIVER APPLE
PRESCHOOL AND EASY EITHER THANK.
ANY HEALTHCARE PROVIDER TO
SACRIFICE. THEIR OWN LIVES
HISTORY I KEEP THE LOWEST WAGES
USUALLY BUT NOT. WHAT ABOUT
ELEVEN CARE AND EDUCATION TO
OUR YOUNGEST CHILDREN.
UNIVERSAL G. K. TO BE LIGHT
LAGER LAND AND WILL BENEFIT
MANY CHILDREN BUT AT THIS POINT
WE'RE DEBATING HOW BEST
IMPLEMENTED. ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY A UNIVERSAL TICKET
CHARGES THAT WORK. AND THOSE
THAT DON'T. DESCRIBE IT BETWEEN
TWO TO NOT MEET THE OF OUR OF
CHILDREN AND THEIR- WHAT ABOUT
CHILD CARE. ONLY THAT BUT
BECAUSE THAT JUMPED OUT BURKE.
THE POOR. PART HI YEARS PRE
LOOK. L. E. A. K. BID GOODBYE.
OF IT AND THINK YOU EVER SPOKE
SHE AS THE SCRIBING BETWEEN.
WITHOUT THE NEEDS OF THE SOUTH
THE CHILL AND FAMILY TO THE
AFFORDABLE CARE. OTHERS
CRITICAL MATCH EDUCATE AND
MISSED THAT WOULD READ THEM ONE
AT. A DIFFERENT TIME CHOI ARE
YOU THERE. WEEK AB TWENTY TWO.
R. AND EXCELLING WEEK THAT ON
PART. CRITICAL FOR CHILDREN
ACCESS PROGRAM. ADELIDAE
BETTING. SITE EVERY CHILD CARE
HOMES. I RIGHT THEIR CHILD
FAMILY. AB TWO TWO TWENTY
RUSSIAN ESPECIALLY. DOCTOR
OTHER CHILDREN OF COLOR. YOU
ONLY WHICH WOULD APPLE USUL
INTO A PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM
GIVES IT BERKELEY DR. WILL
DESCRIBED AND MANY PARA IN
INCOME. URGING BECOME A GREAT.
AND BADLY AT THE LEGACY OF
RACISM PEOPLE BELIEVE SOCIAL
NEED. AND ONLY THE PUBLIC
SYSTEM OPTED.
THE PUBLIC
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE.
C. NINE WILL MOVE ON TO ROUTE
TWENTY FORTY. NONE THERE'S
WHILE AND MODERATE IF YOU CAN
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE-
TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE'LL GO FIRST TO
LINE TO THIRTY NINE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATORS PROGRAM A
CARBOXYL ELLIOT CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION CONSORTIUM IN
OPPOSITION FOR THE READ DARI
STATED THANK. THANK YOU. ONE TO
THIRTY ONE. DAVIDSON WITH
CALIFORNIANS FOR QUALITY EARLY
LEARNING WE ASK YOU TO OPPOSE
THIS EXCLUSIONARY BILL WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL THANK YOU.
NINE ONE EIGHTY SIX. GOOD
AFTERNOON CREAM OVER THE TA
CARE LAWCENTER WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL ONLY ASKING ABOUT NOW.
THANK YOU. NINE TO ELEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS TATUM ADLER WITH THE
INTERNET BY VOTERS ON BEHALF OF
THE LEARNING CARE GROUP THE
SECOND LARGEST FOR PROFIT CHILD%
CARE PROVIDER IN NORTH AMERICA
IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY TWO.
THANK YOU. LINE. TO FOURTEEN.
NUMANTIA SENATORS PACIFIC
ISLANDERS FROM THE CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS ONCE COUNTY MURDER
GROUP OF A HUNDRED LOCATIONS
ABOUT FIFTEEN THOUSAND FAMILIES
THAT WE SERVICE WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU. MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU MODERATOR.
YOU WERE REBUILDING AND
REFORMING CALIFORNIA'S CHILD
CARE DELIVERY SYSTEM HAS BEEN A
MAJOR LEGISLATIVE ISSUES THIS
YEAR. I AM PLEASED THAT THE
ISSUES GIVEN THE ATTENTION THAT
IT DESERVES BECAUSE LAST YEAR
HAS BEEN PARTICULARLY DIFFICULT
FOR CHILD CARE PROVIDERS AND
FOR THE FAMILIES THAT NEED
CHILD CARE. WE'VE LOST SO MANY
PROVIDERS WHICH IS MAKING IT
DIFFICULT FOR PARENTS TO RETURN
TO WORK. AND WORKING FAMILIES
NEED CHILD CARE THAT IS AGE AND
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
AFFORDABLE MEETS OR CULTURAL
LINGUISTIC NEEDS AND IS
AVAILABLE DURING THE PARENTS
WORKING HOURS AND OF COURSE OUR
PROVIDERS DESERVE TO BE
COMPENSATED AT A FAIR RATE. THE
MAJOR THE MAJOR PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL BRINGING FOUR YEAR
OLDS INTO TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN HAVE BEEN
NEGOTIATED IN THE BUDGET. I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S RECENT
EFFORTS TO BUILT IN PROTECTIONS
FOR FAMILIES AND FOR PROVIDERS
WHILE I REMAIN CONCERNED WITH
BE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF
THE MAJOR CHANGE IN OUR CHILD
CARE DELIVERY SYSTEM. I AM
ENCOURAGED THAT THIS IS JUST
ONE PIECE OF LARGER EFFORTS TO
REFORM THE CHILD CARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM INCLUDING CHANGES IN
PROVIDER RATE AND FAMILY FEES.
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
TODAY- THERE ARE A LOT OF
MOVING PARTS HERE ALL WHILE THE
CHILD CARE DELIVERY SYSTEM IS
RECOVERING FROM THE IMPACTS OF
COVE IN NINETEEN. I WANT TO
STRESS THAT WE NEED TO PROCEED
WITH CAUTION AND MONITOR THE
OVERALL IMPACT OF THESE CHANGES
WHAT THAT'S AT ALL- BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND I KNOW I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY ALSO HEAR THE SPELL
AND EDUCATION COMMITTEE- BUT
SINCE THIS IS A NEW COMMITTEE-
YOU KNOW I. NOW WE'RE HEARING
FROM PEOPLE THE CHILD CARE
COMMUNITY WHO ARE WORRIED THAT-
BASICALLY AT LEAST BASED ON
ANALYSIS THAT THIS WOULD.
BASICALLY REMOVE- THE CHILDREN
WHO ARE FOR AN OLDER FROM CHILD
CARE BUT YET I ALSO NOTED THAT
THE BILL VERY EXPLICITLY SAYS-
THAT- THAT WE WILL BE YOU KNOW
PROTECTING THAT CHOICE AND-
AND- THIS IS AN OPTION IT'S
OPTIONAL IT'S NOT REQUIRED SO-
PERHAPS IN A NEW THAT AND SOME
RECORDING YOUR CHAIR OF THE OF
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION FOR THE ASSEMBLY. CAN
YOU HELP US PUT US INTO THIS
THE LARGER CONTEXT OF THE
BUDGET WHAT WE'RE DOING FOR ECA
OVERALL- AND HOW THIS FITS INTO
THIS LARGER. IT IS THIS LARGER
CONTEXT. THANK YOU SENATOR PAN
I THINK OUR CHAIR KIND OF SAID
IT WELL THAT THIS IS A PIECE OF
THE LARGER PUZZLE. AND IF THIS
WAS THE ONLY PIECE IT WOULD BE
PROBLEMATIC IT'S ALWAYS BEENA
QUEST TO ME AND OTHER
SUPPORTERS HAVE UNIVERSAL
ACCESS FOR FOUR YEAR OLDS. BUT
IF WE WERE DOING THIS WITHOUT
INCREASING RATES AND FOCUSING
ON ON SLOTS. AND EXPANDING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PROVIDERS TO
SERVE ZERO THREE THREE WITH THE
INCREASE RATE STRUCTURE AND
MORE SLOTS. THAT WOULD NOT WORK
TOGETHER BUT- IT THE BUT YOU'RE
RIGHT IF THE IF THERE'S A
FAMILY THAT THAT LIKE THE
WITNESS SAID EARLIER THE
OPPOSITION THEY LIKE THIS. I
THINK THE SAID- A BI LINGUAL-
PROGRAM THAT FITS THEIR NEEDS
AND IF THEIR INCOME ELIGIBLE
FAMILY. YOU KNOW FIRST OF ALL
THAT FAMILIES FOR SO THEY'RE
GONNA BE GOING ON TO CANDOR AND
FIRST BY TIMES BILLS
IMPLEMENTED. BUT IF THERE IS A
TWO YEAR OLD THE WORLD TODAY
THAT WANTS TO GO TO THIS TYPE
OF PROGRAM. AND THEY'RE
ELIGIBLE THEY CAN CONTINUE
CONTINUE TO DO THAT WE PUT IT
IN. OUR BILL THAT INCOME
ELIGIBLE FAMILIES CAN CONTINUE
TO DO SO- WHAT THIS REALLY
MEANS IS FAMILIES THAT TODAY
HAVE NO OPTIONS. THERE TO-
BRIDGE TO GET FREE BECAUSE THEY
MAKE YOU KNOW SIXTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS BUT IN OUR
AREAS ACROSS THE STATE. THOSE
FAMILIES ARE STRUGGLING PAYING
THE RENT IN THEIR BILLS AND-
THEY DON'T GET THE SUBSIDIZED
PROGRAM THEY CAN'T AFFORD THE
FREE SO THEY WOULD NOW GET AN
OPTION. TO GO TO T. K. WE ALSO
HAVE- ANOTHER COMPANION BILL
THAT WAS HEARD. IN THIS
COMMITTEE A FEW. MONTHS AGO BY
SEN EARLY MON SB FIFTY WHICH
WOULD SHIFT ALL THE MONEY THAT
CURRENTLY GOES. TO SERVE FOUR
YEAR OLDS AND STATE PRESCHOOL
AND GIVE THOSE TO PROVIDERS TO
SERVE MORRISON THREE ZERO THREE
THREE. SO WHAT DOES THAT MEAN
THAT MEANS FOR OUR LOWEST
INCOME. AND MOST VULNERABLE
THREE TWO AND THREE AND FOUR
YEAR OLDS IN CALIFORNIA THEY
WOULD GET TWO YEARS. OF TOP
QUALITY FREE PRE K. IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS A ON WHICH
WE KNOW THE DIFFERENCE MAKER
WHICH WOULD. ADDRESS THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP. AND THEN
LASTLY I THINK THE ELEPHANT IN
THE ROOM IS WE'RE STILL
STRUGGLING TO FINALIZE THE
STATE BUDGET. I THINK THERE ARE
LIKE LITERALLY THREE ISSUES
THAT WERE STILL. NEGOTIATING
THE SPEAKER AND THE PRO TEM
ALONG WITH THE GOVERNOR. AND I
THINK THE TOP ONE IS THIS ISSUE
OPERATE REFORM. SO WE DID PUT
MONEY IN THE BUDGET. TWO WEEKS
AGO ON MONDAY BOTH HOUSES. OUR
LAST MONDAY I GUESS IT WAS. ON
TO FIND GREAT REFORM. BUT WE
HAVE TO HAVE A COMPANION BILL
EITHER A TRAILER BILL OR CENTER
LAID HIS BILL. TO SET THOSE
PIECES INACTION IN MOTION TO
MAKE TO MAKE TWO TO AUTHORIZE
IT. SO IN IN TILL WE GET THAT
DONE I THINK THE CHILD CARE.
RULES I K. DON'T TELL ME SHE
CHAU THAT YOU'RE GOING TO DO
ALL THESE OTHER. RIGHT SO- AND
I WOULD SAY IS WE'RE WE'RE
GONNA WRAP THE BUDGET UP SOON
AND THIS IS A PRIORITY OF OUR-
LEADERS IN EACH HOUSE SAYING
WE'RE NOT GOING TO SHUT DOWN
OUR BUDGET PROCESS UNTIL THIS
ISSUE IS DONE. SO YOU KNOW THIS
ISSUE IS GOING THROUGH THE-
PUBLIC THIS COMMUNITY DAY THAN
APPROACH ON THE FLOOR SO. I
THINK IN A FEW WEEKS WILL HAVE
MORE CLARITY. AND THAT THIS
WHOLE- PACKAGE I THINK WILL
ADDRESS. THESE ISSUES AND THEN
LASTLY I SAID THIS EARLIER NOW
I'M RAMBLING ON MADAM CHAIR.
BUT WE HAVE BEEN MEETING WITH
THE OPPOSITION FOR WEEKS IF NOT
MONTHS IF NOT. A COUPLE YEARS
ON THIS TOPIC. AND WE REALLY
HAVE HEARD SOME OF THEIR
CONCERNS AND PUT THEM IN. THIS
BILL AND THE TRAILER BILL AND
SO I'M- I'M COMMITTED AND WE
ALREADY HAVE- CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH WITH THE- CHILD CARE FIELD
TO MAKE SURE AS THIS IS
IMPLEMENTED. WE LEAVE NOBODY
BEHIND. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I
WOULD ALSO MAKE NOTE THAT.
OBVIOUSLY IS BEING HEARD AND
POLICY COMMITTEE BUT IT WOULD
ACTUALLY GET TO THE FLOOR UNTIL
ESSENTIALLY. AUGUST RIGHT
BECAUSE IT HAVE TO GO TO
APPROPRIATIONS AND SO FORTH SO
THOSE BUDGET PANEL BUDGET
DISCUSSIONS. HOPEFULLY WILL BE
RESOLVED BEFORE WE SEE THIS ON
THE- BACK ON THE FLOOR AND-
ASSURE YOU MAKE WHATEVER
ADJUSTMENTS NECESSARY. AT THAT
POINT SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
SUMMARY. SENATOR KAMLAGER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I WANT TO
ECHO- MANY OF THE COMMENTS THAT
CAME FROM THE DYESS AND WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR CONTINUING
TO BE A CHAMPION- FOR FOUR YEAR
OLDS WE TALKED ABOUT THIS BILL
AND I DID SAY THAT I WAS- GOING
TO SUPPORT IT BUT I ALSO SHARED
WITH YOU- A LOT OF CONCERNS
THAT I HAVE COMING FROM THE
CHILD CARE FIELD. YOU KNOW
DAHLE AND- IN MY DISTRICT THAT
IS IN THE EASY COMMUNITY- YOU
KNOW LIKES TO KATE IN LIKE
EIGHT YEARS AGO BEFORE I WAS IN
THIS BODY. I'M IN THEY DON'T
LIKE IT TODAY- AND- I THINK WE
HAVE TO DO A BETTER JOB
COLLECTIVELY OF ACKNOWLEDGING.
THE REAL EXPERTISE THAT EASY
PROFESSIONALS OF CARE FOR ZERO
TO THREE. ACTUALLY HAVE WHEN
EDUCATING OUR YOUNG CHILDREN.
AND ONE OF THE CONCERNS. THAT I
HAVE HEARD IS. YOU KNOW MOVING-
LARGE SWATHS OF YOUNG PEOPLE
INTO- TKA INTO SCHOOL SETTINGS
INTO FACILITIES THAT ARE REALLY
NOT OUTFITTED ARE DESIGNED TO
ACCOMMODATE THESE LITTLE FOUR
YEAR OLDS. I'M IS ALSO A REAL
ISSUE. YOU KNOW YOUNG BABIES
WHO ARE FOR THEY DON'T PEE ON
COMMAND THEY NEED TO HAVE
BATHROOMS IN THE CLASSROOMS
THERE ARE A LOT OF SORT OF YOU
KNOW- THE SETTINGS HAVE TO BE
DESIGNED TO ACCOMMODATE. YOU
KNOW THESE LITTLE PEOPLE WHO
ARE. TRANSITIONING THEMSELVES-
AND ARE USED TO DIFFERENT KINDS
OF SETTINGS. AND YOU KNOW FOR
MANY AND THIS ISN'T IN YOUR
BILL BUT FOR MANY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS WHO- WERE ON THE
FRONT LINES DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND TAKING CARE OF OUR
ESSENTIAL WORKERS WHO WORK IN.
THESE FAMILY CHILD CARE
SETTINGS. YOU KNOW FOR US TO
MOVE FORWARD ON SO MANY OTHER
THINGS AND NOT RATE REFORM IS A
SLAP IN THE FACE TO THEM. YOU
KNOW IT AND THEY CONTINUE TO BE
PUT. ON TO THE BACK OF THE BUS
AND THE OTHER REALITY IS WHICH
YOU KNOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS
THAT YOU KNOW WE DON'T WANT TO
CREATE A SYSTEM THAT SIPHONS
OFF THE FOUR YEAR OLD YOU KNOW
AND LEAVES THE HIGHEST COST.
BABIES ZERO TO THREE- IN THE
NEWS- FCC EIGHT SETTINGS
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THOSE ARE
INCREDIBLE I MEAN THEY'RE VERY
EXPENSIVE- AND THAT CAN BE A
REASON WHY. YOU KNOW DOORS ARE
FACED ARE ARE FORCED TO CLOSE.
I DON'T DEAL WITH DEPRIVE ITS-
THAT'S NOT CRYSTAL STAIRS
WASN'T A PRIVATE WE WERE
DEALING WITH SUB CITY FAMILIES
ALL THE TIME- ARM. AND FOR
RENTAL CHOICE DOESN'T REALLY
BECOME PARENTAL CHOICE WHEN THE
OPTION THAT IS FREE WHEN ALL OF
THE OPTIONS THAT ARE AVAILABLE
ARE NOT DO NOT COST THE SAME.
WHEN YOU HAVE ONE SYSTEMAX FREE
IT DOES KIND OF MANIPULATE WHAT
TRUE PARENTAL CHOICE IS. YOU
KNOW HAVING SAID ALL THAT- YOU
KNOW I DO BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
STEPPING UP TO TAKE CARE OF OUR
LITTLE PEOPLE- AND THIS IS A
PIECE OF THAT PUZZLE. BUT THOSE
FAMILIES ALSO. CAN'T REALLY
DEAL WITH PART DAY CARE YOU
KNOW THE PART DAY CARES FOR
FOLKS WHO ARE WEALTHY- WHO HAVE
SOMEONE WHO AT IN YOU KNOW IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE DAY CAN DROP
EVERYTHING I DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO WE CAN PICK UP
THE BABY. AND TAKE THEM HOME
AND CARE FOR THEM AND THOSE ARE
THE FOLKS THAT ARE IN SOUTH LA.
AND SO I HOPE THAT THESE THINGS
CAN MOVE TOGETHER SO AT THE END
OF THE DAY WE HAVE A PUZZLE
WITH ALL OF THE PIECES THAT ARE
CONNECTED. THAT PROVIDE A
HOLISTIC- MENU OF CHOICES FOR
PARENTS OF ALL ECONOMIC
BACKGROUNDS WHO ARE ABLE TO
MAKE THE BEST DECISION POSSIBLE
FOR THEIR LITTLE PEOPLE- AND
YOU KNOW I TOLD YOU THIS I
DON'T WANT TO GET IN TROUBLE
BUT YOU KNOW SOME OF OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE TO STEP UP- AND
THEY- WE SAW THAT THEY- WERE
NOT DOING WHAT THEY NEEDED TO
DURING THE PANDEMIC AS IT
RELATES TO EDUCATING- OUR YOUNG
FOLKS. YOU KNOW WHO WERE SCHOOL
AGE KIDS AND SO I WOULD REALLY
BE CHALLENGED TO OPEN UP A
SCENARIO WHERE WERE FUNNELING
OUR LITTLE BABIES INTO THE
SAME. INTO THE SAME SYSTEM SO
I'M HOPING THAT THIS IS PART OF
SOMETHING MUCH BIGGER AND MUCH
MORE COMPREHENSIVE THAT
INCLUDES RIGHT REFORM BECAUSE
IF IT DOESN'T. THEN YOU KNOW WE
HAVE WE HAVE NOT HELPED THE
PEOPLE WHO WE CONTINUE TO LEAN
ON. I MEAN. THANK YOU WE HAVE
AN- SENATOR PAN IF YOU WANNA
WRITTEN OUT ON THAT THANK YOU
FOR CAST SORRY FOR COMING BACK
ON AGAIN- BUT- WHEN THE OTHER
ISSUES I THINK AND APPRECIATES
SIR KAMAGRA BRING IT UP AND
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT I DEALT
WITH BEFORE WHEN I WAS IN- I
THINK BUDGETS OF THREE. IS THAT
IT IS WERE YOU KNOW STANDING
YOUNGER CHILDREN GO INTO
POTENTIALLY GOING INTO TJ
MENDOZA DEBATE ABOUT THE
STANDARDS OF FACILITIES AND SO
FORTH AND FEATURED A
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
SELF- SO AGAIN I THINK AS WE'RE
LOOKING AT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
PROVIDING TKA TO HELP KIDS WHO
ARE FOR- WE NEED TO BE SURE
THAT BOTH FACILITIES AND ALSO
THE STAFFING IS APPROPRIATE SO-
RECOGNIZING AS SITTING SOME THE
C. PROVIDERS FIND OUT I KNOW
YOU UNDERSTAND THE SOME MEMBERS
A CHAMPION FOR YOU SEE IS THAT.
IT'S NOT JUST IT IT'S NOT JUST
PUTTING KIDS INTO A CLASSROOM
RIGHT IT'S ABOUT FOCUSING ON OR
DEVELOPMENTAL ISSUES
SOCIALIZATION AND ALSO BE SURE
YOU HAVE A DEVELOPMENTALLY
APPROPRIATE SETTINGS AS WELL-
FOR THEM WHICH IS GONNA BE
DIFFERENT THAN THE OLDER KIDS
SO YOU JUST CAN'T A CLASSROOM
AND TURN INTO A T. T. K.
CLASSROOMS RIGHT YOU HAVE TO
YOU HAVE TO REVAMP THAT SOME
SELF- THE SAUSAGES ONE. THANK
ATIKAMEKW FOR PER THAT OUT AND
THEN JUST ONE EXPRESS- THE DEBT
I'VE- MY- OF THAT WELL BUT I
THINK IT'S A THAT CAN BE WORKED
OUT AND- BUT I HAVE MADE. YUP
THAT'S AN ISSUE THAT WE'VE
DISCUSSED BEFORE AND THE NEED
TO FOR THE TWO PERHAPS THREE
SALMON THAT AS WE MOVE TO K. TO
AGAIN. THIS YOUNGER GROUP THANK
YOU. THANK YOU DO YOU HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS NO FINANCING. AS
MCCARTY WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU AYE AYE I WOULD
ANSWER THAT ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE BUT MAYBE IT CAN JUST.
ADDRESS AND REASSURE A FEW OF
THE ISSUES RAISED BY CENTER PAN
INCOME LONGER IN IN MY CLOTHES-
YOU KNOW THIS. TAKES A LOT OF
PIECES. UP TO MAKE SURE IT
WORKS AND THE GOOD NEWS IS WE
HAVE A YEAR OF PLANNING. AND A
COUPLE YEAR PHASE IN PROCESS
WHICH I WE ASSUME. LOCAL
COMMITTEES ARE GONNA DO ANYWAY
BUT WE'RE PUTTING IN THIS BILL
REQUIRING. COUNTY OPS EDUCATION
TO COORDINATE THAT AT EACH
LEVEL WITH A LOCAL. PLANNING
COUNCILS. AND- WEEK WE HAVE
LEARNED FROM THE PAST I
REMEMBER WHEN I FIRST WENT TO
GO VISIT TKA CLASSROOM TEN
YEARS AGO RIGHT DOWN THE STREET
HERE. IT HAD ONE. TEACHER AND
THAT TIME WAS BEFORE THE CLASS
SIZE REDUCTION LC FAT. IS LIKE
THIRTY TWO CATS AND I WAS AND
DOES A NINE I'M SURPRISED THE
TEACHER DIDN'T YOU KNOW FALL
APART- SO THAT'S IS A DISASTER
FOR ANY BUT I CAN IMAGINE
HAVING. ONE TEACHER WITH THAT
MANY. FOUR YEAR OLDS BUT IN
THIS IN THIS BILL AND COMPANION
BUDGET PIECE WE'RE SAYING. WE
WANT RATIOS LIKE CHILD CARE
WHERE THERE'S- ONE ADULT TO
TWELVE KIDS SO EACH. TAKE A
CLASSROOM WOULD HAVE NO MORE
THAN TWENTY FOUR STUDENTS. AND
TWO TEACHERS TO. TO
PROFESSIONALS ONE. CREDENTIAL
TEACHER AND ONE PART
PROFESSIONAL LIKE WE HEARD
FROM. THE CSEA MEMBER FROM
SINGER- AS FAR AS FACILITIES
YOU'RE RIGHT SOME IS CLASSROOMS
ARE NOT READY. THEY DON'T HAVE
LITTLE THINGS LITTLE BATHROOMS-
WHICH IS WHY WE PUT. SEVERAL
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET. ONE TIME TO
HELP- RETROFIT. A PLUS SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WOULD BE ELIGIBLE TO
RECEIVE DISABILITIES MONEY IN
BONDS AND SO FORTH. AND SO ON
THEY KNOW THEIR CHALLENGE AHEAD
AND WE'RE- WE'RE WORKING WITH
THEM. AND THEN I DO KNOW THAT
THE THREE LINGERING YOU SEE
HEAR FROM PARENTS AND PROVIDERS
OF THESE ISSUES YOU MENTIONED.
SENATOR CONLOGUE OR IS. IS HOW
THIS IMPACTS THAT CHOICE AND
WITH THE RATES IN THE AND THAT
CRAP SO. OUR PACKAGE AND LIMóN
BILL ON THE BUDGET WE DO HAVE
MONEY FOR. FULL DAY WRAPS. IF
PARENTS NEED TO HAVE PROOF THAT
THE AFTER CARE AFTER SCHOOL.
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR. THAT
CERTAINLY OF THE AVAILABLE AND
THEN FOR THE ISSUES THAT I
THINK ARE THE MOST LEGIT WITH
THE CENTERS AS FAR AS- HEY HOW
CAN WE SERVE MORE. THREE YEAR
OLDS IN INFANTS AND TODDLERS IF
THOSE ARE THE MOST EXPENSIVE
WELL. THAT'S WHERE THIS WHOLE
RATING. IS THE KEY TO THE
PUZZLE TERM TO MAKE IT ALL
WORK. AND THEN FOR THOSE
EXISTING INCOME ELIGIBLE FOUR
YEAR OLDS. WERE CLARIFYING IN
THE BILL AND THE BUDGET THAT
THEY WANT TO KEEP GOING TO
THOSE. FAMILY CHILD CARE- HOMES
OR CENTER BASE THEY CERTAINLY
CAN'T SO I THINK THAT WE ARE.
ADDRESSING ALL OF THESE PIECES
INTO MOTION AND WILL CONTINUE
TO DO SO. AND WITH. THAT- PAST
THE RIVAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON A. B.
TWO. WE HAVE A FIVE SUTTER
CORTEZ'S N. CHO CAME PLEASE
CALL THE. AB TWENTY TWO THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED BUT FIRST
B. BUT FIRST BE RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FURTADO I. FOR TITLE I JONES.
CORTESE COURTESY I COM LONGER
KAMLAGER AYE PAN AYE PAN AYE.
THANK YOU MORE PLEASE STOP BILL
ON CALL AND BEFORE WE PROCEED
TO OUR AGENDA ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN I WANT TO GO AHEAD AND
TAKE UP THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
AND CONSULTING CAN YOU PLEASE.
HOW DO WE HAVE A MOTION. WE
HAVE A MOTION BY CENTER COME
LONGER. INSULTING YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
ADOPT THE CONSENT CALENDAR AND
THE BILLS ARE AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY SIX BY ARAMBULA AB TEN
FIFTY FIVE BY RAMOS AB THREE
SEVENTEEN BY PATTERSON AB EIGHT
SIXTY FIVE A QUICK SILVA AB TEN
FIFTY ONE BY BENNETT IN AB
TWELVE NINETY FOUR BY CORK. HER
TADO HI. PRODOTTO I'D JONES
CORTESE. HI CORTEZ THE I. COM
WALKER HI KAMLAGER AYE PAN AYE
PAN AYE. PERCENT THE DEPUTY
CALDERON ON CALL AS WELL. OKAY
AGENDA ITEM FIFTEEN A. B. EIGHT
THIRTEEN. PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
BEGIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I'M
PRESENTING THIS ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN. THIS IS
A MEASURE TO ESTABLISH AN
ADMINISTRATIVE PILOT PROGRAM TO
BETTER TRACK AND MEASURE
OUTCOMES AND QUALITY IN THE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
SERVICE AREA THE OUTCOMES WILL
INCLUDE CLEAR CONSISTENT
STANDARDS FOR SERVICE DELIVERY
AND MEASURE THE SUCCESS THAT
CONSUMERS EXPERIENCE. AS THEY
CAN USE THE SERVICES TO ACCESS
THEIR CHOSEN WAYS OF LIKE THIS
IS BASED UPON INFORMATION FROM
LA- REPORTS AND THROUGHOUT THE
BUDGET PROCESS- I ASK THE
ARRIVAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE A LEAD
WITNESS NUMBER ONE ELIZABETH.
GRIGSBY AND KEPT IN A RAP LEAD
WITNESS TO- WILL BEGIN WITH
LEAD WITNESS ONE. I AND MY NAME
WILL LIVE THE LIVES OF MORE
THAN THREE. I AT THEN THE
RENEWAL- DELIVER IN THERE ALL
OF BOTTOM END I WOULD MEAN THE
WORLD VIEW WAS. THE WELLS. YEAH
THE ONLY. BUT THE I ALL ON YEAH
I. I WAS THE ONLY. ONE WE'LL
WORLD- AND- MORE DRIVE A LOT
ONLINE THERE WILL BE LOT OF
MORE. ABU JUNE. HELLO WELL
WOULD LOSE HER WELL WE WANT.
HOW WERE YOU WHEN YOU WANT ARE
LIVE YOU HELLO I. HI I HAVE- WE
WILL UNITS. BUT THEY BOB THEY-
FOR ONE OF. WHAT WAS THE
REALITIES. WANDERLEY. LOS
LAYING. ALL HELLO AND I DON'T
KNOW I DON'T YOU. ONLY ONE OF.
I LOVE NORTE. DOCTORS WHAT I'M-
ONE. LATEST. MANY YEARS DURING
THE WE ARE THE. GRAHAM THERE
WILL. WELL NOW WE'RE A LITTLE
LONGERWELL I'LL IN THE
COMMUNITY LIKE EVERYONE ELSE HI
I HAVE READ JOB. I MY OWN. FILL
IN. THE HI MANAGE MY OWN HOPE
FOR. YEAH THERE ARE REALLY
DURING WHEN THE WILL HOLD OUR
ANY RIGHT IT IS WE DIDN'T ASK.
THE A. BUT I WILL LIKE. WELL
COMMUNITY HAS. BOB GREEN WELL
AND- THERE'S REALLY. L. AND MAN
WITH WHAT WHAT- MORE. HELLO
RESERVE THEY- LAUREN DO. ALL
MORAL WE NEED THAT YOUR. OBAMA
ARE LYING. WE NEED A GREATER DR
SEAT. THERE ARE. ONE NOT ONLY
IN THE- IN RELATED. BUT LIKE
THAT NO PRE NO ALL THE TIME.
YEAH YOU I. BY THE WE DON'T IS
ABLE IN. I DON'T WE REALLY. YOU
KNOW I GIVE NORMAL ONE YOU.
WHAT ARE YOUR- VISIBILITY
GLAZER ARE NO I TOLD. SECOND EN
ROUTE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY NETWORK. THREE
MINUTES. HI MY NAME IS KEVIN
KNOX AND ACCEPTED CORRECTIVE
MINUS WITH SEVENTEEN HUNDRED
DIRECT SERVICE PROFESSIONALS
SERVING SIXTEEN HUNDRED PEOPLE
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
IN THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AND AS
THE SPEECH AS A PERSON BUT I'M
ON MY- BOARD OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY LIVING NETWORK. SO DO
SENATORS I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
SERVICE OUTCOME INITIATIVE FOR
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
SERVICES IT'S INITIATIVE WOULD
CREATE A PILOT PROJECT THAT
WOULD ANSWER QUESTIONS THE
SENATE AND MANY OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO ASK WOULD
LOUDER AND LOUDER VOICES WHAT
THE STATE'S PAYING FOR HOW DO
WE KNOW THE SERVICES ARE
SUCCESSFUL. THE ISSUE CREATE
CLEAR AND CONSISTENT SERVICE
DELIVERY OUTCOMES SO PEOPLE
KNOW WHAT SERVICES THE GETTING
AND KNOW WHICH SERVICES TO
CHOOSE THEN IT'S GOING TO
MEASURE THOSE SERVICE OUTCOMES
NOT BY JUST ANOTHER TASK FORCE
THE TO TRY AND TALKING TO EACH
OTHER BUT BY DISCOVERING HOW
PEOPLE USE DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY SERVICES TO ACCESS
THEIR CHOSEN WAY OF LIFE. IN
THE REAL WORLD THAT THEY LIVE
IN THE COMMUNITY THEY NOW LIVE.
IN AS WELL AS THAT SET. EIGHTY
EIGHT ONE THREE IS A NEW. WILL
ADDRESS DIVERSE IN ACT. ISSUES
TO ALLOW IN PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES TO
ACHIEVE PERSON CENTRED SERVICES.
AND MAINTAIN THEIR LIFESTYLE
CHOICES BASED ON THEIR OWN
PERSONAL IDENTITIES. LOCATIONS
YOU CAN ALSO BE IMPROVED
OUTCOMES ARE TRACKED IN THE
STATE CAN BEGIN MAKING ME WAIT
OUTCOMES TRAINING PROGRAMS
BASED ON OUTCOMES WILL ENSURE
THAT SERVICES ARE DELIVERED
ACCORDING TO SPECIFICATIONS
PEOPLE CHOOSE. WE AND ANALYSIS
WILL ALLOW US NOT ONLY TO
MEASURE OUTCOMES BUT TO IMPROVE
THEM. WE ARE READY TO BREAK NEW
GROUND FOR EFFECTIVE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
SERVICES THAT PUT INDIVIDUALS
RECEIVING THOSE SERVICES AT THE
CENTER. PLEASE VOTE YES ON AB
EIGHT ONE THREE THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND I WANT AGAIN
THANK OUR LEAD WITNESSES A LIST
OF ELISABETH CRISPY AND KEVIN
RAFTER TESTIMONY WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT WILL BE AT ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE S
RTY TWO THREE LET'S MOVE TO
RUN TWENTY FORTY C. KNOWN ONE
TWENTY FORTY. FIVE WRITER
PLEASE BRING ON THE LINE
WITNESSES WHICH TESTIFIED IN
SUPPORT. OF AB EIGHT THIRTEEN.
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
THIRTEEN PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE AT THIS
TIME. WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE
TWO ZERO ONE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS ERIC
HARRIS WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT. THE
NEXT LINE. NINE TO SIXTEEN GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS MARK
LYNTON BECKETT DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LIVING
NETWORK PROUDLY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT ONE THREE
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT TIME.
NINE TWO ZERO SEVEN. YEAH I
DOESN'T MATCH MOST OVER THE
STATE COUNCIL ON DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
WE HAVE NO FURTHER LINES IN Q.
I THANKS VERY MUCH. THERE IS NO%
ROOM LEAD REGISTERED OPPOSITION
FOR TESTIMONY HERE TODAY SO
WE'LL MOVE ON TO DIGITAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
BEGIN WITHIN FORTY TWO OR THREE
SEEN ON FOUR TWO THREE LET'S
MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY. TWENTY
FORTY SEEN ON ROUTE TWENTY
FORTY MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES FOR WITNESSES WHICH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. TO
EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTEEN NAME FOR
SUCH A POSITION. IT JUST BY IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. MISTER JR WE HAVE
NO INCLUDING UP I THANK YOU
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBER
CENTER COME EITHER. THANK YOU I
JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND HIS PROXY FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD AND AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME I WILL MOVE THE BILL AND I
WOULD ASK IF YOU COULD ASK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN IF I
COULD BE A CO AUTHOR. OKAY SO
TO MOVE US OUR COLLECTOR AT THE
END OF THE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SAYING NONE- I JUST.
ALSO THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT
BILL TO ACTUALLY GET US MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT. TERMS
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OUTCOMES-
WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU TO ASK FOR
YOUR I. BUILT. RIGHT THANKS
VERY MUCH SO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE FIRST RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS.
CONSULTING CALL THE ROLL. AB
EIGHT THIRTEEN HER TADO JONES
CORTESE RIGHT ORTEGA'S ARE COM
LOCKER HI COM LONGER AYE PAN BY
HAND HI AS BILLS COULD
CURRENTLY THREE ZERO PUT THE
BILL ON CALL THANKS VERY MUCH
ALL RIGHT NOW LET'S MOVE ON TO.
I NUMBER. TWO EIGHTY SIX NINETY
FIVE BY SOME ARAMBULA WELCOME.
HIS MOMENT TO TIDY UP THE-
PODIUM HERE. WELCOME PLEASE
BEGIN. RETURN MEMBERS AB SIX
NINETY FIVE WILL PROTECT OLDER
INDEPENDENT ADULTS IN
CALIFORNIA FROM ABUSE NEGLECT
AND EXPLOITATION BY EXPANDING
AND ENHANCING ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES BY TWENTY THIRTY ONE
IN FIVE CALIFORNIANS WILL BE
AGE SIXTY FIVE OR OLDER THE
NUMBER OF OLDER ADULTS IN
CALIFORNIA WITH DISABILITIES
WILL INCREASE FROM ONE MILLION
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN TO THREE
MILLION IN TWENTY SIXTY.
CALIFORNIA'S AGING POPULATION
IS ALSO INCREASINGLY SUFFERING
HOMELESSNESS ACCORDING TO UCSF
RESEARCHERS APPROXIMATELY 50%
OF HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS ARE
OVER THE AGE OF FIFTY AND HALF
OF THOSE BECAME HOMELESS AFTER
THE REACHED THE AGE OF FIFTY.
ONE OF THE GREATEST THREATS TO
FULL INCLUSION AND EQUITY FOR
ALL AGES IS ELDER ABUSE WHICH
IS ESTIMATED TO IMPACT 10% OF
OLDER ADULTS LIVING AT HOME.
AND WITH LOSSES TOTALING IN THE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
TO ADDRESS THIS TWO PRONGED
ISSUE OF HOMELESSNESS AND ELDER
ABUSE EFFECTIVELY THE STATE
NEEDS TO INVEST ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES. INTO PLANNING AND
SUPPORT SERVICES. TO FILL SUCH
A NEED AB SIX NINETY FIVE WOULD
EXPAND AND ENHANCE THE ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES FOR OLDER
ADULTS. OLDER INDEPENDENT
ADULTS IN CALIFORNIA BY FIRST
LOWERING THE AGE OF ELIGIBILITY
FROM SIXTY FIVE TO SIXTY TO
SERVE HIGHLY VULNERABLE ADULTS.
SECOND IN EXPANDING ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES TO PROVIDE
LONG TERM CASE MANAGEMENT. AND
THIRD BY BUILDING UPON THE
SUCCESSFUL HOME SAFE PROGRAM TO
ASSIST ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICE
CLIENTS WHO NEED HELP WITH
HOUSING ISSUES. BY EXPANDING
THE OPERATIONAL CAPACITY MORE
OF OUR ELDERLY POPULATIONS CAN
FIND SAFE AND STABLE HOUSING.
IT WILL ALSO ALLOW THE ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES TO SERVE
AND EXPANDED OLDER ADULT
POPULATION ANYMORE UPSTREAM
CAPACITY AND INTERVENE EARLIER
IN SITUATIONS BEFORE THEY REACH
A CRISIS POINT. I WOULD NOTE
THAT THIS BILL DOES NOT SEEK TO
AMEND THE PENAL CODE AND ANY
EFFORTS TO DO SO. WOULD BEST BE
ADDRESSED IN ANOTHER VEHICLE.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX
NINETY FIVE APOLLO VS BECAUSE
OF THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
VIVIENNE IN BAKU. OF JUSTICE
CANADIAN. OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH
CENTER ARAMBULA MODERATOR
PLEASE BRING ON THE LINE OR TO
LEAD WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- PAUL
OF THE SKS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
WILL FOR DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA IF YOU IN BAKU
FROM JUSTICE IN AGING BEGIN
WITH PAHLAVI ASCUS AND AGAIN.
THREE MINUTES EACH. MODERATOR
HERVEY. YOU HEAR ME LET'S GET
YOUR LINE IS OPEN UP. WHAT YES
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE
BEGIN I THOUGHT FANTASTIC THANK
YOU. HELLO CANADA GOOD
AFTERNOON KILLING MEMBERS I'M
PAUL OF THE ACCOUNT DIRECTOR OF
LEGISLATIVE. ALSO DIRECTOR
TECHNICIAN ACROSPIRE OF
EIGHTEEN NINETY FIVE AND THE
CONCURRENT BUDGET ACT I'M HERE
TO PROVIDE THE COUNTY
PERSPECTIVE AND ASK FOR THE
SUPPORT OF THIS MATTER WITH THE
GROWTH THE APS PROGRAM ON THE
HOMEPAGE SO GROUNDWORK. YES
PROGRAM COULD MEET THE NEED WE
ARE SEEING WHAT. THE GROWING
OLDER ADULT POPULATION. EIGHT
PROGRAM SERVES THEM ALL
VULNERABLE OF OUR OLD.
INDEPENDENT BECAUSE- THAT HAVE
BEEN. NEGLECTED OR EXPLOITED.
POPULATION IS NOW FACING AN
UNPRECEDENTED HOUSING CRISIS
WHICH HAS BEEN FURTHER
EXACERBATED BY THE PANDEMIC. I
DON'T WANT AMONG BIRDS BUT A
PASSER OFTEN BEGAN TO REFUSE
NEGLECT. OR EXPLOITATION THE
OLDER ADULTS OFTEN HAVE COMPLEX
HEALTH OR MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
OR COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENTS SUCH
AS DEMENTIA ARE LIVING IN
POVERTY ON FIXED INCOMES ARE
LIVING IN PROPERTIES THAT HAVE
FALLEN INTO DISREPAIR AND ARE
SEEKING. I PLEDGE. APS IS AND
IN BY THE NUMBER OLDER AND THEN
THE DON'T WITH. ME IN THE
CURRENT COMPLEX OF THE- WITHIN
THE CURRENT RESOURCES API ON A
TO GET. HE THE PHONE WEEK. AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THE PROPOSAL
BEFORE YOU WILL MAKE THE HOME
PAPER PER. YOU TARGET THOSE
WORKERS HOME AN EXTRA THE PRO
TO REDUCE COUNTY. HER FOR
COUNTY IS THAT THE HOME PROGRAM
HAS YOU MANY THAT. BURKE
CONSERVING AND HEARING HOUSING
THOSE WE IN EIGHTY ONE AND THE
PROGRAM OLD INCREASED LOCAL
PARK. IF YOU'RE LOOKING FOR THE
INCREASED HEART HOUSING AT THE
FAIR AB OUT LAWN. HOSPITAL WE
TO TAKE ACTION BEGAN. AND AGAIN.
AMONG THE MANY COPY. THAT ARE
MOST AT RISK. I'M HAPPY NUMBER
YES SUPPORT OF AB SIX NINETY.
THANK YOU I YOU FOR STOPPING
VIDEO. THE BACK BACH. CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES PLEASE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TERRY MY NAME IS WITH
INBOX TO RECORD JUSTICE IN EACH
COSPONSORED THE REQUIRE WHERE I
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AB SIX NINETY
FIVE OF AN ORGANIZATION JUSTICE
IN AGING BELIEVE THAT NO MATTER
OUR RACE GENDER GENDER IDENTITY
SEXUAL ORIENTATION ABILITY
LANGUAGE OR COUNTRY OF ORIGIN
WE SHOULD ALL BE ABLE TO ACCESS
THE RESOURCES SERVICES AND
PROGRAMS WE NEED TO THRIVE AS
WE GROW OLDER. THEREFORE WE
SUPPORT INCREASED FUNDING FOR
ATS INTERNAL IN FIGHTING THE
SYSTEMIC INEQUITIES THAT AFFECT
OLDER ADULTS OF COLOR IN
CALIFORNIA PARTICULARLY THOSE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AS
YOU HEARD EARLIER THE NUMBER OF
OLDER ADULTS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA IS
GROWING EVEN MORE CONCERNING IS
NOT BLACK AT ALL OLDER ADULTS
ARE OVERREPRESENTED AMONG THE
HOMELESS POPULATION. 43% OF
HOMELESS ADULTS IN CALIFORNIA
ARE BLACK WHILE BLACK PEOPLE
MAKE UP ONLY 13% OF THE
NATIONAL POPULATION THIS
STATISTIC IS AN EXAMPLE OF THE
AFTER EFFECT OF DISCRIMINATORY
HOUSING PRACTICES. AND SYSTEMIC
RACISM. IN HOMELESS BISHOP HOME-
OLDER IT'S FUNDAMENTAL IN
EQUITY ISSUE. INCREASING BY
DATE WILL WORK IRECTLY TO.
MORE AGING FOR OLDER. AND OLD
OTHER OLDER ADULTS OF. HELD.
AMONG THE CHANGE OF THE ABC
NINETY FIVE MAKES OUR YOUR
TRUSTING EQUITY IS AMONG ADULTS.
THE PROVIDING FOR LONGER TO
STOCK WILL IMPACT COGNITIVELY
BY ALLOWING HUGE WORK TO ENTER
THE CALL NEED OF THE HOME OLDER.
AND PREVENT THE INCREASE AGING
UP ON HOUSEHOLD ADULTS. WE KNOW
ORDERED THAT ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS EACH FASTER THAN
THOSE WHO ARE HOW. MANY HOW
MUCH OLDER ADULTS ARE FOUND OUT
MEDICAL CONDITION FOR SOMEONE
TRYING TO TWENTY YEARS OLDER
THAN THEIR AGE THIS IS THE
REALITY OF HOW DAMAGING HOMES.
CAN BE- A HOME ADULTS OF COLOR
BE WARY OF SOCIAL SERVICE
AGENCIES I NEED MORE TIME TO
BUILD TRUST WITH THEIR CASE
WORKER. MANY OLDER ADULTS OF
COLOR HAVE HAD NEGATIVE
EXPERIENCES WITH SOCIAL
SERVICES IN THE PAST. AND MAY
NEED INCREASED CASE WORKER TIME
TO REBUILD TRUST. ADDITIONAL
LONG TERM STAFFING CAN ASSIST
IN BUILDING THE TRUST NEEDED TO
SERVE OUR MOST VULNERABLE OLDER
ADULTS AND PROVIDE A RESPONSE
CENTERED IN EQUITY. TO HELP
THEM SUCCESSFULLY TRANSITION
INTO PERMANENT HOUSING. IN
ADDITION EXTENDING A HOMESTAY
PROGRAMS BRING MORE FUNDING
WILL IMPACT THE OLDER ADULT
POPULATION POSITIVELY. BY
GIVING APS WORKER FLEXIBILITY
THEY NEED TO SERVE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATION IN A
HOLISTIC WAY. I PEOPLE
OUTSTANDING IF FOUND IN WAYS
THAT SUPPORT CLIENT CENTERED
RESPONSE AS WHAT SHE CAN TO
ACCOMPLISH COMPLEX NEEDS OF
THOSE WHO ARE HOMELESS AND AT
RISK OF HOMELESSNESS. JUSTICE
NEEDING BELIEVES THAT FUNDING
THE PROGRAM IS CRITICAL TO
ADDRESSING BOTH THE ISSUES OF
OLDER DAHLE HOMER AND GROWTH IN
THE OLDER ADULT POPULATION THAT
CALIFORNIA'S BASIC. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY AND TAKING STEPS TO
PROVIDING EQUITY TO ALL OLDER
ADULTS AND WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANKS VERY MUCH
WILL MOVE ON TO THIS TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTEEN SIX NINETY FIVE BEGIN
ON FORTY TWO OR HREE C. KNOWN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THRILLS MOVED
TO ROOM TWENTY FOUR. MY FORTY
SEEN ON ROUTE TWENTY FOUR FIVE
ATOR. OPEN THE LINES TO
WITNESSES WHICH HAS. IN SUPPORT
OF AB SIX FIVE NAME
WORKSTATIONS. TO TEST THE
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. BOOKER
SCORED A LINE TO TWELVE WHAT.
RIGHT WITH THAT YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA CONSTRUCTION THAT
THE GOVERNOR STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
NEXT TIME. NINE TWO FIFTY ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON JERRY MEMBERS
PREFER TO TALK ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY OF HUMBOLDT FRESNO AND
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT TIME. LINE. TWO
FIFTY TWO. BY TWO FIFTY TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE.
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN CANYONS CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
THANKS LINE. BLIND. TWO FIFTY
THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON EBEKAH
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT TIME. LINE TO TWENTY FOUR.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBER
MADELINE COOPER FROM NOTHING
MARC MARON BEHALF OF- THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. LINE. TWO
THIRTY EIGHT- MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE CARROLL SCHOOL
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING AND THE
CALIFORNIA ELDER JUSTICE
COALITION WHICH IS A CO ON A CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT TIME. PINE. TO THIRTEEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON RUSSIAN AT THREE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
WE HAVE NO FURTHER LINES INTO
AT THIS TIME RIGHT THANKS VERY
MUCH WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL EIGHTY SIX NINETY
FIVE- THERE'S NO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS HERE WHO'S
REGISTERED FOR TESTIMONY SO
MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION. BEGIN WITH ROOM FOR
TWO OR THREE C. KNOWN FOR A TWO
OR THREE WILL SMITH JUNE TWENTY
FORTY SEEN HONORING TWENTY
FORTY MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES FOR WITNESSES WHO SHOULD
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
SIX NINETY FIVE. NAME OR
POSITION POSITION ONLY. AND TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL
GO TO LINE ONE SEVENTY SEVEN GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CARE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WERE KILLED
IN THE STATE OR HE TO REMAIN
OPPOSED TO SECTION FIVE OF
EIGHTY SIX NINETY FIVE AS ADDED
ON APRIL THE EIGHT. SEATER
PROPOSITION THAT KIDS BE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF
FURTHER EXPANDING WHO IS
REQUIRED TO REPORT ABUSE TO
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA TO
FIND THE BEAUTY OF THE CRIME
SOCIAL WORKERS HAVE NO LAW
ENFORCEMENT POWERS FOR TRAINING
AT THE START OF THIS YEAR LAW
ENFORCEMENT NOW USE OF THE
SOCIAL SERVICES DEFINITION.
THANKS SB ELEVEN TWENTY THREE.
HELLO DOES NOT ENCOURAGE
RECORDING OTHER CRIMES SUCH AS
A BANK ROBBER YOUR SOCIAL
WORKERS. THE SENATE ALSO OFFICE
OF OVERSIGHT NOW COMES AT THREE
TOP RECOMMENDATIONS ONE WHICH
REPORTING TO SOCIAL WORKERS AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT YET AB SIX
NINETY FIVE. STILL HAVE OR IN
THEIR- SECOND WAS REVISED THE
MEDITATOR REPORTING LAW TO
CONSIST WITH FEDERAL AND STATE
LAWS SB SIX NINETY FIVE IS
STILL NOT CONSISTENT WITH. NO
CODE THREE SIXTY FIVE POINT
FIVE WHICH SAYS LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY RETAIN THE EXCLUSION
RESPONSIBILITY FOR CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION OUT OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT DO THEIR ASSIGNED
SHOP TO INVESTIGATE ABUSE WHEN
THEY NEVER GET THE INITIAL
REPORTS. THREE THE REPORT FOUND
THAT ONLY 25% OF THE VICTIMS
GIVE CONSENT THE BALANCE THREE
OUT OF FOUR RECORDS GO NOWHERE.
LAW ENFORCEMENT DOES NOT NEED
CONSENT OF THE VICTIM TO
INVESTIGATE WHAT DO THESE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES LOOK
LIKE FOR CALIFORNIANS
VULNERABLE. RESIDENTS A
MANDATORY REPORTERS CONCERNED
ABOUT A COWORKER ABUSING A
CHOIR SHE REPORTS FOR THE
MANDATORY REPORTING LAWS IN
EIGHTY SIX NINETY FIVE THE
SOCIAL WORKER VISITS A QUIET
AND BELIEVE THE POINT IS BEING
ABUSE. THE SOCIAL WORKER
ATTEMPTS THREE TIMES TO GET
CONSENT BUT ISN'T SUCCESSFUL
AND CONSEQUENTLY THE ABUSE
REPORT GOES NOWHERE AFTER THE
CLIENT HOUSES FAMILY FILE CIVIL
LITIGATION THROUGH LEGAL
DISCOVERY FAMILY LEARNS THAT
THE SOCIAL WORK WITH VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE CLIENT'S
WELL BEING. MEDICAL RECORDS A
TRIP TO THE ER WITHOUT A RIGHT
BECAUSE WHAT THE REQUESTED
PRIVATE CARE GIVER NOTES AND
OTHER DOCUMENTATIONS ALL
STRONGLY SUGGEST THE CLIENT WAS
REPORTEDLY. REPEATEDLY SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED BY. A MALE CARE GIVER
FOR ABOUT A YEAR. IMMEDIATELY I
THE YEAR TRIP THE USER WAS THE
LEAD TO BE A WAS TERM. DURING
SEVERAL. HE RETAIL EXERCISE HIS
RIGHT AGAINST SELF ACCREDIT.
ABUSE ONE OF THE BEERS OR WINE.
THE THAT WAS THEN SUB CLOSED
LAN PORTS WOULD NEVER NOTIFIED
AND THE SUSPECT. ABUSE THE BEST
SOLUTION IS TO SIMPLY CHANGE
THE OR CONSTRUCTION FIVE TO AND
IN SIX LOCATIONS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU I WOULD
NAY NOTE THAT- IF YOU ARE LEAD
OPPOSITION YOU SHOULD REGSTER
SO THAT WE CAN DO THAT I GAVE
YOU AS CHAIR I. DECIDED TO
ALLOW YOU SINCE YOU ARE LISTED
IN THE ANALYSIS BEING LIED
OPPOSITION BECAUSE WE WERE JUST
TAKING PUBLIC COMMENT BUT- I
DECIDED TO PERMIT YOU TO
CONTINUE TESTIMONY BUT I THINK
IN THE FUTURE PLEASE BE SURE
YOU REGISTER WITH THE STAFF SO
WE KNOW THAT YOU'LL BE READY TO
TESTIFY. BUT THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. TO EIGHTY SIX
NINETY FIVE. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
LINES INTO AT THIS TIME SIR ALL
RIGHT THANKS VERY MUCH NOW
LET'S MOVE ON TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
CORTESE- SUMMER OF RANDALL I
KNOW THAT YOU DID ADDRESS SOME
OF THE ISSUES- BROUGHT BY THE
PROPOSITION IN YOUR OPENING
STATEMENT- I THINK THIS IS A-
VERY VERY- IMPORTANT SET OF
REFORMS. I DID HAVE A QUICK
QUESTION FOR THE- COUNTY WELL
FOR DIRECT ASSOCIATES
CALIFORNIA SO IF PAUL OF THE
ASK IS CAN JUST. COME BACK ON
THE LINE- I WOULD JUST MAKE
NOTE THAT WE ARE ADDING AS
MANDATED REPORTERS SAID THE
BOTH THE COUNTY IN HOME SUPPORT
SERVICES AGENCY COUNTY PUBLIC
AUTHORITY I GUESS MY QUESTION
IS THAT USING MANDY REPORTERS
ARE INDIVIDUALS NOT. AGENCIES
SO. CAN YOU JUST PERHAPS
ELABORATE HOW THAT WOULD WORK-
ACTUALLY HAS RESPONSIBILITY
DOING THE REPORTING IS THAT THE
STAFF ON THE AGENCY DIRECTOR OF
THE AGENCY. HOW DOES THAT WORK
ON THE AGENCY. NOT INDIVIDUALS
TO MANDATE A REPORTER. GOOD
AFTERNOON COVER ON. SPEAKER THE
QUESTION- ACTUALLY I JUST
REALIZED THAT- DR ARAMBULA
MEDICARE BY JUMP I WOULD INSERT
YOU'RE GONNA TRY TO. NOT BE
PRESIDENT. OKAY ACTUALLY I WAS
ASKING THE QUESTION TO YOU-
PAUL THAT'S IN THIS PRACTICE
SO. I ANSWER THAT. YES
ABSOLUTELY NOT WHAT WITH ALL
DIFFERENT OF COURSE. YOU ARE
OFFICE. AND OF COURSE WILL NOT
RETURN AS WELL- I'M HAPPY-
EXACTLY ABOUT. YOUR UNDER BUT
NOT BUT THE WRITING I WOULDN'T.
CATHOLIC THE FROM BUT I'M HAPPY
ABOUT WITH YOU IN YOUR HOUSE
OKAY YEAH I JUST WANT CLARITY
INTO IS WHAT A WEEK WHAT'S THE
EXPECTATION RIGHT SO HOW DOES
THAT I. OF WE CAN. ADDRESS THAT
ISSUE- I'M SURE THEY'LL WILL
JUST ISSUES THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD OF THERE'S ANY DOESN'T
OR- IT'S- JUST MY LACK OF UNDER.
THAT'S THE SO OKAY WITH THAT-
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR BY EXPANDING THE
OPERATIONAL CAPACITY MORE OF
OUR ELDERLY POPULATIONS CAN
FIND SAFE AND STABLE HOUSING.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN IBM. OKAY THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT- SO. MUNEER OKAY YES SO-
NEXT SO THE HAS BEEN TO MOVE
THE FISA COURT IN THE MOST TO-
PASSED FIRST READING TO COME TO
DO- CONSOLE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. EIGHT SIX NINE HER TADO.
JONES CORTESE ON CORTESE I COM
LOCKER. AND HI AM NOT PAN AYE.
OKAY BILLS CURRENTLY TWO ZERO
ALL THE BILL OF ON CALL ALL
RIGHT SO THE NEXT ITEM I SEE
SOME MEMBER RAMOS HERE- AND
NONE OF THE OTHER OFFICE HERE
SO ONCE YOU COME UP SO THEY'LL
BE ITEM NUMBER. NINE EIGHTY TWO
TWENTY SIX. I GIVE US A MOMENT
TO TIDY UP THE PODIUM AGAIN.
TWO TIMES.
SO I UNDERSTAND
YOU'RE ALSO DOING ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AS WELL FOR SOME MEMBER
GARCIA SB SIX SIX FIVE. YES
YEAH SO DO YOU WANT TO BE IN
WITH YOUR BILL FIRST AB TWENTY
TWO TWENTY SIX AND THEN MOVE ON
TO ITEM FOR WHICH ORDER YOU
WISH TO DO THEM AND- THAT WILL
WORK BEST FOR CHAIR OKAY SO
WE'LL BEGIN WITH YOUR BILL ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB TWO TWO SIX.
PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN- SENATORS.
I'LL START BY ACKNOWLEDGING
THAT I ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. AB TWO TWO SIX
WOULD CLARIFY LICENSING ISSUES
AND ENSURE MUCH NEEDED FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR CHILDREN'S CRISIS
RESIDENTIAL PROGRAMS. CURRENTLY
AN ESTIMATED THREE OUT OF EVERY
FOUR CHILDREN IN THE UNITED
STATES WHO NEED MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES DO NOT RECEIVE THEM.
SUICIDE IS NOW THE SECOND
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH AMONG
ADOLESCENTS. IN ADDITION FORTY
SEVEN OUT OF FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE NO CHILD
PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITAL INPATIENT
BEDS FOR CHILDREN UNDER THE AGE
OF TWELVE. THE NEED FOR
CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH
RESIDENTIAL SERVICES COULD NOT
BE MORE URGENT THAN IT IS NOW.
AB TWO TWO SIX WOULD CLARIFY
THE PROGRAMS THAT PLAN TO
PROVIDE TWENTY FOUR HOUR
CHILDREN'S CRISIS RESIDENTIAL
SERVICES TO MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES UNDER THE AGE OF
TWENTY ONE SHALL BE DESIGNATED
AS PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT PROGRAM. P. T. R. F.
WITH THE APPROPRIATE LICENSING
CATEGORY IS ESTABLISHED THE
STATE AND COUNTIES WOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO THIS CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF THE CONTINUUM OF
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS SERVICES
UNDER MEDICARE ALL EARLY AND
PERIODIC SCREENING DIAGNOSIS
AND TREATMENT. I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE SOME
CHANGES THAT WE MADE THROUGH
SOME AMENDMENTS IN THE
COMMITTEE. THOSE AMENDMENTS
MAKE TWO IMPORTANT CHANGES TO
THE BILL FIRST THEY REINFORCE
THE REQUIREMENT FOR PHYSICIAN
OVERSIGHT. THROUGH AN RIEN
CLUED IN THE TEN DAY IN LENGTH
OF STAY LIMITATION. AND SECOND
THEY INCLUDE REFERENCE TO THE
EXISTING RIGHTS OF FOSTER YOUTH
IN THE WELFARE AND INSTITUTIONS
CODE TO STRENGTHEN FOSTER YOUTH
PROTECTIONS UNDER THIS BILL. I
AM HOPEFUL THESE AMENDMENTS
WILL CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD.
IN THE SPIRIT OF WORKING
TOGETHER FOR OUR YOUTH IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO BRING
THEM THE RESOURCES THAT WE
NEED. JOINING ME TODAY IS
ADRIAN SHELTON FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES AND DR
MOSS'S BARON PRESIDENT AND CEO
OF THE SAN DIEGO CENTER FOR
CHILDREN. THANKS FOR MUCH OF
SAN MARINO. MODERATOR PLEASE
BRING ON TO THE LINER TO LEAD
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ADRIAAN
CHILTON FROM CALIFORNIA LANDS
OF CHILDREN AND FAMILY SERVICES
AND WAS APPARENT FROM THE SAN
DIEGO CENTER FOR CHILDREN WILL
BEGIN WITH ADRIAN SHELTON SO BE
ON THE LINE PLEASE BEGIN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ADRIAN SHELTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES. WE
REPRESENT A HUNDRED FIFTY
NATIONALLY ACCREDITED COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS. CHILDREN
YOUTH AND FAMILIES AND PUBLIC
HUMAN SERVICES. OUR MEMBERS
SERVE OF THE MOST VULNERABLE
CHILDREN FAMILY AND ABOUT
ACCOUNT PROGRAM. AND THEIR TEAM
HIGHER ACUITY AND MARTIN THANK
YOU FOR HELP ON THE GROUND
ANOTHER BEFORE. AB TO PICK OUT
A NEW WHITE PARTICLE REINSTATE
THANK YOU. BUT YEAH CORRECT
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT. CRISIS
RESIDENTIAL PROGRAM- ARE
CRITICAL NEEDED TO PREVENT
UNNECESSARY HOSPITALIZATIONS
AND ENABLE THE CHILDREN LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA ACCESSIBLE HEALTH
SERVICES HI MY- ESTABLISHING A
NEW B. CATEGORY IS NOT. FOR
COUNTY FOR THEIR NEEDED A
PROVIDER NETWORK THE DEVELOPING
SHORT TERM PRACTICE PROGRAM.
NEED EXPECTED WELCOME THE CODE
NINE. AND THERE'S EVEN MORE
ACUTE NOW. AND IT THIRTY A
CRISIS SERVICES BEFORE THE END.
BUT I HOPE WITH THE OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNT CAN THE HIGHLIGHTED
THAT FORTY FIVE CHILDREN
HOSPITALIZED YEAR. FIFTEEN
COMMISSION STUDY ONLY SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY. THANK YOUNG.
AVAILABLE CHILDREN ADOLESCENTS.
WIDE THE FEDERAL ON THAT ACT
BOB CALIFORNIA TO THAT THAT'LL
HELP. THE CHILDREN AND THE
CURRENTLY PROTECT THE STUDY.
THE NEW OF CHILDREN AND YOU CAN
HAVE TO BE COST MAKE. THAT IN
MY BE PRIORITIZED ACROSS THE
ENTIRE. MENTAL HEALTH WITHOUT.
ACTUALLY WHERE THERE ARE GAPS.
AB TWO SIX THE DESKTOP. WHAT WE
REQUEST THERE ARE TODAY. YOUR
APPRECIATE THE FACT IN THE
THIRD COMMITTEE STAFF SHARES
WERE WITH US TO FURTHER THANK
THAT FELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LET'S NOT ON TO MOST PRAYER.
GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DR MOORE
SAYS BUT ON I'M A CLINICAL
PSYCHOLOGIST AND THE CEO OF THE
SAN DIEGO CENTER FOR CHILDREN
WE'RE THE OLDEST NONPROFIT
SERVING CHILDREN NOT REGION
OFFERING A RANGE OF NATIONALLY
ACCREDITED THERAPEUTIC AND
EDUCATIONAL SERVICES IN A
SITTING SWELLED FROM DIESEL
COUNTY. I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AS A
PROVIDER ABOUT THE NEED FOR
CHILDREN PRESIDENTIAL PROGRAMS
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMAH SMASHING HIS
REMARKS EVEN BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC BEGAN WE WERE ALREADY
EXPERIENCING A PEDIATRIC RECALL
CRISIS. AS AN EXAMPLE OUR
COLLEAGUES IN CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL HAVE BEEN
CONSISTENTLY REPORTING A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE. IN THE
NUMBER OF PSYCHIATRIC CASES
COMING TO THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS. IN SAN DIEGO. RADY
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL REPORTING
AN INCREASE OF 10005100406%
OVER AN EIGHT YEAR PERIOD IN
THE NUMBER OF MENTAL HEALTH
EMERGENCY SEEING THEIR YACHT.
FORTUNATELY THE PANDEMIC HAS
MADE THIS PUBLIC. CRISIS EVEN
WORSE. MANY OF THE ARRIVING ON
THE OURS COULD BE TREATED MORE
EFFECTIVELY IN A RESIDENTIAL
SETTING THE STEVEN QUALITY AND
SAFE CARE WE'LL SEE MOLD PAINS
ME RESERVING THE LIMITED
INPATIENT PSYCHIATRIC BEDS. FOR
THE KIDS THAT NEED IT MOST.
INFIRMITY FANATICAL ACCESS TO
CREDIT RESIDENTIAL BELTS THE
SOULS OF SAFE AND EFFECTIVE.
SHARKS POPS IN FOR YOU COR
READY TO BE DESTRUCTION MANY
PATIENT BED OR A CRISIS
STABILIZATION UNITS TODAY
COMMERCIALLY INSURED YOU HAVE
RESIDENTIAL IT'S ENOUGH XIN
UNFORTUNATELY ACCESS TO
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT IS NOT
AVAILABLE FOR YOU TO COVER
MAGNETIC CAL WHICH AS YOU KNOW
IS THE PRIMARY HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM FOR MORE THAN ONE HALF
OF THE STATE'S POPULATION UNDER
THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN. WHEN WHO
PRIMARILY COME FROM LOW INCOME
FAMILIES HAVE A DISABILITY
WHITE FOSTER CARE FOR MANY OF
THESE KIDS THE ONLY OPTIONS ARE
A LOG IN PATIENT UNIT OR SEEING
A THERAPIST EVERY FEW WEEKS IN
OPERATION SAID. ABOUT
SURPRISINGLY IS LACK OF OPTIONS
IN THE MENTAL HEALTH CONTINUUM
OF CARE FOR MEDI CAL USED
REGULARLY PROVES INADEQUATE
ASCENDANCE BY THE FACT THAT THE
RATE OF READMISSION TO THE
HOSPITAL BY DISPUTING SAN DIEGO
IS THREE TIMES HIGHER THAN
THOSE COVERED BY COMMERCIAL
INSURANCE WE STRONGLY BELIEVE
THAT WE MUST DO BETTER TO
ENSURE THAT ALL CHILDREN HAVE
EQUAL ACCESS TO A FULL
CONTINUUM OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. INCLUDING.
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT THANK YOU.
THANKS VERY WHEN I ON
ADDITIONAL IN AS A- AND EIGHTY
TO TWO SIX AGAIN WITH REPORT TO
THREE SAN ON FORTY TWO THROUGH
MOVE THROUGH POINT FORTY SEEN
ON ON TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY.
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO TWO SIX
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY.
THAT IS BECAUSE SUPPORT OF AB
TWO TWO SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL
GO FIRST TO LINE TO NINETEEN GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE ERA
ANYTHING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT TIME. WHAT OVER CHRIS.
WILL GO TO LINE TWO FIVE SEVEN
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
NUMBERS PER THOUGHT YOU TALK ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. BLIND. TO
SIXTY TWO. ANY UPPER WITH THE
NATIONAL ALLIANCE ON MENTAL
ILLNESS ALSO KNOWN AS NOBBY
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT THE BILL SIX
THANK YOU NEXT LINE. PINE. TO
FIFTY THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON ONE
PACKET GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT LINE SO WE'RE
TALKING BLIND. TWO OH EIGHT-
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
TIRING THE WITH THE COUNTY THEY
HAVE CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT ALTHOUGH PLAN TO TALK
ABOUT THE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE.
MEMBERS THANK YOU. WE'RE STILL
OPPOSITION HELLO THE I. N. ONE
NINE. NINE ONE NINE TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CARE NUMBERS PAUL
VS BECAUSE WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS. YES THANK
YOU NECKLINE. TWO SIX FOUR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS KERRY AND
CHERYL HINES WITH THIS SAID
DAMARA CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES IN WEST LOS ANGELES
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
TWO SIX. THANK YOU NEXT LINE.
LINE. TWO SIX THREE. I AM VERY
WILL BE HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY BEHAVIOR
HEALTH AGENCIES AND ALL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA TAX THAT COALITION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT TIME.
BY. TWO THREE FIVE. HELLO THIS
IS JAN BACK TRAILER WITH
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CARE
GIVERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT LINE. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
LINES INTO MR RIGHT THANKS VERY
MUCH NOW PASS IT BACK TO THE
CHAIR WHO IS HERE. THANK YOU
EVERYONE JUST GOT BACK FROM
PRESENTING THE BILL. HAVE A
LOOK AT THIS MONTH DOUBLED I
HAD TO- ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AND WE
DO HAVE THIS MARIA REVENUE ON-
THE TELEPHONE LINE. I BELIEVE.
TODAY YES THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARIA
RENEW SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY FOR
THE YOUTH WALKED IN OR AN
ORGANIZATION THAT ADVOCATED FOR
MORE THAN FORTY YEARS
STATEWIDE. AND ACROSS THE
NATION TO TRANSFORM CHILD
WELFARE AND MONTHS AFTER THEM.
CHILDREN PRICE YOU FOSTER
OPPOSES EIGHTEEN EQUIPMENT
CREATING CALIFORNIA MEDICAID
LICENSING CATEGORY OF
CHILDREN'S PSYCHIATRIC.
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT FACILITY.
I'M ONLY KNOWN AS T. I CAN'T
THAT IS BREAKS ENOUGH STATES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY COULD BE
USING PROFIT ON THE BACK OF ALL
THE MOST CHILDREN AT PUBLIC
EXPENSE. RECENT AMENDMENTS TO
THIS BILL DO NOT ALLEVIATE OUR
CONCERNS. IN ORDER TO PROTECT
CHILDREN AVOID THE MISSTEPS OF
OTHER STATE. CALIFORNIA MUST
CAREFULLY EXAMINE YES AND HOW
WE CREATE PR TS. EIGHTY SIX TO
BECOME A TO YOUR BILL TO
PROVIDE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REDESIGN WITH THE BIRTH
STAKEHOLDER INPUT AND TO
PROVIDE A SAFEGUARD THE
NECESSARY TO PROTECT THE HEALTH
SAFETY AND WELL BEING OF
CHILDREN. AB TWO THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA PKR YEAH THE BILL
THESE THAT HAVEBEEN CREATED
UNDER THE GUISE OF PROVIDING
SERVICES FOR CHILDREN WITH
GREAT MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS. RT
YEAH ARE NOT IN THE BEST
PRACTICE IN TREATING MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES THEN YOU.
ADVOCACY IS NOT WELCOME COURTED
BY RESEARCH. MANY P. R. P. R.
T. APPS DO NOT ACTUALLY PROVIDE.
TROM INFORMED OR ADEQUATE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
NATIONAL MEDIA OVER THE PAST
YEAR EXPO SHOCKING BUT COMMON
DETAIL OF THE CONDITIONS THAT
P. R. TO YOU HAVE TO CROSS THE
COUNTRY WHAT NBC NEWS
CHARACTERIZING THEM AS A
PROBABLE DEATH TRAPS. ASIAN IN
CAMPAIGN THE BUILDING RIGHT
ROUTE AND ADVOCATE FOR UNDER
WAY AND STATES. IT WILL BE OF
P. YEAH AND HOLDS VIABLE PRINT.
CHIU RATHER THAN CARING
CHILDREN IN THE CAN. NOT
SURPRISINGLY. BLACK YOU FOR
PLACED IN THE OF THOSE. RATHER
THAN BEING SUPPORT IN FAMILIES
IN THE COMMUNITY. YEAH BECOME
MEDICAIDFUNDING OF THE BOOM
YOU CAN. SERVICE HI YOU JUST.
YOU'LL BUY FOR. PRIVATE
INVESTMENT GROUP BEHIND
PROVIDERS LIKE SEQUEL YOUTH AND
FAMILY SERVICES THAT ARE ONLY
INTERESTED IN THE BOTTOM LINE.
CALIFORNIA HAS TO CERTIFY
PEOPLE ARE NOT THE RPF
RESIDENTIAL BUILDING THE OTHER
STATE AND- OTHER P. R. T. F.
PROVIDERS IN OTHER STATES.
RIGHT GOVERNING PRT YEP HAVE
NOT OBJECTIVELY PROTECTED
pWITH ALL THESE BECAUSE OF THE
VIEWS OF THE MUNICIPALITY. FIVE
AND WOULD BE THE PROVIDERS THAT
ARE IN OTHER STATE OPERATE
THESE P. RTS. PEOPLE ARE ALSO
PARTICULAR CAN ABOUT IN FOSTER.
AB TWO TWO SIX CREATE A NEW
CATEGORY OF LOCK FACILITY THAT
BYPASSES THE REQUIREMENT TO
PROTECTIONS FOR FOSTER CARE
PLACEMENT. PLACEMENT THEN WALK
MENTAL HEALTH FACILITIES. AB
TWO TWO BEEN AMENDED TO ADD
PROTECTIONS ON THE LENGTH OF
STAY IN CLARIFY THE PROCESS FOR
VOLUNTARY MENTAL HEALTH
FACILITY COMMITMENTS OF
JUVENILE COURT ATTENDANT AND
WARD. YOUR AVAILABLE FOR
PLACEMENT INTO P. YEP HOWEVER
THE MEN HOWEVER- THE END OF
JUNE WORK. VOLUNTEER BOB PRICE
IN WEEK SIX BYE. BE UTILIZED
FOR A OF THE TEN OF THE NORMAL.
THANK YOU. BUT DO I WANT TO
SAVE THE ADMIN STUDENTS.
PROHIBIT WIFE STAY THEY JUST
ALLOW A SELF INTERESTED ABOUT.
THE REVIEW BY THE FACILITY
HEALTHCARE PRACTITIONER
THEMSELVES THAT THERE IS A
MEDICAL DETERMINATION AND FOR
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES WHICH
FOSTER YOU ARE IT REQUIRES A
COUNTY MIDDLE HEALTH PLAN TO
REVIEW THE FACILITIES THE
TERMINATION THAT THE CHILD HAS
A MEDICAL NEED FOR THE SERVICES
WHEN THE FACILITY ITSELF IF
SOMEONE WOULD BE VICTIMS. ARE
RELY ON. KEEPING IT BAD STILL.
THANK YOU KNOW WE- OKAY BELIEVE
THAT A SHOULD BE A YEAR AT AND
INCLUDE. WATER INPUT THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO FOR YOUR
AT TESTIMONY HERE TODAY AND
WILL MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL HERE IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE DO WE HAVE
ANY. SEEN NONE. FIVE ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. NOW OPPOSITION ON
THE TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT
LINE. FEDERAL STREET OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. TO GO OVER THE LINE
TO A ONE GO AHEAD PLEASE. YEAH
BURKE WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WE SUBMITTED A
LETTER OF CONCERNS- AND WILL
FOLLOW UP WITH THE DOCTOR- TO
EARN SOME ABOUT IF WE CAN'T.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE OVER THE
LINES IN OPPOSITION. OKAY WELL
I WELL I APPRECIATE THE WORK
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS HAS
DONE IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO BILL PROTECTIONS
FOR YOUR YUTH HAVE PLACED INTO
THESE CHILDREN'S ARE CRISIS
ACCUTRIGGER RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT FACILITIES.
ESPECIALLY FOR THE PROTECTION
OF FOSTER YOUTH HOWEVER I DO
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS AROUND
INTRODUCTION OF P. R. T. F.
SEND THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
I'M SENSITIVE TO THE NEED TO
FILL THE GAPS IN OUR CONTINUUM
OF CARE WHEN IT COMES TO
SERVING FOSTER YOUTH WITH
SEVERE MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS BUT
AS WE HEARD DURING THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION OF APE. AB EIGHT OH
EIGHT TURNER LAST YEAR AND WE
NEED TO BUILD OUR INTENSIVE
TREATMENT OPTIONS WILL ALSO
PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF FOSTER
YOUTH- AND THE AND THE KEEPING
IN MIND OF GOALS OF THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM. THIS
BILL PROPOSES TO CREATE A NEW
PLACEMENT OPTION FOR YOUTH WITH
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS THAT ARE SO
SEVERE IT IS CLINICALLY
NECESSARY TO BE LEASED FOR
YOUTH AT EIGHT O'CLOCK
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT FACILITY
HOPEFULLY FOR A SHORT TERM.
THESE NEW P. R. T. HAVE STARTED
VISION TO BE DIVERSION TO
ADMISSION INTO PSYCHIATRIC
HOSPITAL AS CURRENTLY IN PRINT
THIS BILL DOES NOT PLACE ANY
LIMITATION ON THE LENGTH OF
STAY IN SUCH A FACILITY IT IS
ALSO INCONSISTENT WITH CURRENT
POLICY THAT DOES NOT ALLOW FOR
STREETS BE PLACED IN OUR-
FACILITIES WITHOUT THE CONSENT.
OF THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
REQUIRED INITIAL AUTHORIZATION
FOR COMMISSION TO EIGHT P. R.
T. F. TO BE LIMITED TO TEN
CONSECUTIVE DAYS AND CLARIFY
THE APPLICATION OF EXISTING.
LAW REGARDING FOSTER YOUTH. AND
TO TREAT IN A LOCKED. TO
PLACEMENT IN A PR T. F. WILL BE
THE MOVE WHILE THE AMENDMENTS
MOVE THE BILL IN THE RIGHT. I
DO NOT ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF
QUESTIONS RAISED BY THOSE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL I
ENCOURAGE THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE.
AND SPONSORS TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES OVER THE
SUMMER RECESS- I AM VOTING FOR
THE BILL TODAY AT BUT YOU KNOW
THEM. AS WE MOVE FORWARD. ALL
CONTINUE TO MONITOR THE
CONVERSATIONS AND- HOPING WE
CAN REACH BEYOND. THE BEST
POSSIBLE- LANGUAGES IS
ACHIEVED. AT THIS POINT-
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WE HAVE DATE
AT CENTER COURT AS HE AND THEN.
SENATOR PAT- THANK YOU- THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR QUEST FOR THE
AUTHOR IF HE'S- WILLING TO
JUST. WANT TO CLARIFY SOMETHING
THAT I THINK MY OFFICE IS ABLE
TO CLARIFY WITH THE- WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE REGARDING- THE
LICENSE SEEN- AND HOW THAT
WOULD WORK- WHERE YOU HAVE A
DESIRE BY. FIVE THE LOCALS ON
ME JUST SAY THAT THE BROADEST
TERMS- TO ESSENTIALLY SERVE
BOTH PURPOSES IN THE SAME
CAMPUS THE SAME FACILITY WITH
DUAL LICENSING- HIS IS THAT-
PART OF WHAT'S INCLUSIVE IN THE
IN THE LICENSING I UNDERSTOOD
AS I WAS READING THE ANALYSIS-
THAT THE HERE THERE WAS SOME
THOUGHT IN TERMS OF CONVERSION
OF- FROM ONE LICENSE TO THE
OTHER AND I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE ALSO THAT THERE'S A BOTH
AND OPTION. AGAIN AND TALK TO
YOUR OFFICE AND SOME LIKE THAT
WAS THAT WAS CORRECT THE
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE PUBLISHED IN
THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY MY
COUNTY WOULD BE ABLE TO. WOULD
ABLE TO ADD HELLO. IN SIR BOTH
POPULATIONS IN THE SAME
FACILITY. IN IN A MORE THAN
HAPPY TO HEAR FROM HOME. YOU
KNOW A WITNESS OR OR YOURSELF
ON THAT THAT'S FINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THE NIGHT AND YES
THAT- IT IS WITH- THE STATE AND
THE COUNTY BUT WE CAN HAVE
WITNESSES- SPEAK A LITTLE BIT
MORE TO THAT- ADRIAN OR ONE OF
THEM. YES HELLO ADRIN CHILDREN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE.
LA SERVICES. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THAT OUR CRICKET TEAM FOR THAT
QUESTION- AND YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
CORRECT BACK COULD BE ABOUT AN-
PROGRAM. THAT BUILD AND OPERATE
THE- SHORT TERM RESIDENTIAL
THERAPY PROGRAM. HE BUT BY BY
YES AND ALSO HOW- YOU KNOW BOB
AND HAVE HOW THE CHILDREN
CORRECTIVE RESIDENTIAL FACILITY
UNDER THE P. R. YEAH BY BUT THE
SELLER TO PASS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE RISK IN THE TO
CALM IF THE CHAIR BECAUSE I
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS. OF AN
EMPLOYEE TO HEAR THE BECAUSE-
OKAY I THINK WE ALL THAT. IN A
FROM A STANDPOINT. WE VERY
EASILY BE DEALING WITH TO
DIFFERENT POP BUT EQUALLY IN
NEED OF STATE RESOURCES LOCAL
RESOURCES AND CARE- HERE AND
CERTAINLY I WOULD WANT TO
CREATE. HIM BECAUSE OF FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES- UNDER THE NEW
LICENSING MODEL IN THE BILL NO
TO CREATE AN EXODUS OF. OF
THOSE WHO HAVE FIX AMONG THE
SPACE IN THE FACILITY TOWARD OF
THE PSYCHIATRIC CARE NOT THAT
WE DON'T NEED IT ALONE THE NOT
THAT WE DON'T BUT THAT WE ARE
SHORT BILL SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF MY OWN DISTRICT MOUNT COUNTY
THE BUT WE CERTAINLY DON'T WANT
TO- HE WILL CREATE THAT
OPPORTUNITY S. R. ONE ONE COST
IN TERMS OF BEDS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE- YOU KNOW TO THE NON
PSYCHIATRIC POPULATION SO. I
HEARD IN THE ANSWER THAT. BOTH
AND IS AVAILABLE AND I WOULD
TRUST THAT THE WITH THE LOCAL
LEVEL I ALSO HEARD OPPOSITION
AND CONCERNS BUT I WOULD TRUST
BY HAVING TO RECENTLY BEEN. A
FORMER COUNTY SUPERVISOR IN
DEALING WITH A LOT OF THE
AGENCIES SAID AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL DECISIONS WILL BE MADE.
TO TRY TO. STEER TO THE TO THE
RIGHT OUTCOME IN TERMS OF
BALANCING OUR POPULATIONS WITH
NEEDS SO WITH THAT I'LL BE AN
AYE VOTE ON THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND CENTER PAN. I
THINK IT'S VERY MUCH AND- I DO
I THINK- SUMMER RAMOS FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD INTO
DEALS WITH A VERY DIFFICULT
AREA AND I DO APPRECIATE THE
CONCERNS BEING RAISED BY
OPPOSITION. BUT ALSO MAKE NOTE-
THAT THIS BILL IS ACTUALLY
HEARD IN. SENATE HEALTH JUST
LAST WEEK AND THERE WAS NO
FORMAL OPPOSITION. IN FACT WE
GET IT ON CONSENT BECAUSE
THERE'S NO FORMAL OPPOSITION.
AND SO THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY
MEAN IT'S INAPPROPRIATE FOR US
ON THE BRING IN SOMETHING LATER
ON WE NEED TO FULLY THAT COLOR
BILLS- BUT I DO WANT TO JUST
RECOGNIZE THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERTAINLY I THINK AS IT IS
SOMEONE WHO'S OPEN AND IT HAS
ALWAYS. BEEN WANTS TO DEAL WITH
THE CONCERNS SO BY YOUR CALL
FOR TO YOUR BILL BUT YET THEY
OPPOSITION COMES IN SO LATE YOU
KNOW IT THAT THAT IT DOES BEG
THE QUESTION AS IT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT THEIR CONCERNS ARE NOT
ONES THAT WE SHOULD DEAL WITH.
RIGHT NOW BUT I DON'T URGE
PEOPLE TO TRY TO COME IN A
LITTLE EARLIER SO WE CAN TRY TO
ADDRESS THESE THINGS- BUT I DO
APPRECIATE THAT NOW THIS BILL
WHICH ALSO HAS A- A DEAL
COALITION OF SPONSORS ARE
TRYING TO ADDRESS A GAP IN IT
AND CHAIR- I. DAD'S FOR THESE.
ARE TRYING TO COME UP WITH THIS.
I UNDER. THE FEARS OF THE
OPPOSITION- EVEN HERE IN THIS
COMMITTEE WE'VE DEALT WITH THE
ISSUE FOR EXAMPLE THEY MENTION
SEQUEL WHICH IS A- A
CORPORATION DATA UNFORTUNATELY
IT HAS BEEN DOCUMENTED ABUSE
CHILDREN AND NOT PROVIDE THE
CARE THEY NEEDED IN THIS
ACCESS. POINT OVER RECENTLY.
USED TO SEND THE KIDS OUT OF
THE STATE TO BE CARED IN THEIR
FACILITIES ANALOGY CERTIFIED
AND WE'VE ACTUALLY THE BILL TO
TRY TO DO. THAT FROM. THAT
STRAIGHT THAT'S ALSO TRIED TO
ADDRESS THAT PARTICULAR ISSUE
AS WELL SO I UNDERSTAND THIS
YEAR HOPEFULLY WE DO
DIFFERENTLY- AND HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- BUT I GUESS I WOULD
JUST. SAY TO THE AUTHOR FOR SO
I JUST THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK
AND BRING THE SOUL. THIS BILL
FORD- ASK YOU TO WORK AT THE
OPPOSITION BUT ALSO JUST
ACKNOWLEDGE THE FACT THAT THE
OPPOSITION'S COMING IN VERY
LATE NOW- AND SO HOPEFULLY WE
CAN TRYTO RESOLVE THESE THINGS
INSTEAD OF SIMPLY DELAYING THIS
BILL FOR ANOTHER YEAR- PLEASE
BRING YOUR- ISSUES TO THE FORE
LET'S SEE WE CAN TRY TO SORT
THESE OUT. WELL THE FAMILY
MEMBER TO BE ABLE TO MOVE THIS
BILL FORWARD. AND AND ADDRESS
THE DID THE GAP THAT ACTUALLY
THIS DOWN THAT THAT THIS BILL
IS TRYING TO ADDRESS BECAUSE
I'M NOT SURE JUST THE LAYING
IT. IS THIS IS AN ANSWER
EITHER. SO CERTAINLY I'LL BE
VOTING FOR THE BILL BE HAPPY.
TO MOVE THE BILL TO FOR THE
TIME. THANK YOU SIR. THANK YOU-
WE HAVE A MUCH AND- YOU LIKE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE WITH A
THANK YOU I'M A CHAIR AND IT
IS- YOU KNOW WHERE THE UPPER.
HAS COMMAND WE DID TAKE IT THAT
CONSIDER. WITH THE MEMBERS IT
THAT WE'RE TAKING IN THE
COMMITTEE. BUT WHEN YOU LOOK
AT- THE DIVERSION ASPECT OF IT
IN THE DEFINITION OF TRYING TO
GET THOSE RESOURCES TO THE
LOCAL LEVELS. COUNTIES AND
STATES WHEN WE'RE DEALING WITH
THESE THINGS. AND THEN WHEN YOU
SEE THE FORTY SEVEN COUNTIES.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAVE
NO SERVICES FOR YOUTH IN THIS
PARTICULAR AREA. BEGS THE
QUESTION OF HOW MUCH LONGER
WILL IT TAKE TO GET SOME
SERVICES TO OUR USE. THAT ARE
SUFFERING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO AS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING. WITH THOSE
AT A BROADER QUESTIONS WE DO
LOOK FORWARD TO GETTING TE
SERVICES. TO OUR MUCH NEEDED
YOU IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU OUR- CONSULTANTS WE HAVE A
MOTION BY. FASTENER PAN AND
KEEP PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
TWO TWO SIX THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS HER TADO HI
HER TADO I'D JONES. JONES I'D
CORTESE CORTEZ III COM LONGER
PAN HI PAN HI. AND WE WILL
PLACE THIS BILL LONG CALLED
ALLOW OTHERS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
VOTE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
ABOUT BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT BILL I WANT TO TALK ABOUT.
TAKE A B. R. CONSENT CALENDAR
ONCE AGAIN AND- SO CONSULTING
CAN YOU. DO CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON. ARE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THE BILLS ON CAN
CENTER AB THREE SEVENTEEN BY
PATTERSON AB EIGHT SIXTY FIVE
CORK SILVA AB TEN FIFTY ONE BY
BENNETT AB TEN FIFTY FIVE BY
RAMOS A. B. TWELVE NINETY FOUR
BY QUIRK AB THIRTEEN TWENTY SIX
BY ARAMBULA. JONES JONES I. SO
THE VOTERS FIVE ZERO ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AND THAT IS
THAT CONSENT CALENDARS OUT.
OKAY AGENDA ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB
SIX SIX FIVE EIGHT EDUARDO
GARCIA WILL BE PRESENTED TODAY-
PLEASE POLICE ARE PROCEED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
BE PRESENTING ON AB SIX SIX
FIVE- SB SIX SIX FIVE WILL
REQUIRE VARIOUS CARE FACILITIES
WITH EXISTING INTERNET SERVICE
TO PROVIDE AT LEAST ONE.
INTERNET ACCESS DEVICE FOR
RESIDENTS. THIS WILL ALLOW
RESIDENTS CONTENT TO CONNECT
WITH LOVED ONES AN ACQUIRED
TELEHEALTH SERVICES AND PROMOTE
RESIDENTS QUALITY OF LIFE. I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFFER WORKING WITH STAFF AND
STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE. AB SIX SIX
FIVE HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
NO REGISTERED OPPOSITION. WITH
ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT ASIDE
HEATH COULD ARRIVE ALL THE
YOUTH SENIOR BODIES AND LINDA
CAN CAME COALITION FOR ELDER
AND DISABILITY RIGHTS. HELLO DO
DO WE HAVE SO HEATH OR LINDA ON
THE CALL. HI THIS IS A LOT.
OKAY PLEASE PROVIDE GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE. THEY COULD
FOUNDER AT YOU TO YOUR BUDDIES
HIGH TRIED KERR IN HONOR TO BE
YOUR TAKE IT EVEN IF THE COURT-
BILL EIGHTY SIX SIXTY FIVE
WHICH IS SHORT REQUIRED TO FILL
THESE FOR THE ELDERLY
CHRONICALLY ILL AND ADULTS WITH
THE EXISTING INTERNET SERVICE
TO PROVIDE AT LEAST ONE
INTERNET ACCESS TOOL WITH VIDEO
CONFERENCING TECHNOLOGY.
CONTACT I WANT YOU TO YOUR BY
YOU DURING THE START OF THE
PANDEMIC AUTHOR
INTERGENERATIONAL CONNECTIONS
BETWEEN THE YOUTH AND SENIOR
CITIZENS BECAUSE THEM AS WE
WERE TRYING TO EXPAND OUR REACH
YOU SENIOR LIVING FACILITIES
AND MARK WORLD LOW INCOME AREA.
SEVERAL OF THE PHILIPPINES
COULD NOT PARTICIPATE IN A
PROGRAM TO DO INTERNET
CONNECTION ISSUES. ELDERLY DID
NOT HAVE ACCESS TO RELIABLE
VIDEO CONFERENCING TECHNOLOGY
LIVING IN THE TECHNOLOGY BASED
CENTURY ELDERBERRY SHOCKED TO
LEARN LACK OF ACTIVE TO THE
INTERNET TO BE HEARD OVER THE
YEARS TO CONNECT WITH THE YOUTH
AND OUR PROGRAM. HAVING
INTERNET ACCESS TO A VERY
IMPORTANT FOR THE HEALTH. AND
QUALITY OF LIFE OF THE ELDERLY.
JOINT SOLUTION AND WILLIAM. HI
CAN YOU DURING THE CURRENT THAT
MAKE. HI RISK FOREVER I OF
THINGS AND CAN. HAVING TO AND
INTERNET EXPECT DOING THE CAN
AND THEN MAKE FALLOUT HERE
STEVE WE WILL BE COMMUNICATE
WITH FAMILY AND FRIENDS TO BE A
PART VIDEO. STAY UP TO DATE
WITH NEW. AND FIND A RETAIN.
ALTHOUGH HE YET LONELINESS BY
SENIOR STILL MORE CONNECTED TO
SOCIETY A LOT. MOREOVER THE
CODE AND DEMOCRATS THIS YOU
HOPE POINT AND THE CONVENER YOU
HAVE UNDERONE HEALTH CAN THAT
THEM MORE VULNERABLE TO CRIME.
VIRTUAL DOCTOR ARE THE SAME AS
OPTION FOR THAT. IT WOULD
REQUIRECARE FACILITY IF YOU
HAVE A ONE SHARED. AND INTERNET.
SO TO PROMOTE THE HEALTH AND
QUALITY OF LIFE OF OUR ELDER
AMERICANS. WE MY WORK TO CLOSE
TO DIGITAL THE AND THEM
INTERNET TO STATUS TO STAY
CONNECTED THE WORLD. AB SIX
SIXTY OF THE THIS AND YOU- FOR
THE BILL. THIRTY SIX IN. DURING
MY FREE TIME. THANK YOU NAY
NEXT WITNESS. WHEN MAKING TO
CALL FOR ELDER IN DISABILITY
RIGHTS AND WE ARE GOING TO
SUPPORT THE ACT OF USE YOUR BY
THERE- GROUP OF YOUNG FOLKS WHO
ARE DOING TIME WORK REACHING
OUT TO THE L. AND ARE FACILITY.
HERITABILITY AS CHALLENGES
UNIQUE WITH THE- WORLD IN THE
BEST OF TIME. THE PAST YEAR TO
HELP HELP NOT BEEN ON THE TIME.
WITH THE RECENTLY CONTACT BY K.
IT WAS A RATHER AND A NOR CAL
TO CELEBRATE. NO WONDER DR
DOESN'T. BUT THEY RARELY COME.
ADAM CHILDREN AT A LONG TERM
FRIEND ALL L. CAL- HOLD AND THE
ON. KEVIN FELT ALONG. OVER
MINUTES LOCATE I'M BRING HIM
THE FONG. EMAIL HUNTER KEVIN TO
GO ASTRAY. HE DOES NOT WE'VE
ANY IN THE YOU. WITHOUT
INTERNET ACCESS. CAN BE
COMPLETE CUT OFF FROM OUTSIDE
WORLD. BUT HAVE ACCESS TO A BAR
TOM PROVIDER. BY THE.
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA WE ALL
FOR YOUR AUTOMOTIVE ON EIGHTY
SIX SIX FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ARE HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT FOR MOVE
ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT IN SUPPORT
OF ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE. SEE
NON OUR ROOM TWENTY FORTY. NONE
THERE'S WELL ON AND ON THE
TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT NINE.
BEEN TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT S. ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL
GO TO LINE TWO FORTY SIX GO
AHEAD. NINE TO FORTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SORRY ABOUT THAT.
CALLING ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA.
AT THE BUS STATION BUT- THANK
YOU BYE BLIND. TWO FIFTY THREE.
I GOT REBEKAH NATIONALISTS OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CHAPTER INSOFAR.
THANK YOU. IF THERE ARE ANY OF
THE LINES IN SUPPORT PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. DO WE
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL CALLERS
WHICH- WE HAVE NO NELSON GIVE
IT THIS TIME. THANK AT THIS
MOMENT WE WILL MOVE ON TO-
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WE
DON'T HAVE ANY LEAD- WITNESSES
AT THE FOR THIS BILL BUT- WILL
GO HEAD AND- TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT. BEGINNING HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE AND
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL THREE
NINE FROM TWENTY FORTY. NINE
THERE'S A WALL AND NOW
OPPOSITION ON THE TELEPHONE
PUBLIC COMMENT LINE. SPEAKING
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE WERE OUT OF
LINE TO SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS- ROCKSTAND
GOLDER BEGINNING SIX BEDS WHICH
IS AN ASSOCIATION OF
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY AND DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABLED AT. ALL SIX BETTER
FEWER. I THANK THE AUTHOR THEIR
STAFF THEY WORKED TIRELESSLY
WITH US YEAH WE'RE SORT OF A
TWEENER WE JUST WANT TO INSURE
THAT HOMEOWNERS AND THEIR STAFF
ALSO HAVE ACCESS TO THE DEVICE
ARE THESE ARE PENALIZED IF THEY
HAPPEN TO USE THAT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. OKAY WE HAVE LOOKED
THE LINES AND GIVE IT TO TIME.
OKAY SO- ON BRINGING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS BILL WE HAVE
A MOTION. ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS NOW OKAY-
SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY A
SENATOR PER HAND HOW WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THOSE THREE
RIVAL. A CONSULTING KEY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AB SIX SIX FIVE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE RE REFER TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS HER TADO I.
HURTADO AYE JONES. JONES II
CORTESE. CORTESE I COM LONGER
PAN AM HI. SO WE WILL PLACE UP
ALONG CALL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR. OKAY AND WE HAVE US WOMAN
LOU. HE ARE THE PRESENT ON ITEM
FIVE AND- ITEM SIX. BUT WE'LL
START WITH ADVICE.
PLEASE
PROCEED HEY- THANK YOU
CHAIRWOMAN AND SENATORS I WOULD
LIKE TO START BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
THOROUGH EVALUATION OF THIS
BILL. 60% OF CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA UNDER AGE SIX COME
FROM HOMES WHERE ENGLISH IS NOT
THE PRIMARY LANGUAGE. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO IDENTIFY DUAL
LANGUAGE LEARNERS WHEN THEY
ENTER PRESCHOOL TO DESIGN
PROGRAMS AND TRAIN TEACHERS TO
SUPPORT THE STUDENTS IN WAYS.
THAT DEVELOP THEIR HOME
LANGUAGE AND ENGLISH. RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT FLUENCY IN MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES BENEFITS CHILDREN. BY
BROADENING THEIR COGNITIVE
FLEXIBILITY ENHANCING THEIR
LEARNING. CAPABILITIES AND
GIVING STUDENTS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BECOME MULTI LINGUAL SO THEY
ARE COMPETITIVE IN THE GLOBAL
WORK FORCE. AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
THREE TAKES THE CRITICAL FIRST
STEP IN IMPLEMENTING THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S MASTER PLANNED FOR
EARLY LEARNING. AND CARE FOR
SUPPORTING DUAL LANGUAGE
LEARNERS SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL
WILL REQUIRE THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TO ESTABLISH A
DEFINITION SPECIFICALLY FOR
DUAL LANGUAGE LEARNERS DEVELOP
A STANDARDIZED PROCESS. FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM- SO THAT THEIR
PROVIDERS CAN IDENTIFY DUAL
LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND REQUIRES
PROVIDERS TO REPORT INFORMATION
ABOUT DUAL LANGUAGE LEARNERS TO
THE STATE. TODAY UP TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I HAVE
PATTY HERRERA LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE WITH EARLY EDGE
CALIFORNIA SHOP SHE'S AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. AND I HAVE JESSICA
GOOD HERE IS FROM THE FRESNO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
LANGUAGE LEARNING PROJECT
COORDINATOR. THANK YOU SEE A
WOMAN WE WILL NOW GO TO THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT THE LEAD
WITNESSES I HAVE JESSICA GOOD
TEARS AS NUMBER ONE IS THAT WE
WANT TO GO FIRST YES PLEASE
OKAY IF WE CAN HAVE A JUST A
GOOD TEARS- BEGIN TO. A SPEAK
AND THEN PATTY HERRERA AFTER
THAT. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
WHICH I COULD LOOK AT IT
MANUALLY CONTEXT HERE BECAUSE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHOW
THE VOICE OF AN EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATOR IT'S A GREAT HONOR TO
JOIN LAW THREE LIKE TO SHARE A
LITTLE ABOUT MY ROLE AS AN
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION WHICH
WILL PROVIDE INSIGHT INTO THE
PERSPECTIVE FROM WHICH I WILL
BE SPEAKING. I'M CURRENTLY
WORKING FOR THE UNIFIED
TECHNICAL PROGRAM I FOR THE
PAST SIX YEARS I'VE BEEN A
PROJECT ALONG WITH CERTAIN
PROJECT WHICH SEEKS TO IMPROVE
THE PRACTICE AND THE EASY WORK
FORCE TO QUICKLY THE DOLE BUT
LATER. OUR PROGRAM OF
RECOGNIZING THE PROMISING MODEL
IN THE FIFTH A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
IT BUT- I DON'T KNOW A TON OF
EDUCATOR CALIFORNIA I HAVE A
GREAT FORTUNE TO SOME OF THE
MOST TELL THEM THE FAMILY GIVE
MANY. HOWEVER MOST AYE
EXPERIENCE FOR MY DECISION ON
WHICH ON IN COLLEGE I'VE BEEN
RUNNING PROCESS THE WHICH TO
DEAL I'LL OF MY CAR. THE
PROCESS I YOU WITH A MECHANIZED
NOT AS A MODEL GOING TO OUR A
LADY. AND BE VERY HELPFUL TO
AND FROM THE PROPERTY GARBAGE
THE FBI IF THE PEOPLE
COMPLETELY BECOME I THANK THE
FOR THE BEING HER BY YOUR- I
DIDN'T ABOUT NEEDED AN INTEREST
INTERVIEWED MICHAEL WITH FAMILY
ABOUT THE CULTURE ONLY AND I
DID FACT THAT WITH LANGUAGE.
EVEN WITH FOR REGULAR BY GOING
WITH ONE OR THE COMING PART OF
MY FACT. A CONVERSATION WITH
FAMILY BECAUSE I THE OPTION
COMMUNITY DATA AND INPUT MY
TRUCKI'M REALLY GLAD TO OUR
NEEDS IN MY CAR. ALTOGETHER NOT
ONLY QUALIFIED TEACHING TAX
ACROSS BUT LOCAL PROGRAM
DECISION THAT ALLOCATE RECORD
FOR CHILDREN IN FAMILIES THERE
ARE SO MANY DIFFERENT COME THAT
WE THAT YOU MUST. TO THE BEST
IN THE OF THE CHILD AND FAMILY
REQUIRE OUR FIRST THOUGHT
IDENTIFY DEALING WITH IT YOU
LOOK OF COURSE IN CASH. IN
ATTITUDE ALL LONG WITH THE
TRACKAGE PRODUCT WITH ME I HAVE
THE MOST WHEN I FIRST ABOUT IT
HERE. HOWEVER WILL BE ABLE TO
EASILY INTEGRATE THE CONVERT
THE HARD THANKS FOR OF ENGAGING
IN THE WITHOUT AND I CANNOT AND
ENOUGH HOW IN BY TO CROP BECOME
MY FUTURE PRACTICE. ACTUALLY
TALKING EDUCATED HAVE A GREAT
HONOR.
YOU VERY MUCH AND NOW
MISSES HER. MISERERE GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU CAN
EVERYBODY HEAR ME. AFTERNOON
HAVING HER ON BEHALF OF EARLY
EDGE CALIFORNIA AND PROUD CO
SPONSOR IN AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
THREE ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS
NOTED IN HER OPENING COMMENT WE
REALLY BELIEVE THAT SUPPORTING
OUR DUAL LANGUAGE LEARNERS NOT
ONLY SUPPORT THEM AND THEIR
FAMILIES BUT IN SHORT THE
CALIFORNIA WILL CONTINUE TO BE
AN ECONOMIC COMPETITOR. ON THE
GLOBAL STAGE WITH THAT I'M
REALLY HERE TO JUST ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THAT THE
COMMITTEE YEAH. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE WILL NOW GO TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE NOT SEEING
ANY- IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. NONE
THERE AND WE'LL GO TO THE
TELEPHONES IF THE OPERATOR CAN
INDICATE. A SUPPORT FOR A BI
THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE. IT IS BIG
IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
THREE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
NINETY EIGHT GO AHEAD PLEASE.
HI THIS IS DANIEL ONE DRAW WITH
CHILDREN NOW IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. SURE WE HAVE
ENOUGH FOR THE LINES IN Q.
THANK YOU MODERATOR WE WILL NOW
GO INTO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
WE HAVE NO LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION NO WITNESSES IN
FORTY TWO OR THREE. LOOKING
TWENTY FORTY NOBODY THERE-
MISTER MODERATOR IF WE CAN GO
TO THE PHONE CALLS AND IF
THERE'S ANY. CALLS IN
OPPOSITION. TO THIRTEEN SIXTY
THREE. THE REGISTER OPPOSITION
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THIS YEAR WE HAVE KNOWN
QUEUING UP TO THAT OKAY I SEE.
NO OTHER PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
THE ROOM HERE NO MEMBERS TO
DEFER TO- A SIMILAR RIVAS SIMON
ADAMS- SUPPORTING YOUR BILL- SO
I'LL MAKE THE MOTION IN
SUPPORT- IF THAT WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE. OKAY AND THEN I
WOULDN'T- INVITE YOU TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU YOU KNOW AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY THREE IS THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS PRIORITY AND HAS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT AND
POLICY COMMITTEES- THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WOULD WE LIKE TO CALL THE ROLL.
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
RE REFER TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS HER TADO JONES
HI JONES HI CORTESE COM LONGER.
PAN. WE WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN
HAS ONE VOTE. I'M SURE. YOU
ALSO ME EXCITING THE EXCITING
ONLY ADDING ONTO IT WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO AB FORTY SIX ALSO
BY SOMEONE THREE OF US ON-
CALIFORNIA YOUTH EMPOWERMENT
ACT. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO GO
AHEAD AND OPEN ON THAT THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I
WOULD BEGIN BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
EVALUATION OF THIS BILL I AM
EXCITED TO PRESENT AB FORTY SIX
A CRITICAL USED TO LEAD
MEASURE. SEEKING TO ENSURE THAT
STATE LAW MAKERS HEAR THE
VOICES OF CALIFORNIA'S YOU AB
FORTY SIX WILL ESTABLISH THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH EMPOWERMENT
COMMISSION WHICH WILL BE
COMPRISED SOLELY OF USE AND
FOCUS ON POLICY ISSUES THAT
IMPACT YOUNG CALIFORNIANS. WELL
THERE ARE MULTIPLE COMMISSIONS
ADVISING THE STATE GOVERNMENT
ON MATTERS PERTAINING TO
SPECIFIC COMMUNITIES THERE'S NO
COMMISSION FOCUS SOLELY ON THE
NEEDS OF USE. AB FORTY SIX
ADDRESSES THIS LACK OF USE
REPRESENTATION IN STATE POLICY
BY ESTABLISHING THE CALIFORNIA.
YOUTH EMPOWER ME COMMISSION.
THE COMMISSION'S DUTIES WILL
INCLUDE EXAMINING POLICY
HOLDING MEETINGS WITH YOU
ADVOCATES. AND INVESTING IN
CRITICAL USE DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS. THIS BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY A WIDE COALITION
OF SPONSORS AND REPRESENTATION
OF THAT COALITION I AM PLEASED
TO BE JOINED TODAY BY KEN
LEWIS. LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH.
AND JASMINE HERIS FACILITATOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH
CONNECTION. THANK YOU SOON WE
WILL NOW GO TO KIM LEWIS ON THE
TELEPHONE. GOOD AFTERNOON CAN
LIMIT FOR PRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YEARS
ONE OF THE CARS BOB HERTZBERG
D. B. FORTY FACT. OUR RESEARCH
HAS SHOWN THAT OPPORTUNITY FOR
MEANINGFUL USE IMPACT CAN
INCREASE THEIR ENGAGEMENT AND
ORGANIZATIONAL ACTIVITIES. AND
ONE ADULT. YOUNG PEOPLE OF
VALUABLE RESOURCES THAT CAN
INFORM THE DECISIONS THAT
IMPACT THEM. DALGETY
IMPROVEMENT IN THE QUALITY OF
THE DECISIONS THAT ARE MADE.
TIKI I. AND VALUES THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE FOUR EIGHT
AND PROVIDING YOUNG PEOPLE WITH
OPPORTUNITIES TO MAKE
MEANINGFUL IMPACT IN THE
COMMUNITY. YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
SERVE ON OUR BOARD OF
DIRECTORS. WILL COMPRISE ARE
YOU COULD BUY THREE BOARD YOUR
FAMILY OPPORTUNITIES FOR
ENGAGEMENT A LINE OF THE
RESEARCH RESULTING AND HAVE
THEM PROGRAM IMPROVEMENT. TOO
OFTEN WE FIND STATE
ADMINISTRATION PROGRAM DESIGNED
TO SUPPORT YOUNG PEOPLE FAIL TO
ENGAGE THEM OR SHOULD SHE
DOESN'T PROVE OUTCOMES THAT WE
HELPED YOU INTEND TO ACHIEVE.
AB FORTY SIX LOOK AT ANOTHER
TOLD THE STATE TOOLBOX. BUT WE
CAN GET THE OBVIOUS OUT COME.
OF LIKE TO CLOSE BY THANKING
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REMASTERED
CHAMPING A BILL IN THE
COMMITTEE AND STAFF FOR THEIR
TIME AND ATTENTION TO THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND CAL.
THANK YOU MISS LEWIS NOW. MOVE
ON TO JASMINE HERIS PLEASE. THE
WORK DONE IN CALIFORNIA CAPITAL
AFFECT CONSTITUENTS OF ALL AGES
EVEN UNDER EQUAL. FOURTEEN WE
RE GLAD YOU IN ORDER TO PRE
REGISTER. ONE STARTING REALIZE
THE POWER NUMBER FOR THE FUTURE
OF THIS ALMOST MY NAME IS
JASMINE I'M A TWENTY YEAR OLD
MEMBER YOU CAN. YOU ARE THE OR
WITH THIRTY FIVE CHAPTERS
ACROSS. THE ALAMEDA CHOPPED IN
THE IN THE PAST. YEARS AGO
ALONGSIDE THE- OBJAVILA ON
CREATING CHANGES THE SIMPSONS.
SO HE WANTS TO FUNDED TO BRING
THANK YOU FOR. HI THANK YOU
COULD THE SUPPORT MOST PEOPLE
SHOULD BE A PART OF DIVISION
MAKING LAST. BUT WAIT TO BUY WE
HAD TO SIT BACK AND HOPE
SOMEONE WILL ZERO. VIA YEAH.
NINE MILLION HEALTH. UNDER THE
OF. YOU REALLY CAN'T ABOUT THE
THAT THE COURT TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY TWENTY THREE ALLOW ONE
TO SOMETIME COMMITTEE TO BRING.
POINT ALL ACROSS THE WITH OVER
A HUNDRED AND THIRTY VOCAL
COMMISSION. COALITION ADVOCATES
POPPING UP ACROSS THE CHANNEL.
THE GENERAL COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN OUR. I'M TO BRING THEM
TO THE CAR. COMMUNITY OR WOMAN
SPECIAL WHERE GETTING A LITTLE.
THAT YOUNG ARE KIDS OUT OF
THERE CAN ONLY GO FAR I IT IS
PART OF THE OF SUPPORTING I'M
TO BE. A PART. WELL NOT ANYMORE
YOU'RE- GOING WHERE AND HOW
SOLUTION. I THANK WILL. BE
TAKING BUILT FROM. FOR KIMBERLY
MAKE THE DEFAULT IN A LOT OF
THIS FOLDER AND. WHAT FIRST
SUPPORT ON THE GROUND I THINK
YOU I THINK. EIGHT THE- PART OF
THE FORTY OKAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE WILL MOVE ON TO- WITH
PUBLIC WITNESSES SUPPORT-
NOBODY AND FOR TWO ALL GO TO
FORTY NOBODY IN TWENTY FOUR
MODERATOR IF WE HAVE SOME-
CALLERS IN SUPPORT OF AB FORTY
SIX IF WE CAN HEAR FROM THEM
NOW. THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO WE
WILL FIRST GO TO LINE TWO FIFTY
FOUR GO AHEAD. THE COLE PORTER
ON BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT OF AB
FORTY SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU.
PINE. TO SEVENTY TWO- JACKIE
RETIRED CIVIL CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES IN SUPPORT OF AB FORTY
SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU BLIND
TWO FIFTY THREE. PERFECTING
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LINE. ONE NINETY EIGHT. HI
DANIEL ONE DRAW WITH CHILDREN
NOW IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY
NEW. TWO TWELVE. ANYONE WITH
SEIU CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
NINE TWO SEVENTY THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON TRAVIS YORK WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB FORTY
SIX THANK YOU. LINE TWO FORTY
FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON DOOR ROSE
LEGAL PARAMETERS CALIFORNIA IS
A VERY STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE ONE NINETY TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON POLICY S. GOES WITH
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION BEFORE. HI. NINE
ONE NINETY FIVE. HELLO THIS IS
JORDAN FENSTER CALLING ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA YOUTH
CONNECTION IN A CROWD CO
SPONSOR AND IN SUPPORT OF THE
P. FORTY SIX. NINE TWO SEVENTY
ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON STEPHANIE
JIMENEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FORWARD ACTION FUND
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. SURE WE
HAVE NO FOR THE LINES IN Q.
THANK YOU WILL MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ARE NO
KEY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION-
NOBODY IN FORTY TWO OR THREE
WILL LOOK IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
NOBODY THERE AND WE'LL GO TO
THE PHONES- MODERATOR IF THERE
ARE WITNESSES CALLING IN IN
OPPOSITION TO AB FORTY SIX. WE
HEAR FROM THEM NOW. TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FORTY SIX
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE NO INCLUDED UP
MEASURE. THANK YOU MODERATOR
WILL GO BACK TO COMMITTEE AND-
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
DOCTOR PAN. I THINK IT'S VERY
MUCH AND I WANT TO THANK CENTER
THREE OF US FOR GIVING THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO INCREASE
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO BE OUT
HERE USE AND THE STATE AND
REALLY WANT APPRECIATED
LEADERSHIP IN THIS- JUST HAVE
ONE QUICK QUESTION PERHAPS YOU
CAN ADDRESSING YOUR CLOTHES-
KNOWING THAT WE'RE TRYING TO BE
SURE WE HAVE REPRESENTATION
FROM OPTICALLY UNDER REPRESENT
COMMUNITIES WE KNOW THAT
OFTENTIMES USE UNFORTUNATELY
MAY- BECAUSE OF LACK OF
RESOURCES OR NEED TO HELP OUT
THEIR FAMILIES- JUST CAN YOU
JUST ADDRESS- TERMS OF. I DID
AND I THINK IT TRIED TO THE
ANALYSIS LIKE DO THEY GET PER
DIEM UP THEY'LL TRAVEL EXPENSES
ETCETERA SO THAT PEOPLE CAN
FULLY PARTICIPATE- TO THE ALL
YOU CAN FULLY PARTICIPATE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO WE CAN
DISCUSS THAT NEW CLOTHES BUT
WHAT THANK YOU BRING THIS
FORWARD AND WILL. MOVE TO BUILD
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR PAN. I'LL JUST
MAKE A QUICK. COMMENT AND EAT
THEM ALIVE CLOSE YOU BY NO MY
NO VOTE IN THE PREVIOUS
COMMITTEE. AND I WANT TO ADDING
A CHANCE TO EXPLAIN THAT-
BEFORE- WE'VE GOT A BUNCH OF
NEW COMMISSIONS AND- GOVERNMENT
IDEAS COMING TO THE LEGISLATURE
THIS YEAR AND JUST AS A- MATTER
OF. I HAVE IT I'VE- BEEN VOTING
NO ON ALL OF THOSE. MOST OF
THOSE- NEW COMMISSIONS A NEW
BUREAUCRACIES SO. THAT THAT'S
ALL THIS WAS ON THIS VOTE I
ALSO. YOU KNOW BE VOTING NO
TODAY BUT I THINK WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH IS
ADMIRABLE AND- BUT THERE MIGHT
BE ALREADY WAYS IN OUR- IN OUR
STATE THAT WE CAN ACCOMPLISH IT
WITHOUT. STARTING UP A NEW
PIECE OF GOVERNMENT SO. THAT WE
DO HAVE A MOTION AND ALLOW YOU
TO CLOSE AN ADDRESS WHATEVER
COMMENTS YOU'D LIKE TO ADDRESS.
THANK YOU SENATORS YOU KNOW I
BELIEVE OUR DEMOCRACY IS BETTER
SERVED WHEN YOUTH ARE GIVEN AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTRIBUTE.
THEIR PERSPECTIVES ESPECIALLY
ON POLICY AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
COMMISSION- IS INTENDING TO DO
THAT'S WHY WE'RE TRYING TO
ESTABLISH IT- AS FAR AS PER
DIEM YES YOU KNOW. THEY WOULD
THAT THE EXPENSES WILL BE
COVERED- THE BILL- DOES REQUIRE
THE USE TO COME FROM DIFFERENT
TYPES OF BACKGROUNDS IS YOU MAY
HAVE READ IN THE ANALYSIS- TO
REALLY REPRESENT. THE USE IN
OUR STATE ARE AND YOU KNOW FOR
EXAMPLE HALF OF ALL THE
APPOINTEES MUST HAVE
EXPERIENCED A DISABILITY
HOMELESSNESS FOSTER CARE. OR
JUVENILE INCARCERATION- BEEN SO
THAT THAT'S THE INTENTION TO.
BRING IN A GROUP OF YOUTH THAT
COME FROM DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS- ACROSS THE STATE
AND- NO I UNDERSTAND YOUR
CONCERN SENATOR ABOUT. YOU KNOW
MORE COMMISSIONS- BUT I THINK.
THIS IS ONE THAT IS MISSING IN
OUR IN OUR STATE GOVERNMENT AND
THAT WILL ALLOW. YOU. TO
PARTICIPATE- AND GET IN. AT A
AGE AND THE CIVIC IN TERMS OF
BEING CIVICALLY ENGAGED SO
THAT'S WHY I THINK THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. OKAY THINK
YOU'RE MUCH AVAILABLE FROM
CENTER PAN WILL TAKE THE TAKE
THE ROLE. AB FORTY SIX THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS HER TADO. JONES
JONES NO. CORTESE KAMLAGER HI
COM LONGER AYE HI CAN I. K. THE
BILL HAS TO VOTE TO LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND DO YOU HAVE THE
SHEETS FOR THE- A CLEAN BILLS.
THANK YOU. RIGHT NEXT WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAZ ON A. B. FORTY SEVEN.
SUMMARY OF THE FOR. SURE DOWN
THE MEMBERS I PRESENT TO YOU AB
FORTY SEVEN WHICH WOULD
ESTABLISH A NEW PROGRAM TO
CREATE A COORDINATED AND
UNIFIED RESPONSE TO THE NEEDS
OF CHILDREN PARENTS AFFECTED BY
BORDER SEPARATION. DURING THE
PRIOR ADMINISTRATION'S ZERO
TOLERANCE IMMIGRATION POLICY.
IT IS ESTIMATED THAT AT LEAST
TWENTY SIX HUNDRED CHILDREN
WERE SEPARATED FROM THEIR
FAMILIES AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER. UPON REUNIFICATION MANY
HAVE SETTLED IN CALIFORNIA. THE
AFTER SEPARATING PARENTS FROM
THEIR CHILD. IS CRUEL AND
TRAUMATISING FOR BOTH PARENT
AND CHILD. AND IN ORDER TO
EFFECTIVELY AGENTS DRESSING THE
TRAUMA INFLICTED BY THIS
PRACTICE WE HAVE TO ENSURE
CHILDREN FAMILIES HAVE THEIR
BASIC NEEDS MET. AB FORTY SEVEN
AIMS TO CREATE A PROGRAM THAT
WORKS WITH NONPROFITS AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
TO CONNECT CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES AFFECTED BY BORDER
SEPARATION WITH EXISTING
RESOURCES THAT ENCOMPASS THE
FULL SCOPE OF FAMILIES NEEDS.
AMONG THOSE NEEDS ARE RESOURCES
SUCH AS HOUSING SERVICES FOOD
AND GROCERY RESOURCES LEGAL
RESOURCES AND MORE. HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
ARJONA NEVADO BETTIS WITH
SENECA FAMILY. OF AGENCIES AND
HAVE YET ON THIS WITH INLAND
COALITION FOR IMMIGRANT
JUSTICE. THANK YOU SOMEONE WILL
GO TO THE LEAD WITNESSES NOW. I
THINK CHINA NEVADA PAD AS ITS
FIRST. AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU
TO CHERYL TUTTLE AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JOHANNA
NAVARRO PRESS I'M A SOCIAL
WORKER AND THE DIRECTOR OF THE
TOTAL FOR ME FROM THE UP
PROGRAM AT SENECA FAMILY OF
AGENCIES. NATIONALLY LOCALLY
TAMIYA LOCATE FAMILIES IMPACTED
BY THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
FAMILY SEPARATION POLICY AND
CONNECTIONS MODOC ASSESSMENT
AND SERVICES WE COULD NOT DO
THAT WORK WITHOUT PARTNERING
WITH THE NATIONAL NETWORK OF
EXISTING CARE PROVIDERS. LIKE
KIDNEY AND ALLOW THEM I'M HERE
TODAY TO ENCOURAGE A CUSTOMER
EXIST NETWORK IN CALIFORNIA FOR
THE LONG TERM. AB FORTY SEVEN
WILL CONTINUE THE WORK OF
BRINGING NEEDED MENTAL HEALTH
AND BASIC NEEDS SERVICES TO
FAMILIES IMPACTED BY A ZERO
TOLERANCE WHO NOW RESIDE IN
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
THIS GROUP IS NOT A MONOLITH
LIKE ALL FAMILIES THAT
EXPERIENCED THE TRAUMA THEY ARE
WRITING. HEARING STORIES BUT
FOR MANY. THEY NEED TO SEE A
DOCTOR SPECIALIST URGENT IN THE
COMING MORE CRITICAL. I AM
LEAVING ACCORDING AND- SERVICES
NERVY. CRITICAL CARE MUST BE.
RICH IN TRAUMA INFORMED. IN OUR
RECORDS FAMILIES IMPACTED BY
THE ZERO TOLERANCE. NATIONALLY
MOM DAD SHARE THE FOLLOWING
REUNIFICATION THEIR CHILDREN
ARE STRUGGLING PHYSICALLY
PSYCHOLOGICALLY DAYS WEEKS
MONTHS AND YEARS AFTER
REUNIFICATION. AB FORTY SEVEN
ELEVEN AND ORGANIZED EXISTING
CARE PROVIDERS TO PROVIDE THIS
RESPONSE TO OUR STATE BUILT
AROUND AN ACCEPTABLE TOLL FREE
ONE LINE WE MUST KEEP SHOWING
UP TO THESE CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES. THEY ARE FRIENDLY OUR
FAMILIES OUR NEIGHBORS OUR
CHILDREN CLASSMATE FOR THAT
REASON. I URGE YOUR SUPPORT ON
AB FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. MANY MANY
MANY. I'M EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE IN THE COALITION PROGRAMS.
EVEN CLOSE TO PERMANENT JEFF
THAT IT BECAUSE LISTENABLE
RECORDS YOU CAN BE SENT THAT
COULD DEFINITELY ADVOCATE
IMPROVE THE LACK OF IMMIGRANT
AND AT ELEVEN SEVENTY NINE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY WE'RE PROUD TO
SUPPORT AB FORTY SEVEN
INTRODUCED BY MAJORITY LEADER
ELOISE BY IT. AB FORTY SEVEN
WILL CREATE MORE COORDINATION
BETWEEN VITAL SERVICES THAT
CALIFORNIA PROVIDES TO
IMMIGRANT PACIFIC WE KNOW THAT.
ROUTE THE IN HUMANE QUALITY OF
PAMELA SEPARATION UNDER THE
PREVIOUS PRESIDENTIAL
ADMINISTRATIONS IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE WELL ABOVE THE BORDER
REGIONS OF THE STATE WE HAVE
BEEN HOW THE BROKEN IN IN
HUMAN- I'M AGGRESSIVE POLICY-
HER OPPONENT DECONSTRUCTED
YOUTH AND MIGRANT BETTER
SPEAKING A BETTER LIFE IN THE
COUNTRY. ADMINISTRATION
WRECKAGE. OR ABANDONED I LOCAL.
BUT PATIENT HE CAME IN BUT
PRISON FAMILIES FIRST. AT THE
U. S. MEXICO BORDER. I POLICY
BECAME HARSHER AND SUPPORT WITH
EDITH. MANY TURN TO THAT. ORGAN
YOU THINK THAT THE END. OF IS.
HOW OUT AND JUST MORE SUPPORT
DURING THE THANK. WE ENDED. THE
NEED TO HAVE OR NEED IT.
RESPECTABLE I THE SERVICE.
WE'RE GOING TO BE. ALTHOUGH
FAMILY GRAYSON OUR POLICY WE
THE NEXT THREE YEARS AGO AND
STOP AT A FEW MONTHS WHERE
SEEING THE CURRENT. OF THE YOU
MEAN PAULA. MANY FAMILY HAVE
YET TO BE WE- AND ARE SO
PICKING. FROM NONPROFIT
ARGUMENT. LOCALLY I TO BE WITH
THEIR- CALIFORNIA CAN CONTINUE
WITH IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES AND
ENSURE THAT THOSE THAT HAVE
SUFFERED THROUGH THOSE HARD
PERFECT ARTISTIC QUALITY- HAVE
THE FOR THE- THESE CAN ACT.
BOUGHT AND SUPPORT OF A- THANK
YOU. THANK YOU BOTH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY AND- WILL MOVE
TO PUBLIC COMMENT IF SUPPORTERS
BEGINNING HERE AND ROUTE FORTY
TWO OR THREE. THE NONE OF ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. SANDERS WELL AND
WILL BE MOVING ON TO WITNESSES
OP YET TELL THE TELEPHONE-
CONFERENCE ONE. YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME WE'LL GO
FIRST TO LINE TO FIFTY FOUR.
THE COLD WAR OPEN ON BEHALF OF
THE CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER.
LINE. ONE NINETY EIGHT. HI
DANIELLE ONE DRUG WITH CHILDREN
NOW IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT LINE TO FIFTY THREE.
REBECA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
NINE TO TWELVE. TO THE RIGHT TO
ADDRESS THE ARE YOU CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. NINE TWO SEVENTY
TWO. JACKIE RETIRED THERE THAT
THE CALIFORNIA LINE COMMON
FAMILY SERVICES THE CLERK. NINE
ONE NINETY TWO. ALL THE AFGHAN
WITH THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. NINE TO SEVENTY FOUR.
ONE TWO SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE. THANKS CALLER A
COMMUNITY CHURCH. HEARING
NOTHING WILL MOVE ON THERE ARE
NO FOR THE LINES IN Q. THANK
YOU HAVEN'T HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS- WILL OF MOVE ON TO
LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WE
DON'T HAVE EIGHT EIGHT LEAD.
WITNESS BUT- WILL BEGIN PUBLIC
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL HERE IN THIS ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE. NONE OUR ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. ON THERE AS WELL-
NOW ON THE TELEPHONE PUBLIC
COMMENT NINE. AND TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. MADAM CHAIR WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU AT THIS
MOMENT WILL BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON THIS
BILL. NUMBER OF THE BILL. AND
WE HAVE A MOTION- WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR PAN ON. THIS
MEASURE AND A CONSULTING YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB FORTY
SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS HER
TADO LINE. FOR TITLE II JONES
CORTESE. KAMLAGER I COME LONGER
I'D PAN NIGHT AND I. WE WILL
PLACE THIS BILL- IN CALL- AND
NOW UP NEXT AP NINETY TWO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. AB NINETY TWO WILL
CREATE AN EQUITABLE SLIDING
SCALE FOR FAMILY FEES FOR CHILD
CARE THAT WILL ALLEVIATE THE
BURDEN ON WORKING FMILIES
STRUGGLING TO PAY FOR THE
SERVICES. CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF
THE MOST EXPENSIVE STATES FOR
PARENTS WHO NEED CHILD CARE
SERVICES. WELL THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF STATE AND FEDERALLY
FUNDED PROGRAMS THAT HELP
FAMILIES PAY FOR CHILD CARE
FAMILIES WHO NEED THIS THIS
CARE MUST TILL PAY WHAT IS
CALLED FAMILY FEES. THESE FEES
GROW AS INCOME RISES AND CAN BE
UP TO SIX HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
DOLLARS PER MONTH. WHICH IS NOT
AFFORDABLE FOR MANY WORKING
FAMILIES. THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS ONLY HEIGHTENED
THE NEED FOR AFFORDABLE CHILD
CARE. ESPECIALLY FOR WORKING
MOTHERS AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. WHO ARE SIGNIFICANT OR
SIGNIFICANT PART OF
CALIFORNIA'S ESSENTIAL
WORKFORCE. AB NINETY TWO WILL
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES BY
CONVENING A WORK GROUP OF
PARENTS PROVIDERS AND CHILD
CARE STAKEHOLDERS TO DEVELOP AN
EQUITABLE SLIDING SCALE FOR
FAMILY FEES THAT BETTER
REFLECTS FAMILIES BUDGETS. THE
BILL WILL PROTECT CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS BY ENSURING THEY DO
NOT ABSORB THE COST OF A
REDUCTION IN FAMILY FEES AND
THAT THE NUMBER OF CHILD CARE
SPACES IN CALIFORNIA IS NOT TO
REDUCED. FINALLY AB NINETY TWO
WOULD UTILIZE FEDERAL FUNDING
TO TEMPORARILY WAIVE FAMILY
FEES FOR ALL FAMILIES UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TO REDUCE
THE HARDSHIP OF COPA NINETY ON
CALIFORNIANS. AND AS PERMITTED
UNDER FEDERAL LAW. HERE TO
TESTIFY TODAY ARMY GUY A LOT
MORE THAN A PARENTS PAYING HIGH
FAMILY FEES FOR CHILD CARE. AND
LORI FURSTENFELD WITH A CHILD
CARE LAWCENTER. THANK YOU FOR
SWEETNESS YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS THE GUY
LAMARCA AND I LIVE IN RICHMOND
AND I'M A PROUD MEMBER APPARENT
WHITENESS I HAVE A SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLD AND TWO YEAR OLD. AND
I HAD TO MASTER DEGREE OF THE
MARRIAGE FAMILY THERAPIST AND
SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST I'M NOT
CENTRAL WORKER WORKING WITH
STUDENTS WITH SPECIAL NEEDS
WITHOUT CHILD CARE I WOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO GRADUATE THIS
PAST YEAR AND PROVIDE THE
SERVICES TO MY COMMUNITY. I
REPEAT TODAY AS YOUR NEIGHBOR
OUR SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST THE
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDER AND MY
MOST IMPORTANT ROLE I'M NOT.
IMAGINE NOT BEING ABLE TO PUT
YOUR BABY TO SLEEP BECAUSE YOU
HAVE TO WORK NIGHT OF THE
NUMBER EACH DRIVER TO PAY YOUR
BILL. AFTER OVER A YEAR OF
BEING ON THE CHILD CARE
WAITLISTS BUT CARE ACT OFFERED
THE ESSENTIAL WORKER CHILD CARE
VOUCHERS I WAS ABLE TO QUIT MY
SECOND JOB FOCUSED ON SCHOOL
AND GET THOSE MIGHT BACK TO MY
BABY WOULD BE ABLE TO FALL
ASLEEP IN MY ARMS. SPECIALLY IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN WHEN HE
THE TWO YEAR OLD ONE YEAR OLD
AT THE TIME CONTRACTED KOPET
I'M GRATEFUL BUT I DON'T KNOW.
I DIDN'T KNOW I WOULD HAVE TO
PAY A LATE FEE OF THREE HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER MONTH WE ARE LIVING
PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK I MAXED
OUT MY STUDENT LOANS MY HUSBAND
ANOTHER CENTRAL WORKER HAVE A
LONG COMMUTE AND HE AND HIS
INCOME GOES TO GAS AND LET.
TEAMS SHOOT YOU JENNY WE
COULDN'T MAKE IT BOB WE
COULDN'T MAKE. THEM BECAUSE OF
OUR FAMILY BE A MATCHING HAVING
TO RISK THAT LECTURES TO BEAT
THE PAPER CHILD CARE IF THESE
WERE LIMITED I WOULD USE THE
THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS EVEN
IMMEDIATELY TO CATCH UP IN PAIN
FOR URGENT NEEDS. THOUSANDS OF
FAMILIES LIKE MINE WOULD DO THE
SAME MY FAMILY HE IS ALSO
CONNECTED ANTI BOND BACK MY
FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDER THE
STATE REDUCES HER PAYCHECK AND
EXPECT MY FAMILY TO MAKE UP THE
DIFFERENCE SHE HOURS CLEANING
AND SANITIZING BECAUSE SHE
CAN'T AFFORD EITHER. EVEN IF WE
RAINY PROVIDER RATE THAT WE
DON'T WAIT FAMILIES THESE
PROVIDERS AND FAMILIES WILL
CONTINUE. TO SUFFER FROM THE
SYSTEM AS IT IS. FOR CALLING ON
TO PLAY HAVE AB NINE TWO. AND
THE FACT THE PAIN FOR CHILD
CARE ON THE BACK TO WORK FAMILY.
AND PROVIDERS ALREADY STRETCHED
THIN. WE SHOULD BE WAIVED
TRITON. TWO TWENTY THREE. THERE
ARE FEDERAL FUNDS ASIDE FOR
THIS HOW SHOULD NOT WAY. CHILD
CARE IS THE REGIONAL AND IT MAY
CHILL. LIKE MY SON MATT AND-
THE RIGHTS. ARE FAMILIES.
SHOULD NOT HAPPENED. DO I HE
MIGHT. B. OR DO I HE MIGHT. WE
ADDRESS PARKS CARE. CRISIS AND-
EXPERTISE HARD SHALL CHILD CARE
SYSTEM. IMAGINE FUTURE WHERE
WORKING OR HAVE TO WORK ONE JOB
AT BRITES AND STRENGTHENED
HEALTHY ATTACHED. BETWEEN CHILD.
AND PARENT. WHERE DON'T HAVE TO
TAKE BETWEEN WRITING AND HAVING.
NEEDS SUCH AS UTILITY HOW AND
FOOD HI THREE CLEAN FUTURE AND
WHAT I YOU TO JOIN US WE NEED
YOUR- AB NINETY TWO WELL MOST
OF. R. J. MAJOR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK NEXT WITNESS.
EVERY CHILD DESERVES TO GROW UP
IN A LOVING HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS DESERVE TO
BE FAIRLY PAID FOR THE VITAL
WORK THEY DO AND EVERY PARENT
HAS THE RIGHT TO PROVIDE FOR
THEIR FAMILY AND LORI
FURSTENFELD CO DIRECTOR OF
LEGAL AND LEGISLATIVE ADVOCACY
FOR THE CHILD CARE LAWCENTER.
AB NINETY TWO IS A PANDEMIC
RELIEF ILL THAT IMMEDIATELY
PUTS MONEY BACK INTO THE
POCKETS OF FAMILY AND CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS PARTICULARLY
WOMEN OF COLOR AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE PANDEMIC CALIFORNIA
TEMPORARILY WAY FAMILY FEES FOR
ALL FAMILIES WITH THE PUBLICLY
FUNDED CHILD CARE SUBSIDY
THROUGH AUGUST TWENTY TWENTY
THE SOLUTION ALLOWED PARENTS
WHO WERE ESSENTIAL WORKERS TO
KEEP WORKING AND ENSURE CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS CAN A OPENED BY
PAYING THEM IN FULL. FROM
SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY UNTIL
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE FAMILY FEES ARE WAIVED ONLY
FOR FAMILIES WHO ARE NOT
SENDING THEIR CHILDRENTO CHILD
CARE DUE TO COVERAGE UNDER THE
FEDERAL EMERGENCY RELIEF
FUNDING LIVE WE NOW HAVE A
NARROW WINDOW TO SEIZE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE ALL
FAMILIES WHO REALLY FROM FAMILY
FEES NOW. FIRST THIS BILL
TEMPORARILY RAISING FAMILY
PEACE FOR ALL FAMILIES UNTIL
OCTOBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THREE REDUCE THE
HARDSHIPS OF THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC SECOND THE FEDERAL
CHILD CARE DEVELOPMENT BLOCK
GRANT ACT THE MAIN SOURCE OF
FEDERAL FUNDING FOR CHILD CARE
IN CALIFORNIA MANDATE THAT THE
REQUIRED FAMILY FEES MUST BE
AFFORDABLE AND NOT A BARRIER.
TO FAMILIES RECEIVING CHILD
CARE ASSISTANCE. HOW THEY HAVE
NOT THE AFFORDED FOR MANY YEARS
AND- HAS GREAT L. HOW ON
AFFORDABLE FAMILY FEES IMPACT
WITH UNIX BLACK AND OTHER
FAMILIES OF COLOR. THEREFORE
EIGHTY NINETY TO CONVENE THE
BROAD WORK GROUPS TO CREATE AN
EQUITABLE FAMILY FEAST GADGIL
ONCE THE REQUIRED FAMILY FEES
GO BACK INTO A FACT. EIGHTY
NINETY TWO IS MODELED AFTER
PRESIDENT BIDEN CHILD CARE PLAN
AND THE FEDERAL CHILD CARE FOR
WORKING FAMILIES ACT OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. IMPORTANTLY AB
NINETY TO PROTECT CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS BY ENSURING THEY ARE
PAID IN FULL. THEY'RE BOTH THE
TEAM AND DO NOT ABSORB THE
REDUCTION AND FAMILY FEES. THIS
IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT AT THIS
TIME IN THE ADMINISTRATION IS
RESISTING THAT THEY BE PAID A
LIVING WAGE. AND ALSO ENSURES
THE NUMBER OF CHILD CARE SPACES
IS NOT READING. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IDOL. I
THANK YOU BOTH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND WILL MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT IN SUPPORT HERE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE.
THREE NINE- THE ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. NONE THERE AS WELL AND
NOW IN OUR TOTAL PUBLIC COMMENT
LINE. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. LOCAL FIRST
IN LINE TO SIXTY NINE GLAD.
SHARE MEMBERS KATHY MUSCLE FOR
THE FIRST TIME SO SHE SHOULD OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINETY TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU.
PINE TO FIFTY FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
COAL BOARDMAN ON BEHALF OF SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY AND THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. PINE. TO
SEVENTY SEVEN. MINE TOO PARDON
ME A LINE ONE NINETY EIGHT I
THINK WE'VE OPENED YOUR LINE
INSTEAD. HI THIS IS DANIELLE
ONE DRUG WITH CHILDREN NOW IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NOW LINE TO SEVENTY SEVEN GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON JASON
SOME ITEMS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
WILL TURN IT PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LINE TWO FIFTY
THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON WHAT
BECKETT GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
NINE TO TWENTY FIVE. HI DIANA
DOMINGUEZ ON BEHALF OF CHILD
CARE RESOURCE CENTER IN SUPPORT
OF AB NINETY TWO WEAVING FAMILY
FEES AND BEGINNING THE FAMILIES
THE REFORM PROCESS HELP US GET
CLOSER TO JUSTICE FOR FAMILIES
AND- FAIR WAGES FOR A CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS. THANK YOU BLIND.
TO SEVENTY NINE- GOOD
AFTERNOON- COUNTY DOWN OFTEN
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
CALIFORNIA PROUD CO SPONSOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
NINE TWO SEVENTY FIVE. HE IS A
BABY WITH A CALIFORNIA CHILD
CARE RESOURCE CENTER FROM
NETWORK PROBABLY CONFRONTING
THE TONE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NINE TWO EIGHTY. GOOD AFTERNOON
CALLING BACKGROUND WE HAVE THE
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. BLIND TO
SEVENTY SIX. BUT AFTERNOON
DAMPENING ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF
SILICON VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT. KLEIN.
TWO SEVENTY EIGHT. LINE TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT. NEXT CALLER. YES
GO AHEAD PLEASE. PINE. TO FORTY
FIVE. KIND OF DECLARE LOOKED
SHOCKED WITH THE NATIONAL
COUNCIL OF JEWISH WOMEN
CALIFORNIA. I'M SUPPORT OF AB.
NINETY TWO. LINE TWO EIGHTY
FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
BILLY MCKAY CALLING ON BEHALF
OF FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU. WE HAVE TWO
MORE LINES IN Q. ONE MORE ONE
MORE WHILE THE PROVIDER LINE
NUMBERS.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
LINE TWO EIGHTY TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON PRESS THE NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP ON
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN THE COURT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. BLIND TO
EIGHTY FOUR. THE NEW MARTIKA
REPRESENTED LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SORRY A
LITTLE LATE ON EIGHTY FORTY
SEVEN IN SUPPORT OF AB FORTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU HAVE. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. PINE TO FORTY
EIGHT GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS RAVENNA KARAKTER
ELLIOT CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
CONSORTIUM AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU. WE
HAVE NO FOR THE LINES INTO
MADAM CHAIR GO AHEAD PLEASE.
OKAY THANK YOU- AT THIS MOMENT
WILL GO AHEAD AND MOVE ON TO
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL. BEGINNING HERE AND-
IN THE ROOM. SEEING NONE MOVING
ON TO- TWENTY FORTY MANDERS
WHILE AND THE NOW UNDER TOTAL
PUBLIC COMMENT MIND. ALL THOSE
IN OPPOSITION TO A BILL NINETY
TWO. HI WE CAN OPPOSITION PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO THIS TIME ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. DO WE HAVE ANY
CALLERS. NINE TWO SEVENTY EIGHT
GO AHEAD PLEASE. I AM ACTUALLY
IN SUPPORT IF YOU GET THE
CUSTOMER ON BEHALF OF EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES AND THE STAR
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES NETWORK IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WE HAVE NO FOR THE LIONS
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU. FOR I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL-
NOW MORE THAN EVER WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT- WORKING PARENTS
CAN AFFORD THE CHILD CARE THAT
THEY NEED- THE WORKGROUP
CREATED BY THIS BUILDING
REASONABLE AND MEASURED STEP
TOWARDS THAT GOAL AND- WE'LL
ALL GO AHEAD AND OPEN IT UP TO
QUESTIONS UNDER OTHER COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MOVED
THE BILL. OKAY HOLE WE HAVE A
MOTION AND WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE OKAY WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR PAN AND
CONSULTING YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AB NINETY TO THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS HER TADO AYE
HURTADO AYE JONES. CORTESE
CORTESE I'D COME LONGER ALL
RIGHT KAMLAGER AYE PAN AYE PAN
AYE. THANK YOU WILL PLACE THAT
BUILT ON CALL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE LOOKING
FOR AN OFFERING OF. I NEED TO
DO IT AND IT HAVE A SIGH OF
RELIEF TO. YEAH. WE THE ROLE
FOR THE- FOR. KELLY OPEN ROLES
KESSLER OPEN UP. YEAH DISCOM UP.
STILL. YEAH YEAH. THE MOBILE
CAN DO ADD ONS WHILE WE WAIT
FOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS TO
JOIN US BACK IN THE ROOM FOR
HIS PRESENTATION I KNOW HE HAS
BEEN WAITING PATIENTLY HERE FOR
QUITE SOME TIME SO- WELL HE
GETS BACK WE WILL- TO BE ADD
ONS CONSULTANT. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. OKAY AB SIX NINE FIVE BY
ARAMBULA THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY HER
TADO I FOR TITLE II JONES COM
LONGER. KAMLAGER I LIVE. THE
BILL IS PASSED ALONG CALL. AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE BY
THREE OF US THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
HER TADO HI FOR TITLE II
CORTESE HI. CORTEZ THE I. COM
LONGER. KAMLAGER I PAN NIGHT
CAN I. CONVO IS FIVE ZERO ON
THAT MEASURE IN THE BILL IS OUT.
AB FORTY SIX BY THREE OF US THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
RE REFER TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS HER TADO I. HER
TITLE I CORTESE AYE CORTEZ THE
ICE. THAT BILL IS OUT ON- FOUR
ONE VOTE. AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SALAS HAS JOINED US FOR HIS
PRESENTATION. RELATIVE HERE'S A
PLEASE FORGIVE THE- MEDICALLY
NECESSARY THIS WEEK SO I
APPRECIATE. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
INDULGENCE ON THAT BUT LET ME
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
EIGHTY THREE WHICH WOULD
ESTABLISH AN OLDER ADULT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
ADMINISTRATOR TO OVERSEE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FOR OLDER
ADULTS ESTABLISH OUTCOME
INDICATORS INTEGRATE CARE AND
STANDARDIZE GERIATRICS TRAINING
FOR MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS. WE KNOW THAT ONE
IN FIVE OLDER ADULTS EXPERIENCE
MENTAL MENTAL HEALTH CONCERNS
HOWEVER LESS THAN ONE THIRD OF
ALL OLDER ADULTS IN THE UNITED
STATES WHO NEED MENTAL HEALTH
CARE ACTUALLY RECEIVE IT.
UNDIAGNOSED AND UNTREATED
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES HAVE A
SERIOUS IMPACT FOR OLDER ADULTS
AND THEIR LOVED ONES FROM.
NINETEEN NINETY ONE TO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA SITE 58%
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
SUICIDES FOR THOSE AGE SIXTY
FIVE TO EIGHTY FOUR. AND A 50%
INCREASE FOR THOSE EIGHTY FIVE
AND OLDER YES COMPARED TO
FOURTEEN POINT 8% AVERAGE
STATEWIDE ACROSS ALL AGE GROUPS
SUICIDE RATES ARE PARTICULARLY
HIGH IN RURAL PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA WHERE ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH CARE IS SEVERELY
LACKING. IN CALIFORNIA THE
OLDER ADULT POPULATION WILL
INCREASE 64% BY THE YEAR TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE TO TWELVE MILLION
ADULTS AGE SIXTY AND ABOVE BY
THAT SAME TIME THE US CENSUS
WHILE NUMBER USED FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN OUR NATION'S HISTORY. A
STUDY CONDUCTED BY THE UCLA
CENTER FOR HEALTH POLICY
RESEARCH FOUND A NUMBER OF
CHALLENGES AND DEFICIENCIES IN
THE CURRENT BEHAVIOR HEALTH
STRUCTURE FOR OLDER ADULTS.
THAT THIS BILL SEEKS TO ADDRESS
BY ESTABLISHING STATEWIDE
LEADER. GIVEN THE RAPIDLY
GROWING SEGMENT OF THE STATE'S
POPULATION THAT IS MADE UP OF
OLDER ADULTS IN THE SIGNIFICANT
AND UNIQUE CHALLENGES. THAT
OLDER ADULTS FACE IT IS
CRITICAL THAT THE STATE
APPOINTED LEADER IN A DOCTOR
PLANTING CREASE IMPROVE. AND
INTEGRATE MENTAL AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES FOR OLDER
ADULTS. ON THE PHONE LINE TO
TESTIFY IS DOCTOR JANET FRANK A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING AND ONE OF
THE LEAD AUTHORS OF THE STUDY
CONDUCTED BY THE UCLA CENTER
FOR HEALTH POLICY. AND I ALSO
HAVE SURELY CROWN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA SENIOR
LEGISLATURE. THANK YOU. WHAT
MRS MAY PROCEED. HELLO MY NAME
IS- JANET FRANK AND I'M
PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON AGING
I AM A COMMISSIONER AND ALSO ON
FACULTY AT THE UCLA FIELDING
SCHOOL OF PUBLIC HEALTH. IN OUR
STUDY SPONSORED BY THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION. WE
FOUND THAT FEW PROGRAMS OR
OUTREACH EFFORTS FOR TAYLOR TO
THE COMPLEX CARE NEEDS FOR
OLDER ADULTS. WE ALSO
IDENTIFIED SIGNIFICANT UNMET
SERVICE NEEDS AND GEOGRAPHIC
DISPARITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
FOR EXAMPLE OF THE ESTIMATED
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND OLDER
CALIFORNIANS IN NEED OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES ONLY
4% RECEIVE SERVICES AND FISCAL
YEAR EIGHTEEN. WHILE OLDER
ADULTS ARE 16% OF THE ADULT
MEDICAID POPULATION LESS THAN
2% RECEIVE EVEN ONE SPECIALTY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE. DATA
FROM THE CALIFORNIA BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PLANNING COUNCIL ALSO
SUPPORT OUR STUDIES FINDING.
IMPORTANTLY FOR THIS BILL WE
NOTED THAT THERE IS A LACK OF
LEADERSHIP AT THE STATE FOR
OLDER ADULT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES. ASKING AB THREE
EIGHTY THREE NOW IS CRITICAL
BECAUSE IT SUPPORTS IMPORTANT
POLICY TRIP- DIRECTION
INCLUDING THE HELP REIMAGINE
GOAL OF THE CALIFORNIA MASTER
PLAN ON AGING. IN ADDITION THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES OFFICE OF MEDICARE
INNOVATION AND INTEGRATION A
COMPUTER A COMPONENT OF THE
MASTER PLAN AIMS TO LEAD
INNOVATIVE MODELS FOR DUAL
ELIGIBLES AND MEDICARE ONLY
INDIVIDUAL. THE PROPOSED
CONCESSION IN AB TREATED THREE
WOULD BE A KEY RESOURCE FOR
THAT AFTER. IN ADDITION CAL.
CULTURE ADMINISTRATOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INTEGRATION
STATEWIDE AND THE PHYSICIAN
WILL BE IMPORTANT SURE SURE
THAT THE GAPS IN OLDER ADULTS
ARE EXTRA. WITHOUT STATE
OVERSIGHT AND LEADERSHIP OLDER
ADULTS ESPECIALLY VULNERABLE
OLDER ADULTS WHO ARE FROM LOW
INCOME GROUPS AND FOR MINORITY
GROUPS WILL CONTINUE BEING
UNDERSERVED AB TREATING DREAM
PROVIDES RESOURCES TO ADDRESS
THE STATEWIDE EQUITY ISSUE. AS
EMPHASIZED DURING PANDEMIC THE
SITUATION IS DIRE AND REQUIRES
IMMEDIATE ATTENTION RIGHT NOW
THERE IS NOT ONE PERSON. YOU
HAVE THE RESPONSIBILITY TO HELP
THE SYSTEM BECOME MORE
RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS OF
OLDER CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU AND
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU- NEXT
WITNESS. DO WE HAVE SHIRLEY
CROWN ON THE LINE. NO OKAY.
WILL MOVE ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AB
THREE EIGHTY THREE HEARING ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE. C. NINE
ROOM TWENTY FOUR LIVE THROUGH
WE DO HAVE SURELY CROWN ONLINE
OKAY. SHOULD WE WILL BACK UP
INTO A- PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE.
THIS KRONER LINE SHOULD BE OPEN
PLEASE ON BEACH UPON. CHARLIE
CORNER LINE SHOULD BE OPEN. FOR
YOU TO SPEAK. MY APOLOGIES
WE'RE NOT GETTING A RESPONSE
FROM HER OKAY WELCOME TO MOVE
FORWARD- SO IF WE CAN OPEN UP
THE TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMON
LINE FOR THOSE WAITIN TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
EIGHTY THREE. TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO
TWELVE TO GO AHEAD. IF ANY
RIGHT WHAT DOES THE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THE ONE ON THE LINE
IN Q. ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE
THE PROVIDER LINE NUMBER TO
THEM. ONE MOMENT. IF. WHO WOULD
WANT TO NINETY ONE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. ONE MOMENT PLEASE WE'RE
HAVING TECHNICAL DIFFICULTY.
SHARE MEMBER CAN HEAR ME YES. A
LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU PER THOUGHT YOU DON'T ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRISTS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU. WE
HAVE NO FOR THE LINES IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU AND
WILL MOVE TO LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- WE DON'T HAVE ANY
HERE ON THE RECORD BUT- BOLD
MOVE ON TO. THOSE AT THE WANT
TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION IN
THIS ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE.
THE NONE TWENTY FORTY. OUR
NUMBERS WHILE AND NOW ON THE
TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT LINE
IN OPPOSITION TO AB THREE
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE. TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB THREE
EIGHTY THREE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MADAM CHAIR
WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU
DO YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MOVED BY APOLOGIES BELCHER WE
DID HAVE A SIBLING TO A PLATE
AS I WAS SPEAKING. DO I
UNDERSTAND OUTLINED. IT YES.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU GO AHEAD
LINE ONE NINETY TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY APOLOGIES I'M
HAVING SOME TECHNICAL BASED ON
MY OWN BUT- A POLL OF THE AFTER
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND WE'RE IN
SUPPORT I TRY TO GET YOU UP
UNDER SUPPORT AND IT WAS IT WAS
NOT SUCCESSFUL BUT MY APOLOGIES
AND THANK YOU FOR. LETTING ME
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
OKAY SO WE'RE MOVING WE'RE
CONTINUING TO MOVE FORWARD AND-
THERE'S NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS POINT TO END THE
FEDERAL WE HAVE A MOTION- THE
SUMMER SAUSAGE LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE WAS TO MORE FOR SENIORS
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND
CONSULTA Q. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AB THREE EIGHT THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS FURTADO I. HER
TADO I'D JONES CORTESE I CORTES
THE I. COM WALKER HI CAMARGO HI
PAN. AM PAN HI. THANK YOU. HILL
AND WE HAVE. WE HAVE A WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT IN THE
ROOM SO WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
TAKE- UP AGENDA ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU AND WELCOME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MANAGER-
AND MEMBERS SAID PROJECT SUFFER
20% TO EIGHTY NINE FORTY ONE IT
WILL ESTABLISH A WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND DEVELOPMENT- A
FARMWORKER RESOURCE CENTER AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL- IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WE ESTABLISH SUCH A
CENTER IN VENTURA COUNTY AND I
HAVE BEEN VERY IMPRESSED WITH
IT AND I THINK. BOTH OUR
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY AND OUR
REPRESENTATIVE FARMWORKERS SAID
INVENTOR COUNTY HAVE ALSO BEEN
VERY PLEASED WITH IT WHILE IT
WAS- CONSIDERED RISKY AND
CONTROVERSIAL WHEN WE FIRST
IMPLEMENTED AT- THE A
COMMUNITY- WAS IN PARTICULAR-
CONCERNING RESISTANT THEY ARE
NOW VERY STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF
THE FARM BUREAU OF VENTURA
COUNTY'S ACTUALLY COME OUT IN
FAVOR OF THE SO HAS I'VE GOTTA
COME UP HERE TO- SACRAMENTO I
WANTED TO TRY TO DO THE SAME
THING WHICH IS EXPAND. THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FARMWORKERS
IN THE REST OF VENTURA COUNTY
TO BE EXPOSED TO THIS- AND THE
IDEA HERE IS TO TRY TO GET
ENOUGH COUNTIES DOING IT THAT
WE COULD REALLY GET A FEEL FOR
HOW THIS WORKS AND- WHETHER
THIS IS A GOOD THING FOR US TO
CONTINUE TO TRY TO ENCOURAGE
AND AT A MINIMUM HAVE THE MOST
INTERESTED COUNTIES. HAVE SOME
INCENTIVE TO TRY THIS PROGRAM
AND I THINK ONCE THEY TRY IT
THEY WILL BE VERY CONVINCED AS
TO ITS VALUE- FINALLY I JUST
WANT TO NOTE THAT I MADE A
REQUEST FOR THREE MILLION
DOLLARS. TO FUND THIS PROGRAM-
FOR THE FIRST TWO YEARS A AND-
THAT- FUNDING IS SHE IN THE
BUDGET JUNIOR HIGH- THAT- IS
MOVING FORWARD AT THIS POINT IN
TIME WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY
AS KELLY BROOK'S LENZI ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF
VENTURA- AND LUCAS SUCKER ON
BEHALF OF COSTS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU WHAT WHAT MRS MAY PROCEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS KELLY
FOR LENDING ON BEHALF VENTURA
COUNTY. AND COUNTY-
CORRECTIONAL SERVICES AGENCY
RUN BY FARMWORKER RESOURCE
PROGRAM AT THREE LOCATIONS. THE
PROGRAM IS DESIGNED TO BUILD
TRUST AND RELATIONSHIPS AMONG
THE AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY AND
TO ASSIST IN FACILITATING
PROMPT RESOLUTION TO WORKPLACE
CONCERNS. SUCH AS PAYROLL
ISSUES AND WORKING CONDITIONS.
NAVIGATING AVAILABLE PUBLIC
AGENCIES AND LEVERAGING
EXISTING RESOURCES. SINCE JULY
OF TWENTY NINETEEN VENTURA
COUNTY FARMWORKER RESOURCE
PROGRAM HAS ASSISTED OVER
FOURTEEN HUNDRED CLIENTS.
FARMWORKERS HAVE CONNECTED WITH
THE COUNTY ON VERY ISSUES
INCLUDING EMPLOYMENT LABOR LAWS
HOUSING IMMIGRATION. FINANCIAL
INTO IT AT THE CENTER. AND MANY
OTHER ENQUIRIES RELATED TO
SUPPORT SERVICES. IN ADDITION
THE PROGRAMMING AND DEMOCRATS
SAID DEBORAH THREE THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED APPLICATIONS FOR
THE FARMER HOUSEHOLD. PROGRAM
SH. FORTY ONE OFFERS NECESSARY
SUPPORTS YOUR BANNER REPLICATE
THE MILE. MARKER RESOURCE
CENTERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE. I
CAN'T EXPERIENCE AND ABOUT AN
OP A FARM ON THE RESOURCE
PROGRAM POINT TO POSITIVE
OUTCOMES. I THINK THIS
CONNECTION THE SERVICES THAT
KEEP IT HOW BAD AND FINANCIALLY
STABLE. THE PANDEMIC HI THE
NATURE OF IRAQ OR HI. SUPPORT
TO THE COMMUNITY OF WORKER SH
FOR THESE REASONS COUNTY OF
VENTURA SUPPORT EIGHTY NINE ONE
ZERO. ON THE MEASURE. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. WHERE DO MONEY IS
LUCAS ON THE TO FOR CALL WE'RE
ALSO DOCTORS ARE AND THEN
TURNED ABOUT AND ONE OF OUR
MAIN AREA OF FOCUS IS
ORGANISING FARMWORKERS HAD TO
KEEP BETTER WORKING CONDITIONS
WE ARE DEEPLY INVOLVED IN THE
CREATION THE FARMWORKER
RESOURCE PROGRAM AND THE CHORE
COUNTY. DID PROGRAM REALLY
EMERGED A CLEVER DIALOGUE
BETWEEN US OTHER LOCAL FARMER
ORGANIZATIONS AND I GUESS HE
LEADERS INCLUDING THE LARGEST
MOST PROMINENT GROWING DEMAND.
FOR COUNTY- THE PUBLIC RECORDS
WILL INTENDED TO GOT NEEDED
PEOPLE FORCE THAT THAN THAT OF
MANY DIFFICULT FOR. SPECS SIZE
RIGHT. THAT RIGHT NOW MANY
FARMERS STRUGGLE NAVIGATE. MANY
DIFFERENT EVEN FOR AND SAFETY
WAIT STAFF AT THE SIDE
RETALIATION THE- OFTEN WITH A
LOCK ON THE GROUND PRESIDENT-
OF LABOR AGENCIES AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE- MANY AGENCIES WILL HAVE
A LACK OF. LANGUAGE. ABOUT THE
MANY THE ORAL INDIGENOUS.
UNITY'S FROM SOME MEXICO. THE
LANGUAGE ARE COMMONLY SPOKEN
AMONG HELP FARMER. AND THE OUR
CAN BE OFTEN NOT. FORM BECAUSE
OF LONG HOURS AND FEEL. AND SO
WE REALLY DROUGHT DESPITE
HOLDING THE TREE THE PUBLIC
HEARING THE MENTOR COUNTY ALONG
FARMWORKERS TO. DESIGN THE
PROGRAM THEMSELVES BY GIVING
PUBLIC COMMENT THE COMMITTEE
TASKED WITH IMPLEMENTATION. THE
AFTER HOURS TO BE ELEVEN AT
SEVEN PM FOR A ONE STOP SHOP
LOCATION IN THE- HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY WHERE MANY WORKERS GO TO
SIGN THEIR- KIDS UP MEDIKAL-
FOR. LANGUAGE ABOUT THE
MYSTICAL ANOTHER INDIGENOUS.
LANGUAGES- THE COURT AGREED
PROGRAM HOW FARMWORKERS NOT
THAT FILING PROCESS EIGHTY. BUT
ALSO PROVIDE FARMWORKERS AN
OPTION. TO ENGAGE IN A DIRECT
RESOLUTION CALL THEM PLOY OR
CAN WE LEARN MORE ABOUT THEIR
LABOR LIKE THE TOP. I AM. SO WE
BELIEVE THAT FOR GROUP DOESN'T
REPLACE EXISTING LABOUR MP
CAUGHT THE- BUT ADDED VALUE TO.
THE USE OF IT AND MAKE IT WORK
BETTER FOR FARMWORKERS OUT WE
REALLY THINK THAT THE IT'S A
GREAT MODEL THAT CAN BE
REPLICATED IN OTHER COMMUNITIES
AND ALLOW. YOU KNOW SOME SOME
LOCAL. DECISION MAKING ROOTED
IN THE NEED A FARMWORKERS AND
COULDN'T COME AT A BETTER TIME
THE PANDEMIC HAS REVEALED THE
NEED TO REALLY SUPPORT THE
CENTRAL FARMWORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY MOVIE ON TO
PUBLIC COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE HIM FORTY TWO OR
THREE. SEEN ON MOVING ON TO
TWENTY FORTY. NUMBER AS WELL
NOW ON TO OUR TELEPHONE PUBLIC
COMMENT ONE. TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO
FIFTY THREE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON REBECCA GONZALEZ
NATIONALIST EDUCATION ACROSS
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
WORK THANK YOU. NINE TO NINETY
FOUR. CHEN MEMBER BRIAN CHAU
BUNDY HAPPENS THAT CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE AND AGRICULTURE NETWORK
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY NINE FORTY
ONE THANKS THANK YOU. BLIND.
TWO HUNDRED. AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE FACT THAT
WE'RE WAITING FOR COURT FOR
EIGHTY NINE FOUR ONE HALF THE
CALIFORNIA FOOD AND FINING
NETWORK THAT CALIFORNIA
LOCATION OF FOOD BANK.
CALIFORNIA FOR PESTICIDE REFORM
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA BERMAN
OBJECT AT NETWORK. COMMUNITY
TRUST AND ONLY NOT BE
ANNIHILATED BY THE LAYOUT YOU
CANNOT WALK AND YOUNG. FIBRE
SHAD NATURAL REPORT RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL PESTICIDE
ACTION NETWORK GROUPS OF CHANGE
WELCOME CALIFORNIA AND THE
UNITED FOOD AND COMMERCIAL
WORKERS WESTERN STATE COUNCIL
THANK YOU FOR MUCH. THANK YOU
WE HAVE NO FOR THE LINES WE
HAVE NO FOR THE LINES IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME OKAY FAMILY NON
THERE IS NO LEAD OPPOSITION FOR
THIS BILL BUT WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION BEGIN
HERE FORTY TWO OR THREE. SEE
NON. TWENTY FORTY. AND ON THERE
AS WELL AND WILL. NOW GO TO THE
TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT LINE
FOR THOSE WHO WANT TO COMMENT
IN OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL. TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ELEVEN
CHAIR WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUED UP.
WHILE AT THE SAME HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMP FROM A
CENTER PAN OF WHAT WORLD
HERITAGE SITE THINK KATHERINE
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
APPRECIATE THAT BUILDING ON THE
MODEL THAT- THAT RESULT IN
VENTURA COUNTY AND TRYING TO
EXPAND IT TO ADDITIONAL
COUNTIES AND- SO CERTAINLY ONE
OF THE MOVE TO BUILD
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND IT A COMMITTEE
MEMBER AND WE HAVE SENT A
COURTESY. OKAY- IT WAS REALLY
JUST A COMMENT- IN EXPLANATION
OF MY VOTE I'M GOING TO. BE
STAYING OFTEN THE REASON FOR MY
EXTENSION IS SORRY- INQUIRED
ABOUT THE BILL AND WHILE I
CERTAINLY SUPPORT- THE WORK
THAT THE BILL WILL BE DOING- I
WAS DISAPPOINTED THAT- IT'S NOT
INCLUSIVE IN ANY WAY- THAT WE
CAN UNDERSTAND OF. EXISTING
FARMWORKERS SISTER RESOURCE
CENTERS AND HAVING. INVESTED A
GREAT DEAL OF BLOOD SWEAT AND
TEARS ALONG WITH A LOT OF OTHER
PEOPLE TO SET UP THE CENTRAL
COAST. OF FARMWORKERS CENTER
ALONG WITH U. OF W. IN.
FOLKESTONE IN FOUR DIFFERENT
COUNTIES AND KNOWING HOW IT
STRUGGLES FOR ANY LEVEL OF
ASSISTANCE- YOU KNOW EVEN A
SMALL GRANT OF TWENTY FIVE TO
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS WOULD
BE. TREMENDOUSLY SUPPORTIVE TO
THEM THEY DON'T. NEED THAT KIND
OF A DOLLARS THAT SORT THE
REQUIRED TO STAND UP. YOU KNOW
A NEW FACILITY LIKE HALF A
MILLION DOLLARS TO GET STARTED-
BUT THEY DO STRUGGLING THEY DO
PROVIDE EVERY SINGLE ONE OF.
THOSE FOR THE RESOURCES AND
SERVICES THAT. ARE PRESCRIBED
IN THE BILL SO- I'M A BIG
SUPPORTER OF GETTING THESE
RESOURCES. OUT THERE I. AM
DON'T VOTE NO FARMWORKERS
SYSTEMS- AND I SERVING DO THAT-
BUT I ALSO DON'T WANT FOLKS. IN
MY DISTRICT THE- WHO HAD DUG
DEEP IN THEIR POCKETS TO TRY TO
SUPPORT AN ACTIVITY LIKE THIS-
THAT SEARCH FOR COUNTIES- TO.
YOU KNOW COME TO ME LATER AND
SAY. OH WHY WOULD YOU SUPPORT A
MEASURE THAT LEAVES US OUT SO
YOU KNOW HOPEFULLY THAT'S A
CLEAR EXPLANATION FOR AMOUNT ON
IT AND AGAIN I DO APPLAUD THE
AUTHOR FOR- YOU KNOW FOR YOUR
INTENTIONS AND THEN TRYING TO
EXPAND THIS KIND OF WORK. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM-
WHICH YOU WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
YES IT WOULD NINE REALLY
APPRECIATE- OF THE- COMMENTS
ARE MADE BY- CENTER CORTESE-
THEN IN TERMS OF THIS- IF I
COULD OFFER. THE ONLY REASON
THERE IS AN EXPLICIT LANGUAGE
IN HERE IDENTIFYING CURRENT
ONES IS HAS I BROUGHT THIS TO
THE STATE I DIDN'T WANT TO MAKE
IT LOOK LIKE I WAS TRYING TO
FUND. THE PROGRAM IN MY OWN
COUNTY AND SORT OF BE SELF
SERVING FROM THAT STANDPOINT-
BUT CERTAINLY IF IT IS A
SENATE'S PLEASURE- I. HAVE NO
OPPOSITION TO ASSISTING. THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THESE ARE GOOD
PROGRAMS REALLY GOOD AND
IMPORTANT PROGRAMS THAT I HAVE.
I HAVE NO OPPOSITION TO HAVING
A CURRENT PROGRAMS ALSO BE ABLE
TO APPLY FOR THE GRANT FUNDING
ALONG WITH THE OTHER COUNTY
CENTER AFTER. AND AS LONG AS
PEOPLE ARE. DOING THE SAME
SERVICES AND MEETING THE GRANTS
WHATEVER THE GRANT STANDARDS
ARE SET UP BY THE COMMITTEE I
WOULD HAVE NO OPPOSITION THAT
AND- QUITE FRANKLY YOU'VE MADE
ME MORE AWARE OF. SUCH YOU'VE
MADE THE INQUIRY OF THAT THERE
ARE YOU KNOW OTHERS THAT ARE
OUT THERE AND THEY- HE SINGS
GENERALLY FLY PRETTY LOW ON THE
RADAR SCREEN AND BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF FUNDING YOU
DON'T KNOW ABOUT AND- I'M MORE
AWARE OF THAT AT THIS POINT
TIME SO. THE OTHER THING IF I
COULD. ADD- AND THAT IS. WE
FEEL FOR. THAT CREATE THIS
PROGRAM WE THOUGHT IT HAD
ORIGINALLY THE CONVERSATIONS
WERE AROUND LABOR. AND THE YOU
KNOW TENSION AND TRYING. A
GREAT WAY TO TAKE CARE OF
FARMWORKERS AND THEIR PROBLEMS
ARE ONE OF THE MOST VULNERABLE
AND EASILY EXPLOITED.
POPULATIONS OUT THERE AND AS A
RESULT OF THAT THEIR TRUST IN
VENTURA COUNTY GOVERNMENTS GONE
UP SIGNIFICANTLY. AND WHEN
COVERT HERE THAT. WE SIMPLY HAD
A FAR BETTER NETWORK TO GET OUT
THAT INFORMATION ABOUT VACCINES
AND MASK AND ALL OF THAT. NOT
JUST A BETTER NETWORK BUT A
TRUSTED NETWORK PEOPLE THAT ARE
ALREADY BEEN HELPING PEOPLE
WITH. HOW DO I GET HELP WITH MY
CHILD IS HAVING MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS AND- ALL OF THOSE
KINDS SIX WE ARE TRUSTED.
MEMBERS OUT THERE AND- I'M I'M
HAPPY TO HEAR THAT THERE ARE A
FEW OTHER PLACES IN CENTRAL
COAST WHERE THAT'S HAPPENING-
AND I WANT TO SUPPORT ALL OF
THEM WHICH IS WHY I'M- TALKING
A LITTLE LONGER THAN I SHOULD
AT THIS POINT TIME BUT I. I
REALLY WANT TO BE AN
AMBASSADOR. FOR HOW IMPORTANT
IT IS IF CALIFORNIANS GOING
SUPPORT. AND AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONER IN EVERY COUNTY. I
THINK WE'VE KIND OF MOVED AS A
POINT WHERE WE OUGHT TO SAY WE
OUGHT TO SUPPORT A FARMWORKER
RESOURCE PROGRAM. IN THESE
COUNTIES ALSO SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR ATTENTION- LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH SO YOU
SENATOR AND- EVERYBODY AND THE
AND THE CHAIR. IN TERMS OF ANY
WAY YOU'D LIKE. TO MOVE TO SO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND ARE WE
HAVE AMONG. AND LABOR CENTER
POUND. CONSULT OKAY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AB NINE FOUR ONE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS HER TADO I.
FURTADO I'D JONES CORTESE
VOTING. CORTESE NOT VOTING
KAMLAGER HI COM LARGER AYE PAN
AYE PAN AYE. WILL PLACE A
BELONG COUGH TO LOAD THEIR
STEPPING COOPER THANK YOU. AND
I SEE WE HAVE A SLIM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO IN THE ROOM- AND HE-
IS HERE FOR AGENDA ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN. AND PLEASE BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. HELLO OKAY RIGHT
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS SAID THIS IS A
COMMITTEE THAT KNOWS FULL WELL-
THE CHALLENGES WORLD HAVING
AROUND HOMELESSNESS AND HOW
CALIFORNIA- POLICYMAKERS FOR
THE PUBLIC OR CONSTITUENTS HAVE
NOT BEEN SATISFIED WITH
GOVERNMENT'S RESPONSE AND HOW
MUCH WE NEED TO MAKE PROGRESS
WITH DATA DRIVEN STRATEGIES AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AT ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT. THIS YEAR ARE
BUDGET INCLUDES A HISTORICALLY
UNPRECEDENTED TWELVE BILLION
DOLLARS A FUNDING FOR
HOMELESSNESS WHAT DISCUSSIONS
ON HOW TO CREATE ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR THESE FUNDS HAVE BEEN
ONGOING THIS BILL WOULD CREATE
A LOCAL AND STATE STRATEGY TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS AND HOLD
BILL STATE AGENCIES AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
PROGRESS IT DOESN'T IN THREE
WAYS BY REQUIRING THAT STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS COMPLETE
THEY GAPS NEEDS ANALYSIS TO
DETERMINE WHAT RESOURCES ARE
NEEDED TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS
BASED ON THAT ANALYSIS STATE
AGENCIES AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO CREATE AN
ACTUAL PLAN TO REDUCE
HOMELESSNESS BY NINETY PERCENT.
BY THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY
NINE AND THIS BILL ALSO
ESTABLISHES AN INSPECTOR
GENERAL POSITION THAT CAN HOLD
THE STATE OR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR FAILING TO
SUBMIT THIS PLAN OR NOT
FOLLOWING A PLAN IN ADDITION TO
HELP MEET THE STATEWIDE NEED TO
CREATE HOUSING FOR PEOPLE
XPERIENCING CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS THIS BILL WOULD
PRIORITIZE FEDERAL FUNDING FROM
THE NATIONAL HOUSING TRUST FUND
FOR PROJECTS SERVING PEOPLE.
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. BY
HOLDING ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABLE. THIS
BILL WILL HELP MOVE OUR STATE
TOWARD HOPEFULLY FINALLY
ADDRESSING THE MORAL CRISIS OF
THE DAY. AND WITH THAT I'D LIKE
TO TURN IT OVER TO OUR
WITNESSES FROM THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE JULIE SNYDER. AND
FROM CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING SHAM REPORT. WITNESSES
MAY PROCEED. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
TWO WEEKS LATER WITH THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE WE ARE
EXTREMELY PLEASED TO CO SPONSOR
AB ONE SIX TO CREATE
ENFORCEABLE MANDATE TO REDUCE
HOMELESSNESS WE'RE DEEPLY
GRATEFUL THE FINAL STATE BUDGET
PRIORITIZED HOMELESSNESS WHICH
OF CALIFORNIANS NUMBER ONE
ISSUE ACROSS THE POLITICAL
SPECTRUM WHAT THAT INVESTMENT
NEEDS NOW IS THE CONNECTING
TISSUE THAT'LL ENSURE THE STATE
AND LOCAL PROGRAMS LEVERAGE
EACH OTHER'S STRENGTHS TO
ACHIEVE MEASURABLE OUTCOMES. AB
EIGHT ONE SIX IS THAT
CONNECTING TISSUE FOR EXAMPLE
YOUR STATE BUDGET PROVIDES TWO
BILLION DOLLARS DIRECTLY TO
LOCALITIES TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS SH EIGHT ONE SIX
WOULD REQUIRE THAT THEY DEVELOP
A REGIONAL GAPS A NEEDS
ANALYSIS AS THE ROAD MAP TO
SPEND THESE FUNDS AREN'T ACTIVE
INTERVENTIONS THAT MOVE PEOPLE
QUICKLY INTO PERMANENT HOUSING
AND NOT ONLY THAT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS BUT ALSO THE FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION COUNTIES
RECEIVED IN THE CAL WORK
HOUSING PROGRAM THE TWO BILLION
IN MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
FUNDING EXTRA TRAFFIC STOP
DROP. CORONATION OF THESE
FUNDING STREAMS ALONE WILL MEET
THE NEEDS OF MORE. PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
DESPITE IS THE BILL'S PERCENT
GOAL. WE CAN LOOK TO THE CITY
OF BAKER'S FOR ANSWER. AT THE
JANUARY DISHING. THE CITY
ELIMINATED HOMELESSNESS THROUGH
SECURE COLLABORATION WITH
PUBLIC PRIVATE AND NONPROFIT
PARTNERS SHE PROBABLY DID IT IS
FRANKLY LESS IMPORTANT THAN THE
FACT THAT THEY FIGURED IT OUT
AND THAT. WHAT AB EIGHT ONE SIX
AND ABOUT THE CHARGES THE STATE
IN EACH LOCALITY WITH DOING
WHAT THEY CAN'T IN ANY WAY THEY
FIND FEASIBLE THE BILL IS
COMPLETELY FLEXIBLE ON THE
HOUSE. BEYOND IT RECOGNIZES
THAT JURISDICTIONS HAVE
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF RESOURCES.
90% IS A STATE WIDE GOAL NOT A
LOCAL REQUIREMENTS SHE EACH
LOCALITY SPECIFIC PERFORMANCE
GOAL WILL BE BASED ON WHAT YOU
CAN REASONABLY ACCOMPLISH THREE
ZONING BY USING EXISTING
DOLLARS MORE EFFECTIVELY EXCEPT
TRUCK AND I WANT TO REPEAT THAT
BECAUSE I HEARD A LACK OF
CLARITY FROM OPPONENTS ON THIS
POINT. UNDER AB EIGHT ONE SIX
EACH LOCALITIES PERFORMANCE
GOAL WILL BE BASED ON WHAT THE
APP LOCALITY CAN REASONABLY
ACCOMPLISH. BUT IT SAYS THE
STATE'S NO LONGER GOING TO
ACCEPT INACTION OR INEFFECTIVE
APPROACHES. TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO LOCALS
AB EIGHT ONE SIX ALSO CREEPS
INSPECTOR GENERAL WHICH WILL
HOLD ALL LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT
RESPONSIBLE FOR MEETING THE
GOALS THAT THEY THAT. WE HOPE
THE IG'S AMERICANS DISTANCE
WILL CREATE THE POLITICAL WILL
TO DO WHAT WE KNOW IS POSSIBLE
WE URGE HER AYE VOTE ON THE
STATIONARY MEASURE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS I
WAS CHAIRMAN REPORT WITH
APPROPRIATIONS FOR SUPPORT I
THINK ANOTHER CONSTRUCTION.
HOMELESSNESS IS SOLVABLE
INTOXICATED STATE IN EIGHTY
SEVEN CITIES HAVE ENTERED
CONCORD VETERAN HOMELESSNESS
AND FROM WHERE STATES LIKE
MICHIGAN AND NEW JERSEY HAVE
REDUCED TUMOR THICKNESS. THE
SEVENTY OR 49% RESPECTIVELY. DO
YOU MIND IF WE CANNOT PLACE
WORK REQUIREMENTS LAST YEAR
SPENDING ONE. CAN YOU PLEASE
SPEAK UP. YES I'M SORRY CAN YOU
HEAR ME BETTER NOW YES MUCH
BETTER. OKAY OKAY- DO YOU
SHOULD I START OVER OR PICK UP
WHERE I LEFT US. YOU CAN PICK
UP WHERE YOU LEFT OFF. OKAY
WHAT WE NEED FUNDING TO SOLVE
HOMELESSNESS EVERY LEVEL OF
GOVERNMENT MUST USUALLY
SPENDING WISELY TO END IT. FOR
EXAMPLE STATE SET GOAL USE DATA
TO INVEST COLLABORATE AND
COORDINATE RESOURCES AND
IDENTIFY AND REFORM FAILED
POLICY. AB EIGHT SIXTEEN HOLD
ALL LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT
ACCOUNTABLE FOR DOING WHAT WE
NOW WORK IT FIRST REQUIRES THE
STATE TO DO GAPS A NEEDS
ANALYSIS TO MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS. WE HAVE A STATE WIDE
HOMELESS DATA INFORMATION
SYSTEMS KNOW WHO'S EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND WHERE PEOPLE
GO WHEN THEY ACCESS IT WE NEXT
NEED TO KNOW HOW MANY SHELTER
PETS AND WE HOUSING RESOURCES
WE HAVE. ANALYZE WHAT WE NEED
AND IDENTIFY THE GAP BETWEEN
THE TWO. IT WILL ALSO PINPOINT
HOW MANY PEOPLE WE EXPECT TO
EXIT STATE FUNDED. INSTITUTIONS
IN THE HOMELESSNESS. NAY THE
NEED BEEN A GAME CHANGER FOR
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
TOWARD HOUSE A TOWARD FOCUSING
RESOURCES ON FILLING GAPS. IT
SHOULD BE A NO BRAINER FOR
CALIFORNIA. NEXT AB EIGHT
SIXTEEN REQUIRES THE STATE TO
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO PUT IN PLACE
TOOLS THEY NEED. FINALLY A. B.
EIGHT SIXTEEN SET GOALS FOR
EVERY LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT TO DO
THE HARD WORK OF COLLABORATING
LEVERAGING INVESTMENTS AND
REFORMING POLICIES. THE ONLY
WAY TO MEET THE VOTER PRIORITY
TO SOLVE HOMELESSNESS IS TO
DEDICATE CALIFORNIA TO AN ALL
HANDS ON DECK APPROACH. AB
EIGHT SIXTEEN IS THE CALL FOR
ALL HANDS ON DECK TO SOLVE THIS
CRISIS. I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY WILL BE MOVING
TO PUBLIC COMMENT IN SUPPORT
HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE. SEEN NINE ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. AND THERE AND NOW ON TO
THE TOP OF PUBLIC COMMENT LINE
IN SUPPORT OF AB. EIGHT SIXTY.
THREE TO INDICATE SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
AGAIN THAT'S ONE OF THEM ZERO.
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO EIGHTY
NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ANASTASIA
CAMANCHE WITH CALIFORNIA'S
VISORS ON BEHALF OF MARY
JOURNAL STEINBERG IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU BYE THANK
YOU LINE TO FIFTY THREE.
AFTERNOON MY BRACKET GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. PINE. TO
NINETY EIGHT. PARAMILITARY
MEMBERS FILL THE A POLICE SHOT
ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS FOR THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO IN
COURT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
BLIND TO EIGHTEEN. HI THIS IS
JACKIE EVERY ON BEHALF OF HOUSE
HOUSING CALIFORNIA WE ARE
CLOSED ON THEIR OF AB EIGHT
SIXTEEN AND STRONG WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. NO PER MINUTE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME OKAY HAVE
BEEN HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORTERS
WILL NUMBER A POLICY PROCESS
BUT THOSE ARE THAT ARE IN
OPPOSITION WE INVITE WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO TESTIFY AND I
BELIEVE WE HAVE ONE VIA THE
TELEPHONE LINE A JOSH OUR
CULTURE. AND I'M SORRY IF I
MISPRONOUNCE YOUR NAME OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES. IS JOSH ON THE LINE
NO WORRIES THANK. YES I'M HERE
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON JOSH DUGGAR
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
THE AND ON BEHALF OF MY
COLLEAGUES WITH URBAN COUNTY TO
CALIFORNIA AND THE WILL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA.
BUT POLITICS FOR THE LATE
LETTERS THE MIDDLE TO THE
COMMITTEE BUT WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO EIGHTY
EIGHT SIXTEEN INJECTED A SERIES
OF AMENDMENTS TO THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS CONSIDERATION. WHICH
EARNED TE GOLD IMPROVING THE
STATE'S RESPONSE TO
HOMELESSNESS AND AGREE THAT
PLANNING IS A MAJOR PART OF THE
CHEATING MEASURABLE AND
SUSTAINED PROGRESS. THAT REASON
WE WORK COLLABORATIVELY WITH
THE AUTHOR SPONSORS AND STAFF
LAST YEAR ON SIMILAR BILL AB
THIRTY TO SIXTY NINE AFTER MANY
VALUABLE CONVERSATIONS WE
REMOVED OPPOSITION TO LAST
YEAR'S BILL WITH THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENT THAT WOULD HAVE
TAKEN. UNFORTUNATELY IT DID NOT
CONTINUE IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS BUT WE STAND READY TO
FULLY ENGAGE IN A MEANINGFUL
DIALOGUE THIS YEAR IN HOPES OF
REACHING A SIMILAR COMMON
GROUND THAT WE MET ON LAST
YEAR. GENERALLY ARE CONCERNED
WITH EIGHTY SIXTEEN OF THAT
FALLS SHORT OF BEING A
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS. CAN YOU
AGREE THAT A COMPREHENSIVE
STRATEGY SHOULD INCLUDE ALL THE
ELEMENTS OF CLEARLY ARTICULATED
GOALS DEFINED WORLD IN
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR EACH LEVEL
OF GOVERNMENT COMMENSURATE ON
GO ON GOING FUNDING TO FILL THE
ROLES AND RESPONSIBILITIES. AND
TRANSPARENT ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES. CERTAINLY WOULD BE A
PART OF THAT AS WELL. EIGHTY
EIGHT SIXTEEN THE MAN FOR TOWN
CHARGED. GO BY. OBTAINING
PROCESS IN REGARD CARD. BUT
ALSO ON ACCOUNTABLE MEASURES
THREE WITH. THE HOUSING
HOMELESS. INSPECTOR INTO COURT
INTERVENTION PROCESS RELATED TO
FUNDING AND EXPENDITURES.
HOWEVER THE MEASURE DOES NOT
INCLUDE THE OTHER ELEMENTS
NECESSARY TO ACHIEVE THE
DESIRED OUTCOMES. THAT BEING
SAID. WE DEFINITELY REALIZE
THAT THAT DYNAMIC CONVERSATION
AND- INVOLVING CONVERSATION
EVOLVING CONVERSATION WITH THE
HOMELESSNESS BUDGET TRAILER
BILL NEGOTIATIONS ALSO
OCCURRING AND LOOK FORWARD TO
THE SINGING CALL. BUT THAT WE
HAD. LAST YEAR WITH THE AUTHOR
STAFF. AND SPONSORS I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. OKAY
WILL MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE THREE NINE BROUGH
TWENTY FORTY NINE THERE'S WELL
AND NOW OPPOSITION. TO THIS
MEASURE UP YET THE TOTAL PUBLIC
COMMENT LINE PLEASE NAME
ORGANIZATION. AND POSITION ON
THE BILL ONLY. THANK YOU TO
ENTER THE Q. ME PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO USING YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD ONE NUMBER
ZERO PLEASE. WE WILL MOVE
TIMELINE TO NINETY SEVEN.
GETTING OUR MEMBERS ARE
SELECTED ON FROM THE CAPITAL
CITY OF BEVERLY HILLS AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. COLONEL OTHER LINES
INTO IT THIS TIME. SO HAVEN'T
HEARD ALL COMMENTS FILE ON
OPPOSITION I WANT TO BRING BACK
TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR STEPH
FOR QUESTIONS ANDOR COMMENTS
ON THIS MEASURE. CENTER PAN.
THANK YOU AND- IN APPRECIATE
THE WORK THAT YOU'VE BEEN DOING
ON THIS BILL- PERHAPS- MEETING
YOUR CLOTHES YOU CAN JUST
ADDRESS C. SIX COMMENTS ABOUT
FURTHER WORK- AND ELABORATE ON
THAT BUT- CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
THAT- MY CITY SEE SACRAMENTO'S
SUPPORTS THE BILL THE BILL
PROBABLY TIME. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. OKAY WE HAVE A
MOTION AND WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. SURE JUST TO ANSWER
BRIEFLY CENTER PANS- QUESTIONS
SO I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE OUR
ENGAGEMENT WITH LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS SANDRA- AT THIS
MOMENT IT IS A DYNAMIC
CONVERSATION BECAUSE THERE ARE
DISCUSSIONS GOING ON IN THE
BUDGET TRAILER CONVERSATION.
AROUND HOW WE ENSURE
ACCOUNTABILITY WITH THE TWELVE
BILLION DOLLARS SAID WE'RE
MOVING FORWARD AND- AND SOME OF
THESE IDEAS ARE ARE IN PLAY- A
FEW THINGS THAT- COUNTIES OF
RAISES- A SITUATION THAT
SOMEHOW THERE AREN'T CLEAR
ROLES AND RESPONSIBILITIES AND
WHAT I WOULD SUGGEST IS WHAT
THIS BILL CALLS FOR. IS FOR
EVERY CITY COUNTY REGION AND
STATE AGENCY TO DO AN ANALYSIS
OF GAPS IN NEEDS ANALYSIS OF
WHAT IS THE NEED. HOW MUCH
RESOURCES ARE ADDRESSING THIS
NEED WHAT'S THE GAP BETWEEN
THAT SO WE CAN UNDERSTAND HOW
ALL THE DIFFERENT PLAYERS ALL
FIT TOGETHER AND WORK ASKING
ALL THESE PLAYERS. TO WORK
TOGETHER SO FOR EXAMPLE MANY
FOR COUNTIES HAVE EMBEDDED
CITIES. CITIES SAY THE COUNTIES
OUGHT TO DO ONE ASPECT OF IT
THE COUNTY SAY CITIES OUT TO DO
AN ASPECT OF IT PART OF WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS JUST GET
EVERYONE ON THE SAME PAGE WHAT.
SKIN IN THE GAME ARE YOU
PUTTING INTO THIS WHAT ARE YOU
NOT SO THAT EVERYONE CAN SEE IN
A VERY TRANSPARENT WAY WHAT'S
GOING ON WE CAN'T. EXACTLY
DEFINED ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES UNTIL WE DO
THAT ANALYSIS SO PART OF THIS
BILL SAYS LET'S DO THE ANALYSIS
AND THEN LET'S PUT THE PLAN
TOGETHER TO MOVE THAT FORWARD-
ONE OTHER MAJOR ISSUE THAT HAS
BEEN RAISED AS- THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL AND WHAT THEY'RE GOING
TO HOLD CITIES AND COUNTIES
ACCOUNTABLE FOR AND I WANT TO
MAKE IT VERY CLEAR BECAUSE-
WE'VE HEARD FROM CITIES. IF YOU
DON'T GIVE US ENOUGH MONEY WE
CAN'T AND HOMELESSNESS THIS
BILL SPECIFICALLY STATES. THAT
JURISDICTION'S WILL ONLY BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
RESOURCES THEY HAVE IF THEY
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH RESOURCES WE
UNDERSTAND THAT WE JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE. THAT FOR SPENDING
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS WE'RE
GETTING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
VALUE FROM THAT SO. THOSE ARE
SOME OF THE MAIN ISSUES THAT
HAVE ARISEN BUT AS I'VE SAID
BEFORE THE CONVERSATIONS ON
GOING- I THINK WHEN THE DUST
SETTLES AFTER BUDGET TRAILER
HOPEFULLY THE NEXT COUPLE
WEEKS- WE'LL GET BACK. TO
REALLY FINE TUNING WHERE WE ARE
WITH THIS ALL. THANK YOU. AND
AGAIN JUST EVERYONE'S- SUPPORT
OF THIS IF YOU CAN- WE SPENT
DECADES INVESTING IN
HOMELESSNESS BUT NOT ANY
HOMELESSNESS AND I THINK IT'S
TIME FOR US TO REALLY HAVE A
PLAN TO- TO MAKE A MOVE TO
ACTUALLY ENDED AND THAT'S
REALLY THE PURPOSE OF THIS AND
USING THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
THAT WE WILL HAVE THIS YEAR AND
INTO THE FUTURE- AND WITH THAT
A RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY A CENTER
PAN CONSULTING CUBA PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AB EIGHT ONE SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS FURTADO AYE.
HURTADO AYE JONES. CORTESE
CORTESE I COME LONGER HI COM
LONGER AYE PAN AYE PAN AYE.
REPLACEABLE INCOME THANK YOU
CENTERS THANK OKAY AND OF THE-
UP NEXT WE HAVE A B. TWO SIXTY
BASE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS AB TWO SIXTY IS
INTENDED TO GO AFTER AN AN
ISSUE ABOUT PLACEMENTS
GUARDIANSHIP SOURCES CHILD
WELFARE AND OFTENTIMES THE
CHILD WILL BE PLACED INTO
GUARDIANSHIP THROUGH THE
PROBATE COURT. AND WILL THEN
NOT BE ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE PROGRAM AND THE
OFFERINGS HAD THEY BEEN PLACED
IN THE- JUVENILE SYSTEM FOR IN-INTO THE CHILD CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM. SO OFTEN TIMES THERE IS
A REVIEW BY SOCIAL WORKERS THAT
MAKE THE DECISION TO PUSH FOR A
PROBATE COURT GUARDIANSHIP. AND
WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT COURT THE PROBATE COURT
CAN LOOK IF THE COURT BRINGS
THAT FORD FOR THE A TRIAL DOES
IF THE CHILD IS REPRESENT BY
COUNCIL BRINGS FOR THE DESIRE
FOR THE PROBATE COURT TO LOOK
AT WHETHER OR NOT THEY SHOULD
BE PLACED. INTO THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM THAT CAN HAPPEN
AND EVEN IF THERE IS A
GUARDIANSHIP IN UNDER PROBATE
THIS BILL MAKE SURE THAT THAT
THE CASE STILL COULD BE BROUGHT
IF APPROPRIATE. WITHIN THE
JUVENILE COURTS IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE PROTECTIONS FOR THE
CHILD AND ALSO VERY VERY
IMPORTANTLY. WE'RE ENSURING
THAT THESE KIDS BECAUSE THESE
ARE OFTEN ABUSED AND NEGLECTED
KIDS AND IF THEY ARE GOING TO
BE PUSHED OFF TO GUARDIANSHIP
IN THE PROBATE COURT THEY STILL
NEED ACCESS TO CAN GAP. ALL OF
THE REST OF THE SERVICES THIS
IS CLOSING SOME LOOPS TO ENSURE
THAT KIDS GET THE LEVEL OF
SERVICES THEY NEED AT OUR PLACE
CORRECTLY ALLOWING THE COURTS
TO HAVE THAT FLEXIBILITY TO
LOOK TO ASK QUESTIONS AND MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE
APPROPRIATELY PLACED THAT'S
WHAT AB TWO SIXTY. DOES AND
WITH ME I HAVE CHEN REXRODE AND
SABRINA FORTE BOTH AS MY
PRIMARY WITNESSES AND ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
WITNESSES MAY PROCEED. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM JOHN REX
STRODE AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
THE CARE GIVERS AND BIRTH
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT AT THAT
LEGISLATION- AS A FOSTER PARENT
FOR AND- ABOUT SEVEN YARDS
PLANET THAT MIGHT WORK AS- AN-
ADVOCATE. FOR FOSTER AND
KINSHIP PARENT I'VE COME ACROSS
MANY OF OUR RELATIVES HILL- AND
BEYOND THAT THEN- BASICALLY
FIND A WAY- BARRACK JAIL ANY
ACCESS THE SUPPORT OF THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM. AND
INADVERTENTLY ALSO- AT FIND A
WAY AT THE RIGHT AT THEIR-
THEIR CHILDREN CAN ACCESS-
SUPPORTS AND SERVICES- AND
THEIR PARENTS AND- NOT RECEIVED
LEGAL COUNSEL AND- BRANAGH
CATION SERVICES- DURING. THAT
TIME THAT CRISIS- WHEN SB S.
SENATE COLLECT HAS OCCURRED AND
RELATIVE OUR APPROACH TO TAKE
PLACEMENT OF. THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS- DATE. THEY'RE OFTEN
NOT GIVEN ALL OF THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED IN
ORDER TO MAKE THE BEST CHOICE
FOR AND IT COULD BE THEIR
CHILDREN AND THEIR
GRANDCHILDREN- WE'VE HEARD OF
MANY- GRANDPARENTS FOR INTENT
TO TAKE PLACE MAN HAS- COULD BE
AT THE GOING TO FAT. THREE
YOUNG CHILDREN AND THEY'RE TOLD
THAT IF THEY DON'T. TAKE PLACE
IN A BAND. PARTAKE GUARDIANSHIP
THAT BAND TRIP PROBATE COURT
THAT THE CHILDREN WILL ENSURE
THAT FOSTER CARE SET THEM AND
I'LL NEVER SEE THEM AGAIN. AND
SO THERE AND MEDIA CONCERNED IT
YEAH Q. AND KEEP THE CHILDREN
SAFE AND- OUT OF THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM BUT THE CHILD
BUS FARES BUT THEN IS THE PLACE
THAT- AS THE- HELD AT THE PART
CONSERVE. NEEDED TO SUPPORT THE
FAMILY- IF STABILIZE THE
CHILDREN- THINGS LIKE THAT-
SERVICE THAT'S LIKE THE
EMERGENCY CHILDCARE BRIDGE
PROGRAM AND THE FAMILY URGENT
RESPONSE GEN. OUR AND OUR
PROGRAMS THAT ARE- SUPPORTING
FAMILY IS. IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
THE ABUSE AND NEGLECT THAT HAVE
HAPPENED IN THE CHILD'S LIFE.
AND WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT ALL
FAMILIES HAVE ACCESS TO THE
SUPPORT AND THAT CHILDREN CAN
HEAL AND THRIVE AFTER
EXPERIENCING ABUSE AND NEGLECT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOUR NEXT
WITNESS. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS NINE
ELECT TO BRING UP FOR K. AND I
AM THE DIRECTOR OF POLICY AND
LITIGATION AT THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS. ALLIANCE
PROUD TO CO SPONSOR AB TWO
FIFTY WHICH CLOSES THE GAP AND
THE QUALITY COORDINATION
BETWEEN THE PROBATE AND
JUVENILE DEPENDENCY COURT AND
SHE INOLVING CHILD ABUSE AND
NEGLECT WE'LL PROTECT THE
INDIVIDUAL PACKAGE RIGHT THAT
CHILDREN AND PARENTS. NOTABLY A
BECAUSE THAT WE ALSO ENSURING
THAT OUR STATE CAN GET PROGRAM
SUPPORT ALL KINSHIP CAREGIVERS
TO BECOME GUARDIANS. THE
JUVENILE DEPENDENCY COURT. WE
ARE PLEASED THAT HAD BY PART OF
SUPPORT ON THIS. IN THE AND OF
TIME I WILL MAKE MY AVAILABLE
FOR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M WILL GO AHEAD AND
ADD TO PUBLIC COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND ROOM
HERE ROOM FORTY TWO ZERO THREE
SEEN NONE ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
NONE THERE'S WHILE NOW ON THE
TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT LINE.
AND TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
WILL FIRST GO TO LINE TWO FORTY
EAST APARTMENT TWO FIFTY THREE
GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
NEXT CALLER IF YOU HAVE TWO
OTHER LINE YES WE DO HAVE TWO
OTHER LINES IN Q. ONE MOMENT
WHILE WE PROVIDE THEM DOWN BY
NUMBERS. WE'LL GO NEXT TO LINE
THREE OH TWO GO AHEAD PLEASE.
GIVE THEM A CALL BACK FROM
LINCOLN FAMILY IS CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE OVER THREE
HUNDRED KINSHIP FAMILIES WE
SERVE IN ALAMEDA COUNTY TO
SUPPORT EIGHTY TWO SIXTY THANK
YOU. THE NINE THREE HUNDRED GO
AHEAD PLEASE. COLOCATION SHORT
AND SENSE OF CALLING ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF P. P. TO
SIXTY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BOETTICHER WE HAVE NO FOR THE
LINES IN Q. ALRIGHT- WE WILL
MOVE ON TO ANY WITNESSES- IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL WE
DON'T HAVE EVEN A LEAD INTO
PERCENT- IN OPPOSITION HERE
BUT- PUBLIC COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION BEGIN AND ROUTE
FORTY TWO OR THREE. C. NINE
ROOM TWENTY FORTY NUMBER AS
WELL AND NOW ON TO THE-
TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT LINE.
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
BETTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE
QUEUING UP. ALL RIGHT HOW DO WE
HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OF THE
BILL ALRIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION-
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. TO
CONSULTANT CAN WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR PAN CAN YOU PLEASE
OUR COLORADO. AB TWO SIXTY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS HER TADO HI.
FURTADO AYE JONES. PARTISI
CORTEZ THE I. COM WALKER HI COM
LONGER AYE PAN. AN ONLINE AND
WILL PLACE THE BILL ON CALL.
THANK YOU. AND UP NEXT BOB. IS
AGENDA ITEM THIRTEEN LAST BUT
CERTAINLY NOT LEAST. COME COME
ON UP IN. FEEL FREE FEEL FREE
TO BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND-
SENATORS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AB THREE SIXTY SIX
WHICH WOULD PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
DIRECTION TO KEEP SIBLINGS
TOGETHER AND THE FOSTER YOU
SYSTEM I APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEES- WORK ON THIS AND I
ACCEPT ALL OF THE AMENDMENTS-
THERE ARE VARYING COMPLEXITIES
FOR SIBLINGS WITH THE FOSTER
SYSTEM FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. AND
IT IS WELL ESTABLISHED IN THE
VALUE OF PRIORITIZING SIBLINGS
BEING PLACED TOGETHER ACCORDING
TO THE FEDERAL CHILDREN'S
BUREAU THIRTY SEVEN STATES
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA REQUIRE
CHILD WELFARE AGENCIES TO MAKE
REASONABLE EFFORTS TO PLAY SOAP
SIBLINGS TOGETHER. IN THE
ABSENCE OF A DOCUMENT SAFETY
DOCUMENTED SAFETY AND WELL
BEING CONCERNS ALTHOUGH MANY
STATES IDENTIFY CAPACITY OF THE
BARRIER TO SIBLING PLACEMENT IT
DOES NOT APPEAR THAT ANY OTHER
STATE HAS GONE SO FAR AS TO
CREATE A POLICY THAT DIRECTLY
ADDRESSES. TO THE ADDRESS OF
THE CAPACITY RELATED BARRIERS
TO SIBLING PLACEMENT CURRENT
CALIFORNIA LAW PROVIDES THAT
CHILDREN SHALL BE PLACED WITH
SIBLINGS UNLESS IT IS THE
DETRIMENTAL AND THERE IS A
STRONG STATUTORY PREFERENCE FOR
RELATIVE PLACEMENT. IN PRACTICE
HOWEVER TOO MANY CHILDREN
REMAIN SEPARATED FROM THEIR
SIBLINGS AND RELATIVES DUE TO
THE BUREAUCRATIC HURDLES THAT
ARE NOT RELATED TO CHILD SAFETY
OR UNNECESSARY DELAYS. IN
ASSESSING RELATIVES. FOR
EXAMPLE SETS OF SIBLINGS ARE
OFTEN SEPARATED INTO DIFFERENT
HOMES NOT DUE TO SAFETY.
CONCERNS BUT INSTEAD BECAUSE OF
CAPACITY RESTRICTIONS IN THE
LAW. THIS CAN HAVE LIFELONG
CONSEQUENCES A LARGE SIBLING
GROUPS WHO ARE CLOSELY BONDED
TO EACH OTHER BUT ARE
TRAUMATIZED AGAINST. AGAIN BY
THE LOSS OF THEIR SIBLINGS INTO
A SEPARATE HOME. AB THREE SIXTY
SIX WOULD REMEDY THE ISSUES BY
INSURING SIBLINGS SHOULD BE
PLACED TOGETHER UNLESS THERE IS
A SHOWING THAT. PLACEMENT WOULD
BE CONTRARY TO THE WELL BEING
AND SAFETY OF THE SIBLINGS AND
APPROVE RESOURCE. FAMILIES I
HAD THE SIZE AND SPACE TO PLAY
SIBLINGS TOGETHER ADJUSTMENTS
ARE EXISTING SYSTEM WILL ALLOW
A SIMPLE FIX TO A CRITICAL
ASPECT OF FIVE FOSTER YOUTH
OUTCOMES. TODAY WITH ME VIA
TELEPHONE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF SABRINA FOR TODAY WITH THE
ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN RIGHTS
AND JUNE REMEMBER WHEN A FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH TURNED. ADVOCATE
THANK YOU. WHAT MRS MAY PROCEED.
AFTERNOON SHARING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO BRING A FORTE FROM
THE ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S
RIGHT TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK ABOUT AB THREE SIX
WHICH WE ARE CO SPONSORING WITH
THE CHILDREN WALK ANSWER OF
CALIFORNIA EIGHTY THREE SIX
SECOND STRENGTHENED FAMILY BY
PREVENTING THE SEPARATION OF
THE GOING TO THE DOCTOR CARE.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE AND SHE BETTER
OUTCOMES AND FORM LIFELONG
SUPPORTIVE RELATIONSHIPS WHEN
THEY'RE PLACED TOGETHER IN A
SINGLE MOTHER STRUGGLING
PRESERVING TIED WITH THE BLAME
CAN HELP OUR CHILDREN FROM THE
NEGATIVE IMPACT OF TRAUMA AND
REMOVAL RELATED RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT LIVING WITH THE CARRYING
RELATIVE INCREASES THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT THE PLANE
ACTUALLY LARGE THE. BRING BACK.
WE PLAYED TOGETHER. CALIFORNIA
LAW RECOGNIZE RECOGNIZE MISTER
OF THE THIRTY CONVENE OUR
CURRENT THAT'S FOR KEEP BILLION
TOGETHER AND ARE YOU. PLACEMENT
RELATIVES BUT DESPITE THAT.
MANY HAVE LINGERED CONTINUE TO
BE SEPARATED WHEN THEY ENTERED
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM EVEN
WHEN THEY WERE WILLING RELATIVE
TO TAKE AN ACTIVE LINK GROUP.
ARE THE LEVEL DATA INDICATE
THAT 45% OF CHILDREN IN FOSTER
CARE EXPERIENCE REGION FROM
THEIR SIBLINGS IN HERE. THIS
REPRESENTS AN INCREASE IN
PREPARATIONS OVER THE PAST
FIFTEEN YEARS REQUIRING A
TARGETED APPROACH FOR THE
SPECIFIC REASON. MY CHILDREN
ARE SEPARATE AND- THREE THEY
HAVE TO DO WITH THE
RESTRICTIONS ON THE BY THE
STATE AND THE CARE GIVERS HOME.
THAT ARE UNRELATED TO THE BT
AND WELLBEING OF THE CHILDREN.
EIGHTY THREE FIFTY SIX DURING.
THE STRENGTHENING WITHIN LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS AND REMOVE
TECHNICAL BARRIERS THAT THE
BLANK THANK MEANT RELATED TO
FIVE. EIGHT THE CARE GIVERS
HOME. FIRST BY LEGISLATORS
INTENT AT THE BRIDGE THE PLACE
TOGETHER UNLESS THERE'S PROOF.
OF AFFECTED THEIR SPEAKING AND
WILL BEAM AND SECOND CREATES A
PRESUMPTION. IN APPROVED
RESEARCH FAMILY HOME BECAUSE
THE FIRE BASICALLY THE PLAN
TOGETHER. THIRTY THREE THAN
THEIR LANDED PROPERTY COOK
BONTA EIGHTY THREE THICK THICK
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
EYES OUT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION
ASSEMBLY. MEMBER RUBIO FOR
OFFERING THAT THE- THANK YOU
NEXT WE- HI NAME IS GENERALLY
MERLIN I AM A FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH I AM SURE THE JANUARY
THIRTIETH STYLE TEN I SPENT
FIVE YEARS IN CARE UNTIL I EACH
DAY INTO THE FIFTEEN WHEN I
FIRST ENTERED FOR CARE I AM
WITH MY ONE MONTH OLD SON. MY
ANGER BROTHER MY TWINS-
ALTOGETHER AND MY FIRST FOSTER
HOME FOR ABOUT EIGHT MONTHS THE
HOME THAT THE CHILD WELFARE
AGENCY PLACE SINCE THEN WAS.
WHAT FAR AWAY MY COMMUNITY LOS
ANGELES BECAUSE WE WERE TOLD
THEY COULDN'T FIND A HOME BIG
ENOUGH TO FIT ALL OF US. WE
REPRESENT A PLAN THIS WAS THE
ONLY HOME DURING OUR TIME IN
FOSTER CARE WHERE WE WERE ALL
TOGETHER. THROUGH NO FAULT OF
OUR OWN WE WERE REMOVED FROM
THE HOME UNTIL BY THE CHILD
WELFARE AGENCY THAT THEY COULD
NOT FIND A HOME TO PUT THEM
TOGETHER. I WAS THE FIRST ONE
REMOVED AND I WAS BACK IN LOS
ANGELES. AFTER THAT MY BROTHER
AND SISTER ENDED UP BEING
REMOVED AND EIGHT AND THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AREA- THEY HAD
EACH OTHER FOR A WHILE. THEN
FROM THERE THEY ENDED UP
GETTING SEPARATE AT. ENTERING
FOSTER CARE. WE WERE STRUCK OF
EVERYTHING AND TORN AWAY FROM
OUR FAMILY. THE ONLY THING WE
HAD WAS EACH OTHER AND OUR GOT
TAKEN AWAY TO. BEING SEPARATED
FROM HIS SIBLINGS WAS VERY
CHALLENGING. MY YOUNGER BROTHER
WAS NINE YEARS OLD AT THE TIME
AND MY SISTER AND I WORK
FIFTEEN. WE DON'T WANT TO BE
THERE FOR MY BROTHER AND
PROTECT THEM AND FOR BEING
FRATERNAL TWINS. WE WEREN'T AS
CLOSE AS OTHER TWENTY. OVER THE
YEARS BECAUSE OF THE DISTANCE
BETWEEN US. ON MY SIBLINGS WERE
IN RIVERSIDE I DIDN'T HAVE A
SUPPORT OF FOSTER PARENTS WHO
WOULD ARRANGE BUT IS IT MY BABY
AND I ACTUALLY HAD TO TAKE THE
MY CHILLING TO GET THE
RIVERSIDE AND SOMETIMES IT
WOULD TAKE FIVE HOURS JUST TO
GET THERE. MY FOSTER PARENT
DIDN'T MAKE IT A PRIORITY FOR
ME THAT LINK THE NIGHT TO GET
TO KNOW EACH OTHER DID THAT
EACH OTHER OPTION. AND
DIFFERENCE WAS DEFINITELY A
HUGE ISSUE. THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM DEFINITELY HAVE IMPACTED
THE DYNAMIC OF OUR RELATIONSHIP
WITH EACH OTHER. I'M NOT
EQUIPMENT SIBLINGS AS I WOULD
HAVE IF WE WOULD HAVE BEEN
TOGETHER BUT WE CURRENTLY DO
REMAIN IN TOUCH. SOME OF THE
YOU ARE LOS FORTUNATE AND END
UP LOSING CONTACT ALL TOGETHER
WITH THEIR SIBLINGS I SUPPORT
AB THREE SIX THANKS AND THANKS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO FOR THE
BILL BECAUSE IT IS IMPORTANT
FOR THE PROSECUTOR. TO KEEP
THAT ONE GATHER THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY AND- WILL BE
MOVING ON TO PUBLIC COMING IN
SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OR THREE. THREE NINE ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. NONE THEIR AS
WELL AND ON TO THE TELEPHONE
POLE COMMA LINE FOR THOSE IN
SUPPORT OF A. THREE SIXTY SIX.
THAT IS BECAUSE SUPPORT PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO SIXTY
SEVEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. THIRDS
WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ONE TWO FIFTY THREE.
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NINE TWO SEVENTY TWO. TALKING
WITH HI THERE WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA LINE COMMENTING ON
THE THERMOSTAT AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO FOR SHARING THIS
VERY IMPORTANT LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU. NINE THREE ZERO
FOUR. GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS WILLIAM BUT BURKE
ON BEHALF OF NARAL PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
NURSE MIDWIFE THE AGENT IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE THREE
ZERO THREE. ON BEHALF OF. HE
THANK YOU. BLIND. TWO FIFTY.
REMEMBER AS MANY ARE GONNA
RODRIGUEZ IF YOU CALIFORNIA
ACTUALLY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. LINE. TWO EIGHTY
SEVEN. AFTERNOON KAREN
HONORABLE MEMBERS THE BILL
ABRAMS- REPRESENTING CHILDREN
LOCKED IN A CALIFORNIA WE ARE
PROUD CO SPONSOR AB THREE SIX
SIX AND STRONG SUPPORT AND
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF THE
UPPER OFFERING. IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION THANK YOU. LINE ONE
NINETY EIGHT. HI THIS IS
DANIELLE ONE DRUG WITH CHILDREN
NOW IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU BETTER MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE
NO FOR THE LINES IN Q. THANK
YOU I HAVEN'T HEARD FROM ALL
THE SUPPORTERS- WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY SCHEDULE LEE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION FOR THIS BILL BUT TO
WILL TO POP PUBLIC COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN FORTY TWO OR
THREE THREE NINE ROOM TWENTY
FORTY NINE THERE'S WHILE. AND
NOW- OPPOSITION. IN THE LINES
AND THE TOTAL PUBLIC COMMENT
LINES. TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. SEVEN SURE WE HAVE THE
ONE QUEUED UP OKAY QUESTIONS
AND QUESTIONS AND OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. IN A
PAN THANK U. S. AND RUBIO IT'S
WHAT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE. TO BE
ABLE TO KEEP SIBLINGS TOGETHER
AND- AND REALLY ADD TO THE
NATIVES BUREAUCRATIC BARRIERS
THAT PREVENT THAT FROM
HAPPENING. I KNOW THAT THESE
RULES ARE PUT IN PLACE FOR.
YEAH GOOD REASONS BUT- I THINK
THE- BILL KEEPS COMING TOGETHER
SO EVEN MORE IMPORTANT SO
REALLY APPRECIATE BEING SUCH A
FORMAL MOVE IT AT THE PROPER
TIME THANK YOU OKAY. ALL RIGHT-
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
PAN- AND AS SUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHO WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU I JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE OKAY CONTROL
TO KEEP PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB THREE SIX SIX THE MOTION IS
DO YOU PASS AS AMENDED BUT
FIRST DEMAND IN RE REFER TO
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. HER
TADO NINE FURTADO I'D JONES
JONES I CORTES C. CORTEZ THE
ICON LOCKER. COME WALKER I PAN
HI CAN I. THE BILL IS FIVE ZERO
NOT BILL IS OUT THANK YOU. AND
AT THIS POINT WE WILL- DO ADD
ONS IF SOMEONE TOLD. YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THE ADDAMS. AB
TWENTY TWO BY MCCARTY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
RE REFER TO COMMITTEE ON A PER
ON APPROPRIATIONS JONES NO.
JONES NO. BUT FOR ONE AND THAT
BILL IS OUT. AB SIX NINE FIVE
BY ARAMBULA THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE RE REFER TO
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY JONES I.
JONES I. THE BOW IS FIVE ZERO
NABIL IS AL. AB SIX SIX FIVE BY
EDUARDO GARCIA THE MOTION IS
THE MOTION IS DUE FEB DO PASSED
BUT FIRST BE RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CALL MARKER. KAMLAGER BY. THE
VOTE WAS FIVE ZERO ANNAPOLIS
OUT. AB FORTY SEVEN BY RAY IS
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
JONES L. JONES NO CORTESE-
TENNESSEE ALLY. THE VOTE IS FOR
ONE AND THAT BILL IS OUT. AB
NINETY TWO BY RAY IS THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED BUT FIRST BE RE
REFER TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS JONES JONES NO.
THE BILL IS FOR ONE AND THAT
BILL IS OUT. AB TWO TWO SIX BY
RAMOS THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS COM LONGER. NOT
VOTING. THE BOOK WAS FOUR ZERO
AND THE BILL IS OUT. AB TWO
SIXTY BY STONE THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS BUT FIRST BE RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS JONES. JONES BY.
THE VOTE IS FIVE ZERO AND THAT
BILL IS OUT. AB THREE EIGHT
THREE FIVE SALAS THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS JONES. NUMBERING
JONES NOT VOTING. THE BOAT IS
FOUR ZERO AND THAT BILL IS OUT.
AB EIGHT ONE THREE BY MULLIN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE RE REFER TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS HER TADO. I HER
TADO I'D JONES JONES I. THE
VOTE IS FIVE ZERO AND THAT BILL
IS OUT. AB EIGHT ONE SIX BY CHU
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED BUT
FIRST BE RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
JONES. JONES NO. THE BILL IS
FOR ONE AND THAT BILL IS OUT
WHICH- A. B. NINE FOUR ONE BY
BENNETT THE MOTION IS DUE TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE RE REFER TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
JONES UPLOADING. JONES NOT
VOTING. THE VOTE IS THREE ZERO
AND THAT BILL IS AT. LOS
ANGELES DEPENDABLE- ONE. M.
THATCH- THE FACT THAT CONCLUDES
ALL OF OUR BILLS FOR TODAY AND
FOR THE YEAR RIGHT THIS IS OUR
LAST OUR LAST HEARING SO I WANT
TO THANK- THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR THEIR PATIENTS FOR-
PROVIDING FEEDBACK AND INPUT
INTO ALL OF THE ALL OF THE
BILLS THIS YEAR. I ALSO WANTED
BIGGER COMMITTEE STAFF AND THE
TEAM THAT THAT YOU KNOW PART OF
THE- COMMITTEE HEARING IN THE
MAKES MAKES IT HAPPEN AND MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYTHING IS. SOUNDS
GOOD AND- AND THAT EVERYONE CAN
BE HEARD AND ALSO WANT TO THINK
THAT JUST THE AUDIENCE FOR IF
YOU CALL IN AND IN THE PATIENTS
WITH US AND- FOR ALL THE
FEEDBACK- SO. THANK YOU MAY
HAVE BEEN REAL QUICK JUST GO
AHEAD THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
IT MEAN INTERRUPT RIGHT I
DIDN'T INTERRUPT IT EXCUSE ME
FOR INTERRUPTING. I JUST WANT
TO SAY TO THE CHAIR A JOB-
CHAIRING THIS COMMITTEE IT WE
DO A LOT OF HARD ISSUES AND-
YOU KNOW. I THINK THAT YOU
MANAGE THE COMEDIANS SUCH A WAY
THAT ALL OF THE DEBATE WAS
PROPERLY HEARD AND TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION SO I THANK YOU
FOR THAT. AGAIN TO THE STAFF.
WHO'VE DONE A GREAT JOB I KNOW
THAT THE TELECONFERENCING IS
NOT ALWAYS EASY. BUT IT SEEMS
LIKE THIS COMMITTEE HAS HANDLED
THAT- IN A TOP NOTCH FASHION SO
I APPRECIATE THAT. AND LOOK
FORWARD TO SERVING WITH YOU
AGAIN. MAYBE NEXT YEAR THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
LIKEWISE SEND. AND THANK YOU
FOR CALLING LONGER AND SENATOR
CORTESE AND- SENATOR PANNED AND-
HOLD ON TO THE CLOSING REMARKS
THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF
YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY THE OFFICIAL HEARING
RECORDS. THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
THANK YOU FOR. EVERYONE FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND COOPERATION
WE HAVE CONCLUDED THAT THE
AGENDA THE SALMON THE SENATE.
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE IS NOW
ADJOURNED.